sci-fi movies and books depict a future
with sentient machines capable of
interacting with humans and performing
tasks just like people would
what if we told you that this future is
already a reality all of this is already
made possible by machine learning
machine learning is the science of
programming machines to think and act
like humans without being specifically
programmed to we already use machine
learning in our daily life without
knowing it email spam recognition spell
check even the youtube video
recommendation which brought you here
are implemented using machine learning
machine learning uses algorithms to
learn tasks these algorithms are fed
with data from which they learn to
perform these tasks this means that over
time as changes in data occur we don't
need to reprogram our application just
let it find patterns and learn from the
new data
machine learning is a subset of
artificial intelligence which is a
science concern with imparting
human-like intelligence onto machines
and creating machines which can sense
reason act and adapt
deep learning is a sub-branch of machine
learning which is inspired by the
working of the human brain
machine learning is leading us to a
future where machines can learn and
think and has opened us a whole new
plethora of job opportunities
this was a brief intro to machine
learning machine learning is one of the
top technologies of the 21st century
it has brought in a revolution in the
business sectors hello everyone welcome
to this full course video on machine
learning this video will help you
understand all the concepts and give you
ample hands-on experience building
machine learning models we have our
experienced instructors who will take
you through this course
first
you will learn the basics of machine
learning and jump into understanding the
various machine learning algorithms
you will learn about linear regression
logistic regression decision trees
support vector machines and many more
then you will look at reinforcement
learning and understand mathematics for
machine learning you will learn the
concepts such as principal component
analysis regularization and feature
selection
finally you will perform your selection
prediction analysis and understand the
machine learning roadmap for 2021 so
let's begin with a short animated video
on machine learning we know humans learn
from their past experiences
and machines follow instructions given
by humans
but what if humans can train the
machines to learn from their past data
and do what humans can do and much
faster well that's called machine
learning but it's a lot more than just
learning it's also about understanding
and reasoning so today we will learn
about the basics of machine learning
so that's paul he loves listening to new
songs
he either likes them or dislikes them
paul decides this on the basis of the
song's tempo
genre
intensity
and the gender of voice for simplicity
let's just use tempo and intensity for
now so here tempo is on the x-axis
ranging from relaxed to fast whereas
intensity is on the y-axis ranging from
light to soaring we see that paul likes
the song with fast tempo and soaring
intensity while he dislikes the song
with relaxed tempo and light intensity
so now we know paul's choices let's say
paul listens to a new song let's name it
as song a song a has fast tempo and a
soaring intensity so it lies somewhere
here looking at the data can you guess
whether paul will like the song or not
correct so paul likes this song by
looking at paul's past choices we were
able to classify the unknown song very
easily right let's say now paul listens
to a new song let's label it as song b
so song b
lies somewhere here with medium tempo
and medium intensity neither relaxed nor
fast neither light nor soaring now can
you guess whether paul likes it or not
not able to guess whether paul will like
it or dislike it are the choices unclear
correct we could easily classify song a
but when the choice became complicated
as in the case of song b yes and that's
where machine learning comes in let's
see how in the same example for song b
if we draw a circle around the song b we
see that there are four votes for like
whereas one would for dislike if we go
for the majority votes we can say that
paul will definitely like the song
that's all this was a basic machine
learning algorithm also it's called k
nearest neighbors so this is just a
small example in one of the many machine
learning algorithms quite easy right
believe me it is but what happens when
the choices become complicated as in the
case of song b that's when machine
learning comes in it learns the data
builds the prediction model and when the
new data point comes in it can easily
predict for it more the data better the
model higher will be the accuracy there
are many ways in which the machine
learns it could be either supervised
learning unsupervised learning or
reinforcement learning let's first
quickly understand supervised learning
suppose your friend gives you one
million coins of three different
currencies say one rupee one euro and
one dirham each coin has different
weights for example a coin of one rupee
weighs three grams one euro weighs seven
grams and one dirham weighs four grams
your model will predict the currency of
the coin here your weight becomes the
feature of coins while currency becomes
the label when you feed this data to the
machine learning model it learns which
feature is associated with which label
for example it will learn that if a coin
is of 3 grams it will be a 1 rupee coin
let's give a new coin to the machine on
the basis of the weight of the new coin
your model will predict the currency
hence supervised learning uses labeled
data to train the model here the machine
knew the features of the object and also
the labels associated with those
features on this note let's move to
unsupervised learning and see the
difference suppose you have cricket data
set of various players with their
respective scores and wickets taken when
you feed this data set to the machine
the machine identifies the pattern of
player performance so it plots this data
with the respective wickets on the
x-axis while runs on the y-axis while
looking at the data you will clearly see
that there are two clusters the one
cluster are the players who scored
higher runs and took less wickets while
the other cluster is of the players who
scored less runs but took many wickets
so here we interpret these two clusters
as batsmen and bowlers the important
point to note here is that there were no
labels of batsmen and bowlers hence the
learning with unlabeled data is
unsupervised learning so we saw
supervised learning where the data was
labeled and the unsupervised learning
where the data was unlabeled and then
there is reinforcement learning which is
reward based learning or we can say that
it works on the principle of feedback
here let's say you provide the system
with an image of a dog and ask it to
identify it the system identifies it as
a cat so you give a negative feedback to
the machine saying that it's a dog's
image the machine will learn from the
feedback and finally if it comes across
any other image of a dog it will be able
to classify it correctly that is
reinforcement learning to generalize
machine learning model let's see a
flowchart input is given to a machine
learning model which then gives the
output according to the algorithm
applied if it's right we take the output
as a final result else we provide
feedback to the training model and ask
it to predict until it learns i hope
you've understood supervised and
unsupervised learning so let's have a
quick quiz you have to determine whether
the given scenarios uses supervised or
unsupervised learning simple right
scenario one facebook recognizes your
friend in a picture from an album of
tagged photographs
scenario two netflix recommends new
movies based on someone's past movie
choices
scenario 3 analyzing bank data for
suspicious transactions and flagging the
fraud transactions think wisely and
comment below your answers moving on
don't you sometimes wonder how is
machine learning possible in today's era
well that's because today we have
humongous data available everybody is
online either making a transaction or
just surfing the internet and that's
generating a huge amount of data every
minute and that data my friend is the
key to analysis also the memory handling
capabilities of computers have largely
increased which helps them to process
such huge amount of data at hand without
any delay and yes computers now have
great computational powers so there are
a lot of applications of machine
learning out there to name a few machine
learning is used in healthcare where
diagnostics are predicted for doctor's
review the sentiment analysis that the
tech giants are doing on social media is
another interesting application of
machine learning fraud detection in the
finance sector and also to predict
customer churn in the e-commerce sector
while booking a gap you must have
encountered surge pricing often where it
says the fear of your trip has been
updated continue booking yes please i'm
getting late for office well that's an
interesting machine learning model which
is used by global taxi giant uber and
others where they have differential
pricing in real time based on demand the
number of cars available bad weather
rush r etc so they use the surge pricing
model to ensure that those who need a
cab can get one also it uses predictive
modeling to predict where the demand
will be high with a goal that drivers
can take care of the demand and search
pricing can be minimized great hey siri
can you remind me to book a cab at 6 00
pm today okay i'll remind you thanks no
problem comment below some interesting
everyday examples around you where
machines are learning and doing amazing
jobs so that's all for machine learning
basics today from my site what is
machine learning hello my name is
richard kirchner i'm with the simply
learn team that's www.simplylearn.com
get certified get ahead today we're
covering what is machine learning what's
in it for you we're going to cover the
basics of machine learning what is
machine learning artificial intelligence
versus machine learning versus deep
learning how does machine learning work
types of machine learning machine
learning pre-requisites applications of
machine learning
here we have our
looks a little bit like frankenstein our
frankenstein looking robot today let me
tell you what is machine learning
machine learning works on the
development of computer programs that
can access data and use it to
automatically learn and improve from
experience watch a robot builder
construct a house in two days this was
back in july 29th
2016 so that's pretty impressive this
amount of time to continue to grow in
his development and it's smart enough to
leave spaces in the brickwork for wiring
and plumbing and can even cut and shape
bricks to size
amazon echo relies on machine learning
and with more data it becomes more
accurate play your favorite music order
pizza from domino's voice control your
home request rides from uber have you
ever wondered the difference between ai
machine learning and deep learning
artificial intelligence a technique
which enables machines to mimic human
behavior this is really important
because this is how we are able to gauge
how well our computations or what we're
working on works is the fact that we're
mimicking human behavior we're using
this to replace human work and make it
more efficient and make it more
streamlined and more accurate and so the
center of artificial intelligence is the
big picture of all this put together ibm
deep blue chess electronic game
characters those are just a couple
examples of artificial intelligence
machine learning a technique which uses
statistical methods enabling machines to
learn from their past data so this means
if you have your input from last time
and you have your answer you use that to
help prove the next guess it makes for
the correct answer ibf watson google
search algorithm email spam filters
these are all part of machine learning
and then deep learning which is a subset
of machine learning composing algorithms
that allow a model to train itself and
perform tasks
alpha natural speech recognition these
are a couple examples deep learning is
associated with tools like neural
networks where it's kind of a black box
as it learns it changes all these things
that are as a human we'd have a very
hard time tracking and it's able to come
up with an answer from that now let's
see how machine learning works
first we start with training the data
once we've trained the data the train we
go into the machine learning algorithm
which then puts the data into a
processing which then goes down to
machine another machine learning
algorithm and then we take new data
because you have to test whatever you
did to make sure it works correctly and
we put that into the same algorithm once
we do that we check our prediction we
check our results and from the
prediction if we've set aside some
training date and we find out it didn't
do a good job predicting it and it gets
a thumbs down as you see then we go back
to the beginning and we retrain the
algorithm and a lot of times it's not
just about getting the wrong answer it's
about continually trying to get a better
answer so you'll see the first time you
might be like oh this is not the answer
i want depending on what domain you're
working in whether it's medical
economical business stocks whatever you
try out your model and if it's not
giving you a good answer you retrain it
if you think you can get a better answer
you retrain it and you keep doing that
until you get the best answer you can
let's see the types of machine learning
supervised learning unsupervised
learning there's a number of ways to
divide up machine learning and how it
works these are two main categories you
can divide it into supervised learning
we have a known amount of data so in
this case we have a bunch of apples we
have a machine learning algorithm it
goes through the process it goes through
and trains a model based on that known
data and then once you've trained your
model on the known stuff you can then
put an unknown data in there and you get
a new response and of course in this
particular one it's an apple so it's
trying to figure out whether it's an
apple or another fruit there are many
different algorithms you can use for
computing this information for doing
this supervised training just to list
the some of the top ones that are
currently being used and by no means not
there's more than just this so by no
means this isn't the complete list
there's polynomial regression there's a
random forest there's linear regression
there's logistic regression there's
decision trees there's k nearest
neighbors and there's naive bayes like i
said this is just a short list of some
of the many tools that are out there
nowadays and if you have supervised
learning then we should also look at
unsupervised learning unsupervised
learning so we have unknown data in this
case you can see we have a bunch of
fruit and we might not have labeled it
we don't know we've never had anybody
look at it and say this is what this is
and we take that data and we put it
through the machine learning algorithm
and then that goes through the
processing and then the trained model
and what the trained model says hey can
i see a pattern here and from that
pattern it divides it up into a response
in this case apples and pairs you can
see some of these things look just like
the other and it tries to put them all
together so that you get similar things
in similar groups and again we have a
nice list of algorithms here and this is
not the only algorithms used for this so
don't limit yourself to this just these
these are just some of the primary ones
used today and of course we have the
k-means clustering singular value
decomposition fuzzy means partial least
squares a priori hierarchical clustering
principle component analysis
machine learning prerequisites computer
science fundamentals and programming so
any of the machine learning out today
you have to know some basic scripting or
programming intermediate statistical
knowledge you have to understand a
little bit about probabilities if a is
current how likely is b going to happen
if there's clouds overhead how likely is
it going to rain
linear algebra and intermediate calculus
the linear algebra is very important
because you have to understand basically
drawing a line through the data points
and what that means that's the most
fundamental linear regression models you
draw a line through all your data and
you use that line to compute new values
intermediate calculus means you need to
have a little bit of understanding of
what a differential equation is you
really don't need to be an expert
because the computer does all the heavy
lifting for you but it's important to
know the terms when they come up unless
you're doing some advanced programming
on the actual models themselves and data
wrangling and cleaning i would say this
might be the biggest one in here is you
have to start getting a grip on how to
clean up your data there's a saying is
bad data in bad data out good data in
you're more likely to have good data out
some applications of machine learning
instance segmentation object detection
instant segmentation you can see here
where they use machine learning to go in
there and find where the different cats
are and the different objects are in the
picture and then in segmentation it
actually cuts them out kind of a fun one
especially if you have a google pixel
phone and you can do little animation
objects on top of your ongoing pictures
you're taking or movies
number plate detection you can see here
where we have a card it comes in there
and it finds a number plate on the car
once it's done that it can then do
automatic translation automatic
translation is we pick up some symbols
in this case on a machine and it does
machine translation so that you can know
what it's saying even if you don't speak
that language let's look at another
example machine learning based on the
amount of rainfall how much would be the
crop yield so we here we have our crops
we have our rainfall and we want to know
how much we're going to get from our
crops this year so we're going to
introduce two variables independent and
dependent the independent variable is a
variable whose value does not change by
the effect of other variables and is
used to manipulate the dependent
variable it is often denoted as x in our
example rainfall is the independent
variable this is a wonderful example
because you can easily see that we can't
control the rain but the rain does
control the crop so we talk about the
independent variable controlling the
dependent variable let's define
dependent variable as a variable whose
value change when there is any
manipulation the values of the
independent variables it is often
denoted as y and you can see here our
crop yield is dependent variable and it
is dependent on the amount of rainfall
received now that we've taken a look at
a real life example let's go a little
bit into the theory and some definitions
on machine learning and see how that
fits together with linear regression
numerical and categorical values let's
take our data
coming in this is kind of random data
from any kind of project we want to
divide it up into numerical and
categorical so numerical is numbers age
salary height where categorical would be
a description the color a dog's breed
gender categoricals limited to very
specific items where numerical is a
range of information now that you've
seen the difference between numerical
and categorical data let's take a look
at some different machine learning
definitions we look at our different
machine learning algorithms we can
divide them into three areas supervised
unsupervised reinforcement we're only
going to look at supervised today
unsupervised means we don't have the
answers we're just grouping things
reinforcement is where we give positive
and negative feedback to our algorithm
to program it and it doesn't have the
information until after the fact but
today we're just looking at supervised
because that's where linear regression
fits in in supervised data we have our
data already there and our answers for a
group and then we use that to program
our model and come up with an answer the
two most common uses for that is through
the regression and classification now
we're doing linear regression so we're
just going to focus on the regression
side and in the regression we have
simple linear regression we have
multiple linear regression and we have
polynomial linear regression now on
these three simple linear regression is
the examples we've looked at so far we
have a lot of data and we draw a
straight line through it multiple linear
regression means we have multiple
variables remember where we had the
rainfall and the crops we might add
additional variables in there like how
much food do we give our crops when do
we harvest them those would be
additional information add in to our
model and that's why we multiple linear
regression and finally we have
polynomial linear regression that is
instead of drawing a line we can draw a
curved line through it now that you see
where regression model fits into the
machine learning algorithms and we're
specifically looking at linear
regression let's go ahead and take a
look at applications for linear
regression let's look at a few
applications of linear regression
economic growth used to determine the
economic growth of a country or a state
in the coming quarter can also be used
to predict the gdp of a country product
price can be used to predict what would
be the price of a product in the future
we can guess whether it's going to go up
or down or should i buy today housing
sales to estimate the number of houses a
builder would sell and what price in the
coming months score predictions cricket
fever to predict the number of runs a
player would score in the coming matches
based on the previous performance i'm
sure you can figure out other
applications you could use linear
regression for so let's jump in and
let's understand linear regression and
dig into the theory
understanding linear regression
linear regression is the statistical
model used to predict the relationship
between independent and dependent
variables by examining two factors
the first important one is which
variables in particular are significant
predictors of the outcome variable and
the second one that we need to look at
closely is how significant is the
regression line to make predictions with
the highest possible accuracy if it's
inaccurate we can't use it so it's very
important we find out the most accurate
line we can get since linear regression
is based on drawing a line through data
we're going to jump back and take a look
at some euclidean geometry the simplest
form of a simple linear regression
equation with one dependent and one
independent variable is represented by y
equals
m times x plus c and if you look at our
model here we plotted two points on here
x1 and y1 x2 and y2
y being the dependent variable remember
that from before and x being the
independent variable so y depends on
whatever x is m in this case is the
slope of the line where m equals the
difference in the y 2 minus y 1 and x 2
minus x 1. and finally we have c which
is the coefficient of the line
or where it happens to cross the zero
axes
let's go back and look at an example we
used earlier of linear regression we're
going to go back to plotting the amount
of crop yield based on the amount of
rainfall and here we have our rainfall
remember we cannot change rainfall and
we have our crop yield which is
dependent on the rainfall so we have our
independent and our dependent variables
we're going to take this and draw a line
through it as best we can through the
middle of the data and then we look at
that we put the red point on the y axis
is the amount of crop yield you can
expect for the amount of rainfall
represented by the green dot so if we
have an idea what the rainfall is for
this year and what's going on we can
guess how good our crops are going to be
and we've created a nice line right
through the middle to give us a nice
mathematical formula let's take a look
and see what the math looks like behind
this
let's look at the intuition behind the
regression line now before we dive into
the math and the formulas that go behind
this and what's going on behind the
scenes
i want you to note that when we get into
the case study and we actually apply
some python script that this math you're
going to see here is already done
automatically for you you don't have to
have it memorized it is however good to
have an idea what's going on so if
people reference the different terms
you'll know what they're talking about
let's consider a sample data set with
five rows and find out how to draw the
regression line we're only going to do
five rows because if we did like the
rainfall with hundreds of points of data
that would be very hard to see what's
going on with the mathematics so we'll
go ahead and create our own two sets of
data and we have our independent
variable x and our dependent variable y
and when x was 1 we got y equals 2 when
x was
2 y was 4 and so on and so on if we go
ahead and plot this data on a graph we
can see how it forms a nice line through
the middle you can see where it's kind
of grouped going upwards to the right
the next thing we want to know is what
the means is of each of the data coming
in the x and the y the means doesn't
mean anything other than the average so
we add up all the numbers and divide by
the total so 1 plus 2 plus 3 plus 4 plus
5 over 5 equals 3 and the same for y we
get 4. if we go ahead and plot the means
on the graph we'll see we get 3 comma 4
which draws a nice line down the middle
a good estimate
here we're going to dig deeper into the
math behind the regression line now
remember before i said you don't have to
have all these formulas memorized or
fully understand them even though we're
going to go into a little more detail of
how it works and if you're not a math
wiz and you don't know if you've never
seen the sigma character before which
looks a little bit like an e that's
opened up that just means summation
that's all that is so when you see the
sigma character it just means we're
adding everything in that row and for
computers this is great because as a
programmer you can easily iterate
through each of the x y points and
create all the information you need so
in the top half you can see where we've
broken that down into pieces and as it
goes through the first two points it
computes the squared value of x the
squared value of y and x times y and
then it takes all of x and adds them up
all of y adds them up all of x squared
adds them up and so on and so on and you
can see we have the sum of equal to 15
the sum is equal to 20 all the way up to
x times y where the sum equals 66. this
all comes from our formula for
calculating a straight line where y
equals the slope times x plus the
coefficient c so we go down below and
we're going to compute more like the
averages of these and we'll explain
exactly what that is in just a minute
and where that information comes from is
called the square means error but we'll
go into that in detail in a few minutes
all you need to do is look at the
formula and see how we've gone about
computing it line by line instead of
trying to have a huge set of numbers
pushed into it and down here you'll see
where the slope m equals and then the
top part if you read through the
brackets you have the number of data
points times the sum
of x times y which we computed one line
at a time there and that's just the 66
and take all that and you subtract it
from the sum of x times the sum of y and
those have both been computed so you
have 15 times 20. and on the bottom we
have the number of lines times the sum
of x squared easily computed as 86 for
the sum minus i'll take all that and
subtract the sum of x squared and we end
up as we come across with our formula
you can plug in all those numbers which
is very easy to do on the computer you
don't have to do the math on a piece of
paper or calculator and you'll get a
slope of 0.6 and you'll get your c
coefficient if you continue to follow
through that formula you'll see it comes
out as equal to 2.2 continuing deeper
into what's going behind the scenes
let's find out the predicted values of y
for corresponding values of x using the
linear equation where m equals 0.6 and c
equals 2.2 we're going to take these
values
and we're going to go ahead and plot
them we're going to predict them so y
equals 0.6 times where x equals 1 plus
2.2 equals 2.8 so on and so on and here
the blue points represent the actual y
values and the brown points represent
the predicted y values based on the
model we created the distance between
the actual and predicted values is known
as residuals or errors
the best fit lines should have the least
sum of squares of these errors also
known as e-square if we put these into a
nice chart where you can see x
and you can see y what we actual values
were and you can see why i predict it
you can easily see where we take y minus
y predict it and we get an answer what
is the difference between those two and
if we square that y minus y prediction
squared we can then sum those squared
values that's where we get the 0.64 plus
the 0.36 plus 1 all the way down until
we have a summation equals 2.4 so the
sum of squared errors for this
regression line is 2.4 we check this
error for each line and conclude the
best fit line having the least e square
value in a nice graphical representation
we can see here where we keep moving
this line through the data points to
make sure the best fit line has the
least square distance between the data
points and the regression line now we
only looked at the most commonly used
formula for minimizing the distance
there are lots of ways to minimize the
distance between the line and the data
points like sum of squared errors sum of
absolute errors root mean square error
etc what you want to take away from this
is whatever formula is being used you
can easily using a computer programming
and iterating through the data calculate
the different parts of it that way these
complicated formulas you see with the
different summations and absolute values
are easily computed one piece at a time
up until this point we've only been
looking at two values x and y well in
the real world it's very rare that you
only have two values when you're
figuring out a solution so let's move on
to the next topic multiple linear
regression let's take a brief look at
what happens when you have multiple
inputs so in multiple linear regression
we have well we'll start with the simple
linear regression where we had y equals
m plus x plus c and we're trying to find
the value of y now with multiple linear
regression we have multiple variables
coming in so instead of having just x we
have x1 x2 x3 and instead of having just
one slope each variable has its own
slope attached to it as you can see here
we have m1 m2 m3 and we still just have
the single coefficient so when you're
dealing with multiple linear regression
you basically take your single linear
regression and you spread it out so you
have y equals m1 times x1 plus m2 times
x2
so on all the way to m to the nth x to
the nth and then you add your
coefficient on there implementation of
linear regression now we get into my
favorite part let's understand how
multiple linear regression works by
implementing it in python if you
remember before we were looking at a
company and just based on its rnd trying
to figure out its profit we're going to
start looking at the expenditure of the
company we're going to go back to that
we're going to predict his profit but
instead of predicting it just on the r d
we're going to look at other factors
like administration costs marketing
costs and so on and from there we're
going to see if we can figure out what
the profit of that company is going to
be to start our coding we're going to
begin by importing some basic libraries
and we're going to be looking through
the data before we do any kind of linear
regression we're going to take a look at
the data to see what we're playing with
then we'll go ahead and format the data
to the format we need to be able to run
it in the linear regression model and
then from there we'll go ahead and solve
it and just see how valid our solution
is so let's start with importing the
basic libraries now i'm going to be
doing this in anaconda jupiter notebook
a very popular ide i enjoy it's such a
visual to look at and so easy to use
just any id for python will work just
fine for this so break out your favorite
python ide so here we are in our jupiter
notebook let me go ahead and paste our
first piece of code in there and let's
walk through what libraries we're
importing first we're going to import
numpy as np and then i want you to skip
one line and look at import pandas as pd
these are very common tools that you
need with most of your linear regression
the numpy which stands for number python
is usually denoted as np and you have to
almost have that for your sk learn
toolbox you always import that right off
the beginning pandas although you don't
have to have it for your sklearn
libraries it does such a wonderful job
of importing data setting it up into a
data frame so we can manipulate it
rather easily and it has a lot of tools
also in addition to that so we usually
like to use the pandas when we can and
i'll show you what that looks like the
other three lines are for us to get a
visual of this data and take a look at
it so we're going to import
matplotlibrary.pipelot as plt and then
seaborn as sns seaborn works with the
matplot library so you have to always
import matplot library and then seaborn
sits on top of it and we'll take a look
at what that looks like you could use
any of your own plotting libraries you
want there's all kinds of ways to look
at the data these are just very common
ones and the seaborne is so easy to use
it just looks beautiful it's a nice
representation that you can actually
take and show somebody and the final
line is the amber signed matte plot
library inline that is only because i'm
doing an inline ide my interface in the
anaconda jupiter notebook requires i put
that in there or you're not going to see
the graph when it comes up let's go
ahead and run this it's not going to be
that interesting so we're just setting
up variables in fact it's not going to
do anything that we can see but it is
importing these different libraries and
setup the next step is load the data set
and extract independent and dependent
variables now here in the slide you'll
see companies equals pd.read csv and it
has a long line there with the file at
the end 1000 companies dot csv you're
going to have to change this to fit
whatever setup you have and the file
itself you can request just go down to
the commentary below this video and put
a note in there and simply learn we'll
try to get in contact with you and
supply you with that file so you can try
this coding yourself so we're going to
add this code in here and we're going to
see that i have companies equals
pd.reader underscore csv and i've
changed this path to match my computer c
slash simply learn slash 1000 underscore
companies dot csv and then below there
we're going to set the x equals to
companies under the i location and
because this is companies as a pd data
set i can use this nice notation that
says take every row that's what the
colon the first colon is comma except
for the last column that's what the
second part is where we have a colon
minus one and we want the values set
into there so x is no longer a data set
a pandas data set but we can easily
extract the data from our pandas data
set with this notation and then y we're
going to set equal to the last row well
the question is going to be what are we
actually looking at so let's go ahead
and take a look at that and we're going
to look at the companies dot head which
lists the first five rows of data and
i'll open up the file in just a second
so you can see where that's coming from
but let's look at the data in here as
far as the way the pandas sees it when i
hit run you'll see it breaks it out into
a nice setup this is what panda's one of
the things pandas is really good about
is it looks just like an excel
spreadsheet you have your rows and
remember when we're programming we
always start with zero we don't start
with one so it shows the first five rows
zero one two three four and then it
shows your different columns r d spend
administration marketing spend state
profit it even notes that the top are
column names it was never told that but
pandas is able to recognize a lot of
things that they're not the same as the
data rows why don't we go ahead and open
this file up in a csv so you can
actually see the raw data so here i've
opened it up as a text editor and you
can see at the top we have rnd spend
comma administration comma marketing
spin comma state comma profit carries
return i don't know about you but i'd go
crazy trying to read files like this
that's why we use the pandas you could
also open this up in an excel and it
would separate it since it is a comma
separated variable file but we don't
want to look at this one we want to look
at something we can read rather easily
so let's flip back and take a look at
that top part the first five row now as
nice as this format is where i can see
the data to me it doesn't mean a whole
lot maybe you're an expert in business
and investments and you understand what
uh 165 349 dollars and 20 cents compared
to the administration cost of a hundred
and thirty six thousand eight hundred
ninety seven dollars and eighty cents so
on so on helps to create the profit of a
hundred ninety 192 261 and 83 cents that
makes no sense to me whatsoever no pun
intended so let's flip back here and
take a look at our next set of code
where we're going to graph it so we can
get a better understanding of our data
and what it means so at this point we're
going to use a single line of code to
get a lot of information so we can see
where we're going with this let's go
ahead and paste that into our notebook
and see what we got going and so we have
the visualization and again we're using
sns which is pandas
as you can see we imported the map plot
library dot pi plot as plt which then
the seaborn uses and we imported the
seaborn as sns and then that final line
of code helps us show this in our inline
coding without this it wouldn't display
and you could display it to a file in
other means and that's the matplot
library in line with the amber sign at
the beginning so here we come down to
the single line of code seaborn is great
because it actually recognizes the panda
data frame so i can just take the
companies dot core for coordinates and i
can put that right into the seaborn and
when we run this we get this beautiful
plot and let's just take a look at what
this plot means if you look at this plot
on mine the colors are probably a little
bit more purplish and blue than the
original one we have the columns and the
rows we have r and d spending we have
administration we have marketing
spending and profit and if you cross
index any two of these since we're
interested in profit if you cross index
profit with profit it's going to show up
if you look at the scale on the right
way up in the dark why because those are
the same data they have an exact
correspondence so r d spending is going
to be the same as r d spending and the
same thing with administration costs
right down the middle you get this dark
row or dark um diagonal row that shows
that this is the highest corresponding
data that's exactly the same and as it
becomes lighter there's less connections
between the data so we can see with
profit obviously profit is the same as
profit and next it has a very high
correlation with r d spending which we
looked at earlier and it has a slightly
less connection to marketing spending
and even less to how much money we put
into the administration so now that we
have a nice look at the data let's go
ahead and dig in and create some actual
useful linear regression models so that
we can predict values and have a better
profit now that we've taken a look at
the visualization of this data we're
going to move on to the next step
instead of just having a pretty picture
we need to generate some hard data some
hard values so let's see what that looks
like we're going to set up our linear
regression model in two steps the first
one is we need to prepare some of our
data so it fits correctly and let's go
ahead and paste this code into our
jupyter notebook and what we're bringing
in is we're going to bring in the
sklearn pre-processing where we're going
to import the label encoder and the one
hot encoder to use the label encoder
we're going to create a variable called
label encoder and set it equal to
capital l label capital e encoder this
creates a class that we can reuse for
transferring the labels back and forth
now about now you should ask what labels
are we talking about let's go take a
look at the data we processed before and
see what i'm talking about here if you
remember when we did the companies dot
head and we printed the top five rows of
data we have our columns going across we
have column 0 which is r and d spending
column 1 which is administration column
2 which is marketing spending and column
3 is state
and you'll see under state we have new
york california florida now to do a
linear regression model it doesn't know
how to process new york it knows how to
process a number so the first thing
we're going to do is we're going to
change that new york california and
florida and we're going to change those
to numbers that's what this line of code
does here x equals and then it has the
colon comma 3 in brackets the first part
the colon comma means that we're going
to look at all the different rows so
we're going to keep them all together
but the only row we're going to edit is
the third row and in there we're going
to take the label coder and we're going
to fit and transform the x also the
third row so we're going to take that
third row we're going to set it equal to
a transformation and that transformation
basically tells it that instead of
having a new york it has a zero or one
or a two and then finally we need to do
a one hot encoder which equals one hot
inc or categorical features equals three
and then we take the x and we go ahead
and do that equal to one hot encoder fit
transform x to array this final
transformation preps our data force so
it's completely set the way we need it
as just a row of numbers even though
it's not in here let's go ahead and
print x and just take a look what this
data is doing you'll see you have an
array of arrays and then each array is a
row of numbers and if i go ahead and
just do row 0 you'll see i have a nice
organized row of numbers that the
computer now understands we'll go ahead
and take this out there because it
doesn't mean a whole lot to us it's just
a row of numbers
next on setting up our data we have
avoiding dummy variable trap this is
very important why because the computers
automatically transformed our header
into the setup and it's automatically
transformed all these different
variables so when we did the encoder the
encoder created two columns and what we
need to do is just have the one because
it has both the variable and the name
that's what this piece of code does here
let's go ahead and paste this in here
and we have x equals x colon comma one
colon all this is doing is removing that
one extra column we put in there when we
did our one hot encoder and our labeling
coding let's go ahead and run that and
now we get to create our linear
regression model and let's see what that
looks like here and we're going to do
that in two steps the first step is
going to be in splitting the data now
whenever we create a
predictive model of data we always want
to split it up so we have a training set
and we have a testing set that's very
important otherwise we'd be very
unethical without testing it to see how
good our fit is and then we'll go ahead
and create our multiple linear
regression model and train it and set it
up let's go ahead and paste this next
piece of code in here and i'll go ahead
and shrink it down a size or two so it
all fits on one line so from the sklearn
module selection we're going to import
train test split and you'll see that
we've created four completely different
variables we have capital x train
capital x test smaller case y train
smaller case y test
that is the standard way that they
usually reference these when we're doing
different models you usually see that a
capital x and you see the train and the
test and the lower case y what this is
is x is our data going in that's our rnd
spin our administration our marketing
and then why which we're training is the
answer that's the profit because we want
to know the profit of an unknown entity
so that's what we're going to shoot for
in this tutorial the next part train
test split we take x and we take y we've
already created those x has the columns
with the data in it and y has a column
with profit in it and then we're going
to set the test size equals 0.2 that
basically means 20 percent
so 20 percent of the rows are going to
be tested we're going to put them off to
the side so since we're using a thousand
lines of data that means that 200 of
those lines we're going to hold off to
the side to test for later and then the
random state equals zero we're going to
randomize which ones it picks to hold
off to the side we'll go ahead and run
this it's not overly exciting so setting
up our variables but the next step is
the next step we actually create our
linear regression model now that we got
to the linear regression model we get
that next piece of the puzzle let's go
ahead and put that code in there and
walk through it so here we go we're
going to paste it in there and let's go
ahead and since this is a shorter line
of code let's zoom up there so we can
get a good look and we have from the
sklearn dot linear underscore model
we're going to import linear regression
now i don't know if you recall from
earlier when we were doing all the math
let's go ahead and flip back there and
take a look at that do you remember this
where we had this long formula on the
bottom and we were doing all this
summarization and then we also looked at
uh setting it up with the different
lines and then we also looked all the
way down to multiple linear regression
where we're adding all those formulas
together all of that is wrapped up in
this one section so what's going on here
is i'm going to create a variable called
regressor and the regressor equals the
linear regression that's a linear
regression model that has all that math
built in so we don't have to have it all
memorized or have to compute it
individually and then we do the
regressor dot fit in this case we do x
train and y train because we're using
the training data x being the data in
and y being profit we're looking at and
this does all that math for us so within
one click and one line we've created the
whole linear regression model and we fit
the data to the linear regression model
and you can see that when i run the
regressor it gives an output linear
regression it says copy x equals true
fit intercept equals true in jobs equal
one normalize equals false it's just
giving you some general information on
what's going on with that regressor
model now that we've created our linear
regression model let's go ahead and use
it and if you remember we kept a bunch
of data aside so we're going to do a y
predict variable and we're going to put
in the x test and let's see what that
looks like scroll up a little bit paste
that in here predicting the test set
results so here we have y predict equals
regressor dot predict x test going in
and this gives us y predict now because
i'm in jupiter inline i can just put the
variable up there and when i hit the run
button it'll print that array out i
could have just as easily done print
why predict so if you're in a different
ide that's not an inline setup like the
jupiter notebook you can do it this way
print y predict and you'll see that for
the 200 different test variables we kept
off to the side it's going to produce
200 answers this is what it says the
profit are for those 200 predictions but
let's don't stop there let's keep going
and take a couple look we're going to
take just a short detail here and
calculating the coefficients and the
intercepts this gives us a quick flash
at what's going on behind the line we're
going to take a short detour here and
we're going to be calculating the
coefficient and intercepts so you can
see what those look like what's really
nice about our regressor we created is
it already has a coefficients for us we
can simply just print regressor dot
coefficient underscore when i run this
you'll see our coefficients here and if
we can do the regressor coefficient we
can also do the regressor intercept and
let's run that and take a look at that
this all came from the multiple
regression model and we'll flip over so
you can remember where this is going
into where it's coming from you can see
the formula down here where y equals m1
times x1 plus m2 times x2 and so on and
so on plus c the coefficient so these
variables fit right into this formula y
equals slope one times column 1 variable
plus slope 2 times column 2 variable all
the way to the m to the n and x to the n
plus c the coefficient or in this case
you have minus 8.89
to the power of 2 etc etc times the
first column and the second column and
the third column and then our intercept
is the minus 1 0 3 0 0 9 point boy it
gets kind of complicated when you look
at it this is why we don't do this by
hand anymore this is why we have the
computer to make these calculations easy
to understand and calculate now i told
you that was a short detour and we're
coming towards the end of our script as
you remember from the beginning i said
if we're going to divide this
information we have to make sure it's a
valid model that this model works and
understand how good it works so
calculating the r squared value that's
what we're going to use to predict how
good our prediction is and let's take a
look what that looks like in code and so
we're going to use this from
sklearn.metrics we're going to import r2
score that's the r squared value we're
looking at the error so in the r2 score
we take our y test versus our y predict
y test is the actual values we're
testing that was the one that was given
to us that we know are true the y
predict of those 200 values is what we
think it was true and when we go ahead
and run this we see we get a 0.9352
that's the r2 score now it's not exactly
a straight percentage so it's not saying
it's 93 percent correct but you do want
that in the upper 90s o and higher shows
that this is a very valid prediction
based on the r2 score and if r squared
value of 0.91 or 9 2 as we got on our
model remember it does have a random
generation involved this proves the
model is a good model which means
success yay we successfully trained our
model with certain predictors and
estimated the profit of the companies
using linear regression what is logistic
regression as i mentioned earlier
positive regression is an algorithm for
performing binary classification so
let's take an example and see how this
works let's say your car has not been
serviced for quite a few years and now
you want to find out if it is going to
break down in the near future so this is
like a classification problem find out
whether your car will break down or not
so how are we going to perform this
classification so here's how it looks if
we plot the information along the x and
y axis x is the number of years since
the last service was performed and why
is the probability of your car breaking
down and let's say this information was
this data rather was collected from
several car users it's not just your car
but several car users so that is our
labeled data so the data has been
collected
and
for for the number of years and when the
car broke down and what was the
probability and that has been plotted
along x and y axis so this provides an
idea or from this
graph we can find out whether your car
will break down or not we'll see how so
first of all the probability can go from
zero to one as you all aware probability
can be between zero and one and as we
can imagine it is intuitive as well as
the number of years are on the lower
side maybe one year two years or three
years till after the service the chances
of your car breaking down are very
limited right so for example chances of
your car breaking down the probability
of your car breaking down within two
years of your last service are 0.1
probability similarly 3 years is maybe
0.3 and so on but as the number of years
increases let's say if it was six or
seven years there is almost a certainty
that your car is going to break down
that is what this graph shows so this is
an example of a application of the
classification algorithm and we will see
in little details how exactly logistic
regression is applied here one more
thing needs to be added here is that the
dependent variables outcome
is discrete so if we are talking about
whether the car is going to break down
or not so that is a discrete value the
why that we are talking about the
dependent variable that we are talking
about what we are looking at is whether
the car is going to break down or not
yes or no that is what we are talking
about so here the outcome is discrete
and not a continuous value so this is
how the logistic regression curve looks
let me explain a little bit what exactly
how exactly we are going to
determine the class at the outcome
rather so for a logistic regression
curve a threshold has to be said saying
that because this is a probability
calculation remember this is a
probability calculation and the
probability itself will not be zero or
one but based on the probability we need
to decide what the outcome should be so
there has to be a threshold like for
example 0.5 can be the threshold let's
say in this case so any value of the
probability below 0.5 is considered to
be 0 and any value above 0.5 is
considered to be 1. so an output of
let's say 0.8 will mean that the car
will break down so that is considered as
an output of one and let's say
an output of 0.29 is considered as zero
which means that the car will not break
down so that's the way logistic
regression works now let's do a quick
comparison between logistic regression
and linear regression because they both
have the term regression in them so it
can cause confusion so let's try to
remove that confusion so what is linear
regression linear regression is a
process is once again an algorithm for
supervised learning however here you're
going to find a continuous value you're
going to determine a continuous value it
could be the price of a real estate
property it could be your hike how much
hike you're going to get or it could be
a stock price these are all continuous
values these are not discrete compared
to a yes or no kind of a response that
we are looking for in logistic
regression so this is one example of a
linear regression let's say the hr team
of a company tries to find out what
should be the salary hike of an employee
so they collect all the details of their
existing employees their ratings and
their salary hikes what has been given
and that is the labeled information that
is available and the system learns from
this it is trained and it learns from
this labeled information so that when a
new employees information is fed based
on the rating it will determine what
should be the height so this is a linear
regression problem and a linear
regression example now salary is a
continuous value you can get 5 000
hundred
five thousand six hundred it is not
discrete like a cat or a dog or an apple
or a banana these are discrete or a yes
or no these are discrete values right so
this way you are trying to find
continuous values is where we use linear
regression so let's say just to extend
on the scenario we now want to find out
whether this employee is going to get a
promotion or not so we want to find out
that is a discrete problem right a yes
or no kind of a problem in this case we
actually cannot use linear regression
even though we may have labeled data so
this is the label data so based on the
employee rating these are the ratings
and then some people got the promotion
and this is the ratings for which people
did not get promotion that is a no and
this is a rating for which people got
promotion we just plotted the data about
whether a person has got an employer's
got promotion or not yes no right so
there is nothing in between and what is
the employees rating okay and ratings
can be continuous that is not an issue
but the output is discrete in this case
whether employee got promotion yes no
okay so if we try to plot that and we
try to find a straight line this is how
it would look and as you can see it
doesn't look very right because looks
like there will be lot of errors this
root mean square error if you remember
for linear regression would be very very
high and also the the values cannot go
beyond zero or beyond one so the graph
should probably look somewhat like this
clipped at 0 and 1. but still the
straight line doesn't look right
therefore instead of using a linear
equation we need to come up with
something different and therefore the
logistic regression model looks somewhat
like this so we calculate the
probability and if we plot that
probability not in the form of a
straight line but we need to use some
other equation we will see very soon
what that equation is then it is a
gradual process right so you see here
people with some of these ratings are
not getting any promotions and then
slowly uh
at certain rating they get promotion so
that is a gradual process and
this is how the math behind logistic
regression looks so we are trying to
find the odds for a particular event
happening and this is the formula for
finding the odds so the probability of
an event happening divided by the
probability of the event not happening
so p if it is the probability of the
event happening probability of the
person getting a promotion and divided
by the probability of the person not
getting a promotion that is one minus p
so this is how you measure the odds now
the values of the odds range from zero
to infinity so when this probability is
zero then the odds will the value of the
odds is equal to zero and when the
probability becomes one then the value
of the odds is one by zero that will be
infinity but the probability itself
remains between zero and one now this is
how an equation of a straight line looks
so y is equal to beta 0 plus beta 1 x
where beta 0 is the y intercept and beta
1 is the slope of the line if we take
the odds equation and take a log of both
sides then this would look somewhat like
this and the term logistic is actually
derived from the fact that we are doing
this we take a log of dx by 1 minus px
this is an extension of the calculation
of odds that we have seen right and that
is equal to beta0 plus beta1 x which is
the equation of the straight line and
now from here if you want to find out
the value of px you will see we can take
the exponential on both sides and then
if we solve that equation we will get
the equation of p x like this p x is
equal to 1 by 1 plus e to the power of
minus beta0 plus beta 1 x and recall
this is nothing but the equation of the
line which is equal to y y is equal to
beta 0 plus beta 1 x so that this is the
equation also known as the sigmoid
function and this is the equation of the
logistic regression all right and if
this is plotted this is how the sigmoid
curve is obtained
so let's compare linear and logistic
regression how they are different from
each other let's go back so linear
regression is solved or used to solve
regression problems and logistic
regression is used to solve
classification problems so both are
called regression but linear regression
is used for solving regression problems
where we predict continuous values
whereas logistic regression is used for
solving classification problems where we
have had to predict discrete values the
response variables in case of linear
regression are continuous in nature
whereas here they are categorical or
discrete in nature and
linear regression helps to estimate the
dependent variable when there is a
change in the independent variable
whereas here in case of logistic
regression it helps to calculate the
probability or the possibility of a
particular event happening and linear
regression as the name suggests is a
straight line that's why it's called
linear regression whereas logistic
regression is a sigmoid function and the
curve is the shape of the curve is s
it's an s-shaped curve this is another
example of application of logistic
regression in weather prediction whether
it's going to rain or not rain now keep
in mind both are used in weather
prediction if we want to find the
discrete values like whether it's going
to rain or not rain that is a
classification problem we use logistic
regression but if we want to determine
what is going to be the temperature
tomorrow then we use linear regression
so just keep in mind that in weather
prediction we actually use both but
these are some examples of logistic
regression so we want to find out
whether it's going to be rain or not
it's going to be sunny or not it's going
to snow or not these are all logistic
regression examples a few more examples
classification of objects this is a
again another example of logistic
regression now here of course one
distinction is that these are
multi-class classification so logistic
regression is not used in its original
form but it is used in a slightly
different form so we say whether it is a
dog or not a dog i hope you understand
so instead of saying is it a dog or a
cat or an elephant we convert this into
saying so because we need to keep it to
binary classification so we say is it a
dog or not a dog is it a cat or not a
cat so that's the way logistic
regression can be used for classifying
objects otherwise there are other
techniques which can be used for
performing multi-class classification in
healthcare logistic regression is used
to find the survival rate of a patient
so they take multiple parameters like
trauma score and age and so on and so
forth and they try to predict the rate
of survival
all right now finally let's take an
example and see how we can apply
logistic regression to predict the
number that is shown in the image so
this is actually a live demo i will take
you into jupiter notebook and
show the code but before that let me
take you through a couple of slides to
explain what we are trying to do so
let's say you have an eight by eight
image and there the image has a number
one two three four and you need to train
your model to predict what this number
is so
how do we do this so the first thing is
obviously in any machine learning
process you train your model so in this
case we are using logistic regression so
and then we provide a training set to
train the model and then we test how
accurate our model is with the test data
which means that like any machine
learning process we split our initial
data into two parts training set and
test set with the training set we train
our model and then with the test set we
test the model then we get good accuracy
and then we use it for for inference
right so that is typical methodology of
uh
training testing and then deploying of
machine learning models so let's uh take
a look at the code and see what we are
doing so i will not go line by line but
just take you through some of the blocks
so first thing we do is import all the
libraries and then we basically take a
look at the images and see what is the
total number of images we can display
using matplotlib some of the images are
a sample of these images and
then we split the data into training and
test as i mentioned earlier
and we can do some exploratory analysis
and then we build our model we train our
model with the training set and then we
test it with our test set and find out
how accurate our model is using the
confusion matrix the heat map and use
heat map for visualizing this and i will
show you in the code what exactly is the
confusion matrix and how it can be used
for finding the accuracy in our example
we got we get an accuracy of about 0.94
which is pretty good or 94 which is
pretty good all right so what is the
confusion matrix this is an example of a
confusion matrix and
this is used for identifying the
accuracy of a
classification model or like a logistic
regression model so the most important
part in a confusion matrix is that first
of all this as you can see this is a
matrix and the size of the matrix
depends on how many outputs we are
expecting right so
the most important part here is that the
model will be most accurate when we have
the maximum numbers in its diagonal like
in this case that's why it has almost 93
94 because the diagonals should have the
maximum numbers and the others other
than diagonals the cells other than the
diagonals should have very few numbers
so here that's what is happening so
there is a 2 here there are there is a
one here but most of them are along the
diagonal this what does this mean this
means that the
number that has been fed is zero and the
number that has been detected is also
zero so the predicted value and the
actual value are the same so along the
diagonals that is true which means that
let's let's take this diagonal right if
the maximum number is here that means
that like here in this case it is 34
which means that 34 of the images that
have been fed or rather actually there
are two misclassifications in there so
36 images have been fed which have
number four and out of which 34 have
been predicted correctly as number four
and one has been predicted as number
eight and another one has been predicted
as number nine so these are two
misclassifications okay so that is the
meaning of saying that the maximum
number should be in the diagonal so if
you have all of them so for an ideal
model which has let's say 100 accuracy
everything will be only in the diagonal
there will be no numbers other than zero
in all other cells so that is like a
hundred percent accurate model okay so
that's uh just of how to use this matrix
uh how to use this uh confusion matrix i
know the name uh is a little funny
sounding confusion matrix but actually
it is not very confusing it's very
straightforward so you are just plotting
what has been predicted and what is the
labeled information or what is the
actual data that's also known as the
ground truth sometimes okay these are
some fancy terms that are used so
predicted label and the actual name
that's all it is okay yeah so we are
showing a little bit more information
here so 38 have been predicted and here
you will see that all of them have been
predicted correctly there have been 38
zeros and the predicted value and the
actual value is is exactly the same
whereas in this case
right it has there are i think 37 plus
five yeah 42 have been fed the images 42
images are of digit 3 and
the accuracy is only 37 of them have
been accurately predicted three of them
have been predicted as number seven and
two of them have been predicted as
number eight and so on and so forth okay
all right so with that let's go into
jupiter notebook and see how the code
looks so this is the code in
in jupiter notebook for logistic
regression in this particular demo what
we are going to do is train our model to
recognize digits
which are the images which have digits
from let's say 0 to 5 or 0 to 9 and
and then we will see how well it is
trained and whether it is able to
predict these numbers correctly or not
so let's get started so the first part
is as usual we are importing some
libraries that are required and
then the last line in this block is to
load the digits so let's go ahead and
run this code then
here we will visualize the shape of
these digits so we can see here if we
take a look this is how the shape is
by 64. these are like eight by eight
images so that's that's what is
reflected in this shape now from here
onwards we are basically once again
importing some of the libraries that are
required like numpy and matplot and we
will take a look at
some of the sample images that we have
unloaded so this one for example creates
a figure and then we go ahead and take a
few sample images to see how they look
so let me run this code and so that it
becomes easy to understand so these are
about five images sample images that we
are looking at zero one two three four
so this is how the image is this is how
the data is okay and
based on this we will actually train our
logistic regression model and then we
will test it and see how well it is able
to recognize so the way it works is the
pixel information so as you can see here
this is an 8 by 8 pixel kind of a image
and
the each pixel whether it is activated
or not activated that is the information
available for each pixel now based on
the pattern of this activation and
non-activation of the various pixels
this will be identified as a zero for
example right similarly as you can see
so overall each of these numbers
actually has a different pattern of the
pixel activation and that's pretty much
that our model needs to learn
for which a number what is the pattern
of the activation of the pixels right so
that is what we are going to train our
model okay so the first thing we need to
do is to split our data into training
and test data set right so whenever we
perform any training we split the data
into training and test so that the
training data set is used to train the
system so we pass this probably multiple
times
and then we test it with the test data
set and the split is usually in the form
of there and there are various ways in
which you can split this data it is up
to the individual preferences in our
case here we are splitting in the form
of 23 and 77 so when we say test size as
20 0.23 that means 23 percent of that
entire data is used for testing and the
remaining 77 percent is used for
training so there is a readily available
function which is
called train test split so we don't have
to write any special code for the
splitting it will automatically split
the data based on the proportion that we
give here which is test size so we just
give the test size automatically
training size will be determined and
we pass the data that we want to split
and the the results will be stored in x
underscore train and y underscore train
for the training data set and what is x
underscore train these are these are the
features right which is like the
independent variable and why underscore
train is the label right so
in this case what happens is we have the
input value which is or the features
value which is in x underscore train and
since this is the labeled data for each
of them each of the observations we
already have the label information
saying whether this digit is a zero or a
one or a two so that this is what will
be used for comparison to find out
whether the the system is able to
recognize it correctly or there is an
error for each observation it will
compare with this right so this is the
label so the same way x underscore train
y underscore train is for the training
data set x underscore test y underscore
test is for the test data set okay so
let me go ahead and execute this code as
well and then we can go and check
quickly what is the how many entries are
there and in each of this so x
underscore train the shape is 13 83
by 64. and y underscore train has 1383
because there is nothing like the second
part is not required here and then x
underscore test shape
we see is 414 so actually there are 414
observations in test and 1383
observations in train so that's
basically what these four lines of code
are are saying okay then we import the
logistic regression library and
which is a part of scikit learn so
we we don't have to implement the
logistic regression process itself we
just call this the function and let me
go ahead and execute that so that
we have the logistic regression library
imported now we create an instance of
logistic regression right so logistic
regr is uh is an instance of logistic
regression and then we use that for
training our model so let me first
execute this code so these two lines so
the first line basically creates an
instance of logistic regression model
and then the second line
is where we are passing our data the
training data set right this is our the
the predictors and uh this is our target
we are passing this data set to train
our model all right so
once we do this in this case the data is
not large but by and large the training
is what takes usually a lot of time so
we spend in machine learning
activities and machine learning projects
we spend a lot of time for the training
part of it okay so here the data set is
relatively small so it was pretty quick
so all right so now our model has been
trained using the training data set and
we want to see how accurate this is so
what we'll do is we will test it out in
probably faces so let me first try out
how well this is working for
one image okay i will just try it out
with one image my the first entry in my
test data set and see whether it is uh
correctly predicting or not so
and in order to test it so for training
purpose we use the fit method there is a
method called fit which is for training
the model and once the training is done
if you want to test for a particular
value new input you use the predict
method okay so let's run the predict
method and we pass this particular image
and
we see that the
shape is or the prediction is 4. so
let's try a few more let me see for the
next 10
seems to be fine so let me just go ahead
and test the entire data set okay that's
basically what we will do so now we want
to find out how accurately this has uh
performed so we use the score method to
find what is the percentages of accuracy
and we see here that it has performed up
to 94 percent to accurate okay so that's
on this part now what we can also do is
we can
also see this accuracy using what is
known as a confusion matrix so let us go
ahead and try that as well
so that we can also visualize how well
this model has uh done so let me execute
this piece of code which will basically
import some of the libraries that are
required and
we we basically create a confusion
matrix and instance of confusion matrix
by running confusion matrix and passing
these values so we have so this
confusion underscore matrix method takes
two parameters one is the y underscore
test and the other is the prediction so
what is the y underscore test these are
the labeled values which we already know
for the test data set and predictions
are what the system has predicted for
the test data set okay so this is known
to us
and this is what the system has
the model has generated so we kind of
create the confusion matrix and we will
print it and this is how the confusion
matrix looks as the name suggests it is
a matrix
and
the key point out here is that the
accuracy of the model is determined by
how many numbers are there in the
diagonal the more the numbers in the
diagonal the better the accuracy is
okay and first of all the total sum of
all the numbers in this whole matrix is
equal to the number of observations in
the test data set that is the first
thing right so if you add up all these
numbers that will be equal to the number
of
observations in the test data set and
then out of that the maximum number of
them should be in the diagonal that
means the accuracy is pretty good if the
the numbers in the diagonal are less and
in all other places there are a lot of
numbers uh which means the accuracy is
very low the diagonal indicates a
correct prediction that this means that
the actual value is same as the
predicted value here again actual values
same as the predictive value and so on
right so the moment you see a number
here that means the actual value is
something
and the predicted value is something
else right similarly here the actual
value is something and the predicted
value is something else so that is
basically how we read the confusion
matrix now how do we find the accuracy
you can actually add up the total values
in the diagonal so it's like 38 plus 44
plus 43 and so on and divide that by the
total number of test observations that
will give you the percentage accuracy
using a confusion matrix now let us
visualize this confusion matrix in a
slightly more sophisticated way
using a heat map so we will create a
heat map with some we'll add some colors
as well it's uh it's like a more
visually
visually more appealing so that's the
whole idea so if we let me run this
piece of code and this is how the heat
map looks uh and as you can see here the
diagonals again are all the values are
here most of the values so which means
reasonably this seems to be reasonably
accurate and yeah basically the accuracy
score is 94 percent this is calculated
as i mentioned by adding all these
numbers divided by the total test values
or the total number of observations in
test data set
okay so this is the confusion matrix for
logistic regression
all right so now that we have seen the
confusion matrix let's take a quick
sample and see how well the system has
classified and we will take a few
examples of the data so if we see here
we we picked up randomly a few of them
so
this is uh number four which is the
actual value and also the predicted
value both are four
this is an image of zero so the
predicted value is also zero actual
value is of course zero then this is the
image of nine
so this has also been predicted
correctly nine and actual value is nine
and this is the image of one and again
this has been predicted correctly as
like the actual value okay so this was a
quick demo of logistic regression how to
use logistic regression to identify
images
what is a decision tree let's go through
a very simple example before we dig in
deep decision tree is a tree shaped
diagram used to determine a course of
action each branch of the tree
represents a possible decision or
current or reaction let's start with a
simple question how to identify a random
vegetable from a shopping bag so we have
this group of vegetables in here and we
can start off by asking a simple
question is it red and if it's not then
it's going to be the purple fruit to the
left probably an eggplant if it's true
it's going to be one of the red fruits
is the diameter greater than 2 if false
is going to be a what looks to be a red
chili and if it's true it's going to be
a bell pepper from the capsicum family
so it's a capsicum
problems that decision tree can solve so
let's look at the two different
categories the decision tree can be used
on it can be used on the classification
the true false yes no and it can be used
on regression where we figure out what
the next value is in a series of numbers
or a group of data in classification the
classification tree will determine a set
of logical if-then conditions to
classify problems for example
discriminating between three types of
flowers based on certain features in
regression a regression tree is used
when the target variable is numerical or
continuous in nature we fit the
regression model to the target variable
using each of the independent variables
each split is made based on the sum of
squared error
before we dig deeper into the mechanics
of the decision tree let's take a look
at the advantages of using a decision
tree and we'll also take a glimpse at
the disadvantages the first thing you'll
notice is that it's simple to understand
interpret and visualize it really shines
here because you can see exactly what's
going on in a decision tree little
effort is required for data preparation
so you don't have to do special scaling
there's a lot of things you don't have
to worry about when using a decision
tree it can handle both numerical and
categorical data as we discovered
earlier and non-linear parameters don't
affect its performance so even if the
data doesn't fit an easy curved graph
you can still use it to create an
effective decision or prediction
if we're going to look at the advantages
of a decision tree we also need to
understand the disadvantages of a
decision tree the first disadvantage is
overfitting overfitting occurs when the
algorithm captures noise in the data
that means you're solving for one
specific instance instead of a general
solution for all the data high variance
the model can get unstable due to small
variation in data low bias tree a highly
complicated decision tree tends to have
a low bias which makes it difficult for
the model to work with new data
decision tree important terms before we
dive in further we need to look at some
basic terms we need to have some
definitions to go with our decision tree
in the different parts we're going to be
using we'll start with entropy entropy
is a measure of randomness or
unpredictability in the data set for
example we have a group of animals in
this picture there's four different
kinds of animals and this data set is
considered to have a high entropy you
really can't pick out what kind of
animal it is based on looking at just
the four animals as a big clump of uh
entities so as we start splitting it
into subgroups we come up with our
second definition which is information
gain information gain it is a measure of
decrease in entropy after the data set
is split so in this case based on the
color yellow we've split one group of
animals on one side as true and those
who aren't yellow as false as we
continue down the yellow side we split
based on the height true or false equals
10 and on the other side height is less
than 10 true or false and as you see as
we split it the entropy continues to be
less and less and less and so our
information gain is simply the entropy
e1 from the top and how it's changed to
e2 on the bottom and we'll look at the
deeper math although you really don't
need to know a huge amount of math when
you actually do the programming in
python because it'll do it for you but
we'll look on the actual math of how
they compute entropy finally we went on
the different parts of our tree and they
call the leaf node leaf node carries the
classification or the decision so it's
the final end at the bottom the decision
node has two or more branches this is
where we're breaking the group up into
different parts and finally you have the
root note the top most decision note is
known as the root node
how does a decision tree work wonder
what kind of animals i'll get in the
jungle today maybe you're the hunter
with the gun or if you're more into
photography you're a photographer with a
camera so let's look at this group of
animals and let's try to classify
different types of animals based on
their features using a decision tree so
the problem statement is to classify the
different types of animals based on
their features using a decision tree the
data set is looking quite messy and the
entropy is high in this case so let's
look at a training set or a training
data set and we're looking at color
we're looking at height and then we have
our different animals we have our
elephants our giraffes our monkeys and
our tigers and they're of different
colors and shapes let's see what that
looks like and how do we split the data
we have to frame the conditions that
split the data in such a way that the
information gain is the highest note
gain is a measure of decrease in entropy
after splitting so the formula for
entropy is the sum that's what this
symbol looks like that looks like kind
of like a e funky e of k where i equals
1 to k k would represent the number of
animals the different animals in there
where value or p
value of i would be the percentage of
that animal times the log base two of
the same the percentage of that animal
let's try to calculate the entropy for
the current data set and take a look at
what that looks like and don't be afraid
of the math you don't really have to
memorize this math and just be aware
that it's there and this is what's going
on in the background and so we have
three giraffes two tigers one monkey two
elephants a total of eight animals
gathered and if we plug that into the
formula we get an entropy that equals
three over eight so we have three
giraffes a total of eight times the log
usually they use base two on the log so
log base two of three over eight plus in
this case i say it's the elephants two
over eight two elephants over total of
eight times log base two two over eight
plus one monkey over total of eight log
base two one over eight and plus two
over eight of the tigers log base two
over eight and if we plug that into our
computer or calculator i obviously can't
do logs in my head we get an entropy
equal to 0.571
the program will actually calculate the
entropy of the data set similarly after
every split to calculate the gain now
we're not going to go through each set
one at a time to see what those numbers
are we just want you to be aware that
this is a formula or the mathematics
behind it gain can be calculated by
finding the difference of the subsequent
entropy values after a split now we will
try to choose a condition that gives us
the highest gain we will do that by
splitting the data using each condition
and checking that the gain we get out of
them the condition that gives us the
highest gain will be used to make the
first split can you guess what that
first split will be just by looking at
this image as a human is probably pretty
easy to split it let's see if you're
right if you guessed the color yellow
you're correct let's say the condition
that gives us the maximum gain is yellow
so we will split the data based on the
color yellow if it's true that group of
animals goes to the left if it's false
it goes to the right the entropy after
the splitting has de decreased
considerably however we still need some
splitting of both the branches to attain
an entropy value equal to zero so we
decide to split both the nodes using
height as the condition since every
branch now contains single label type we
can say that entropy in this case has
reached the least value and here you see
we have the giraffes the tigers the
monkey and the elephants all separated
into their own groups this tree can now
predict all the classes of animals
present in the dataset with a hundred
percent accuracy that was easy
use case loan repayment prediction let's
get into my favorite part and open up
some python and see what the programming
code in the scripting looks like in here
we're going to want to do a prediction
and we start with this individual here
who's requesting to find out how good
his customers are going to be whether
they're going to repay their loan or not
for his bank and from that we want to
generate a problem statement to predict
if a customer will repay loan amount or
not and then we're going to be using the
decision tree algorithm in python let's
see what that looks like and let's dive
into the code in our first few steps of
implementation we're going to start by
importing the necessary packages that we
need from python and we're going to load
up our data and take a look at what the
data looks like so the first thing i
need is i need something to edit my
python and run it in so let's flip on
over and here i'm using the anaconda
jupiter notebook now you can use any
python ide you like to run it in but i
find the jupiter notebook's really nice
for doing things on the fly and let's go
ahead and just paste that code in the
beginning and before we start let's talk
a little bit about what we're bringing
in and then we're going to do a couple
things in here we have to make a couple
changes as we go through this first part
of the import the first thing we bring
in is numpy as np that's very standard
when we're dealing with mathematics
especially with uh very complicated
machine learning tools you almost always
see the numpy come in for your num your
number it's called number python it has
your mathematics in there in this case
we actually could take it out but
generally you'll need it for most of
your different things you work with and
then we're going to use pandas as pd
that's also a standard the pandas is a
data frame setup and you can liken this
to taking your basic data and storing it
in a way that looks like an excel
spreadsheet so as we come back to this
when you see np or pd those are very
standard uses you'll know that that's
the pandas and i'll show you a little
bit more when we explore the data in
just a minute then we're going to need
to split the data so i'm going to bring
in our train test and split and this is
coming from the sk learn package cross
validation in just a minute we're going
to change that and we'll go over that
too and then there's also the sk.tree
import decision tree classifier that's
the actual tool we're using remember i
told you don't be afraid of the
mathematics it's going to be done for
you well the decision tree classifier
has all that mathematics in there for
you so you don't have to figure it back
out again and then we have
sklearn.metrics for accuracy score we
need to score our our setup that's the
whole reason we're splitting it between
the training and testing data and
finally we still need the sklearn import
tree and that's just the basic tree
function is needed for the decision tree
classifier and finally we're going to
load our data down here and i'm going to
run this and we're going to get two
things on here one we're going to get an
error and two we're going to get a
warning let's see what that looks like
so the first thing we had is we have an
error why is this error here well it's
looking at this it says i need to read a
file and when this was written
the person who wrote it
this is their path where they stored the
file
so let's go ahead and fix that
and i'm going to put in here my file
path i'm just going to call it full file
name and you'll see it's on my c drive
and this is very lengthy setup on here
where i stored the data2.csv file
don't worry too much about the full path
because on your computer it'll be
different
the data.2 csv file was generated by
simplylearn
if you want a copy of that you can
comment down below and request it here
in the youtube
and then if i'm going to give it a name
full file name
i'm going to go ahead and change it here
to full
file name so let's go ahead and run it
now and see what happens
and we get a warning
when you're coding
understanding these different warnings
and these different errors that come up
is probably the hardest lesson to learn
so let's just go ahead and take a look
at this and use this as a opportunity to
understand what's going on here
if you read the warning it says the
cross validation is depreciated so it's
a warning on it's being removed
and it's going to be moved in favor of
the model selection
so if we go up here we have sklearn dot
cross validation and if you research
this and go to the sklearn site you'll
find out that you can actually just swap
it right in there with model selection
and so when i come in here and i run it
again
that removes a warning
what they've done is they've had two
different developers develop it in two
different branches
and then they decided to keep one of
those and eventually get rid of the
other one that's all that is and very
easy and quick to fix
before we go any further i went ahead
and opened up the data
from this file remember the the data
file we just loaded on here the data
underscore 2.csv
let's talk a little bit more about that
and see what that looks like both as a
text file because it's a comma separated
variable file and in a spreadsheet
this is what it looks like as a basic
text file you can see at the top they've
created a header and it's got one two
three four five columns and each column
has data in it and let me flip this over
because we're also going to look at this
uh in an actual spreadsheet so you can
see what that looks like and here i've
opened it up in the open office calc
which is pretty much the same as excel
and zoomed in and you can see we've got
our columns and our rows of data a
little easier to read in here we have a
result yes yes no we have initial
payment last payment credit score
house number
if we scroll way down
we'll see that this occupies a thousand
and one lines of code or lines of data
with the first one being a column and
then 1 000 lines of data
now as a programmer
if you're looking at a small amount of
data i usually start by pulling it up in
different sources so i can see what i'm
working
with but in larger data you won't have
that option it would just be too too
large so you need to either bring in a
small amount that you can look at it
like we're doing right now or we can
start looking at it through the python
code so let's go ahead and move on and
take the next couple steps to explore
the data using python let's go ahead and
see what it looks like in python to
print the length and the shape of the
data so let's start by printing the
length of the database we can use a
simple lin function from python
and when i run this
you'll see that it's a thousand long and
that's what we expected there's a
thousand lines of data in there if you
subtract the column head
this is one of the nice things when we
did the
balance data from the panda read csv
you'll see that the header is row zero
so it automatically removes a row
and then shows the data separate it does
a good job sorting that data out for us
and then we can use a different function
and let's take a look at that
and again we're going to utilize the
tools in panda
and since the balance underscored data
was loaded as a panda data frame
we can do a shape on it and let's go
ahead and run the shape and see what
that looks like
what's nice about this shape is not only
does it give me the length of the data
we have a thousand lines it also tells
me there's five columns so we were
looking at the data we had five columns
of data and then let's take one more
step to explore the data using python
and now that we've taken a look at the
length and the shape let's go ahead and
use the
pandas module for head another beautiful
thing in the data set that we can
utilize so let's put that on our sheet
here and we have print data set
and balance data dot head and this is a
pandas print statement of its own so it
has its own print feature in there and
then we went ahead and gave a label for
a print job here of dataset just a
simple print statement
and we run that
let's just take a closer look at that
let me zoom in here
there we go
pandas do such a wonderful job of making
this a very clean
readable data set so you can look at the
data you can look at the column headers
you can have it when you put it as the
head
it prints the first five lines of the
data
and we always start with zero so we have
five lines we have zero one two three
four instead of one two three four five
that's a standard scripting and
programming set as you wanna start with
the zero position and that is what the
data head does it pulls the first five
rows of data puts in a nice format that
you can look at and view very powerful
tool to view the data so instead of
having to flip and open up an excel
spreadsheet or open office cal or trying
to look at a
word doc where it's all scrunched
together and hard to read you can now
get a nice open view of what you're
working with we're working with a shape
of a thousand long five wide so we have
five columns and we do the full data
head you can actually see what this data
looks like the initial payment last
payment credit scores house number so
let's take this now that we've explored
the data and let's start digging into
the decision tree so in our next step
we're going to train and build our data
tree and to do that we need to first
separate the date out we're going to
separate into two groups so that we have
something to actually train the data
with and then we have some data on the
side to test it to see how good our
model is remember with any of the
machine learning you always want to have
some kind of test set to weigh it
against so you know how good your model
is when you distribute it let's go ahead
and break this code down and look at it
in pieces
so first we have our x and y
where do x and y come from well x is
going to be our data
and y is going to be the answer or the
target you can look at its source and
target
in this case we're using x and y to
denote the data in and the data that
we're actually trying to guess what the
answer is going to be and so to separate
it we can simply put in x equals the
balance of the data.values the first
brackets
means that we're going to select all the
lines
in the database so it's all the data
and the second one says we're only going
to look at columns one through five
remember i always start with zero zero
is a yes or no
and that's whether the loan went default
or not so we wanna start with one if we
go back up here that's the initial
payment and it goes all the way through
the house number
well if we want to look at one through
five we can do the same thing for y
which is the answers and we're going to
set that just equal to the zero row so
it's just the zero row and then it's all
rows going in there so now we've divided
this into two different data sets
one of them with the
data going in and one with the answers
next we need to split the data
and here you'll see that we have it
split into four different parts
the first one is your x training your x
test your y train your y test
simply put we have x going in where
we're going to train it and we have to
know the answer to train it with
and then we have x test where we're
going to test that data
and we have to know in the end what the
y was supposed to be
and that's where this train test split
comes in that we loaded earlier in the
modules this does it all for us and you
can see they set the test size equal to
0.3 so it's roughly 30 percent will be
used in the test and then we use a
random state so it's completely random
which rows it takes out of there and
then finally we get to actually build
our decision tree and they've called it
here clf underscore entropy that's the
actual decision tree or decision tree
classifier and in here they've added a
couple variables which we'll explore in
just a minute and then finally we need
to fit the data to that so we take our
clf entropy that we created and we fit
the x train and since we know the
answers for x-trade or the y-train we go
ahead and put those in and let's go
ahead and run this and what most of
these sk learn modules do is when you
set up the variable in this case we set
the clf entropy called decision tree
classifier it automatically prints out
what's in that decision tree there's a
lot of variables you can play within
here and it's quite beyond the scope of
this
tutorial to go through all of these and
how they work but we're working on
entropy that's one of the options we've
added that is completely a random state
of 100 so 100 percent and we have a max
depth of three
now the max depth if you remember above
when we were doing the different graphs
of animals means it's only going to go
down three layers before it stops and
then we have minimal samples of leaves
as five so it's going to have at least
five leaves at the end so i'll have at
least three splits i'll have no more
than three layers and at least five end
leaves with the final result at the
bottom now that we've created
our decision tree classifier not only
created it but trained it let's go ahead
and apply it and see what that looks
like so let's go ahead and make a
prediction and see what that looks like
we're going to paste our predict code in
here
and before we run it let's just take a
quick look at what's it's doing here
we have a variable y predict that we're
going to do
and we're going to use our
variable clf entropy that we created
and then you'll see dot predict and it's
very common in the sk learn modules
that their different tools have the
predict when you're actually running a
prediction
in this case we're going to put our x
test data in here
now if you delivered this for use in
actual commercial use and distributed it
this would be the new loans you're
putting in here to guess
whether the person's going to be pay
them back or not
in this case so we need to test out the
data and just see how good our sample is
how good of our tree does at predicting
the loan payments and finally since
anaconda jupiter notebook is it works as
a command line for python we can simply
put the y predict e in to print it i
could just as easily put the print
and put brackets around y predict en to
print it out we'll go ahead and do that
it doesn't matter which way you do it
and you'll see right here that runs a
prediction this is roughly 300 in here
remember it's 30 percent of a thousand
so you should have about 300 answers in
here
and this tells you which each one of
those lines of our test went in there
and this is what our y predict came out
so let's move on to the next step we're
going to take this data and try to
figure out just how good a model we have
so here we go since sklearn does all the
heavy lifting for you and all the math
we have a simple line of code to let us
know what the accuracy is and let's go
ahead and go through that and see what
that means and what that looks like
let's go ahead and paste this in and let
me zoom in a little bit
there we go
so you have a nice full picture
and we'll see here we're just going to
do a print accuracy is
and then we do the accuracy score
and this was something we imported
earlier if you remember at the very
beginning let me just scroll up there
real quick so you can see where that's
coming from
that's coming from here down here from
sklearn.metrics
import accuracy score
and you could probably run a script make
your own script to do this very easily
how accurate is it how many out of 300
do we get right and so we put in our y
test that's the one we ran the predict
on and then we put in our y predict e n
that's the answers we got and we're just
going to multiply that by a hundred
because this is just going to give us an
answer as a decimal and we want to see
it as a percentage
and let's run that and see what it looks
like
and if you see here we got an accuracy
of
93.66667 so when we look at the number
of loans and we look at how good our
model fit we can tell people it has
about a 93.6
fitting to it so just a quick recap on
that we now have accuracy up on here and
so we have created a model that uses the
decision tree algorithm to predict
whether a customer will repay the loan
or not the accuracy of the model is
about 94.6 percent the bank can now use
this model to decide whether it should
approve the loan request from a
particular customer or not and so this
information is really powerful we may
not be able to as individuals understand
all these numbers because they have
thousands of numbers that come in but
you can see that this is a smart
decision for the bank to use a tool like
this to help them to predict how good
their profit's going to be off of the
loan balances and how many are going to
default or not so why random forest it's
always important to understand
why we use this tool over the other ones
what are the benefits here and so with a
random forest the first one is there's
no overfitting if you use of multiple
trees reduce the risk of overfitting
training time is less overfitting means
that we have fit the data so close to
what we have as our sample that we pick
up on all the weird parts and instead of
predicting the overall data you're
predicting the weird stuff which you
don't want
high accuracy runs efficiently in large
database for large data it produces
highly accurate predictions
in today's world of big data this is
really important and this is probably
where it really shines this is where why
random forest really comes in it
estimates missing data data in today's
world is very messy so when you have a
random forest it can maintain the
accuracy when a large proportion of the
data is missing what that means is if
you have data that comes in from five or
six different areas and maybe they took
one set of statistics in one area
and they took a slightly different set
of statistics in the other so they have
some of the same same shared data but
one is missing like the number of
children in the house if you're doing
something over demographics and the
other one is missing the size of the
house it will look at both of those
separately and build two different trees
and then it can do a very good job of
guessing which one fits better even
though it's missing that data let us dig
deep into the theory of exactly how it
works
and let's look at what is a random
forest
random forest or random decision forest
is a method that operates by
constructing multiple decision trees the
decision of the majority of the trees is
chosen by the random forest as a final
decision and this uh we have some nice
graphics here we have a decision tree
and they actually use a real tree to
denote the decision tree which i love
and given a random some kind of picture
of a fruit this decision tree decides
that the output is it's an apple and we
have a decision tree two where we have
that picture of the fruit goes in and
this one decides that it's a lemon and
the decision three tree gets another
image and it decides it's an apple and
then this all comes together in what
they call the random forest and this
random forest then looks at it and says
okay i got two votes for apple one vote
for lemon the majority is apples so the
final decision is apples to understand
how the random forest works we first
need to dig a little deeper and take a
look at the random forest and the actual
decision tree and how it builds that
decision tree in looking closer at how
the individual decision trees work we'll
go ahead and continue to use the fruit
example since we're talking about trees
and forests a decision tree is a tree
shaped diagram used to determine a
course of action each branch of the tree
represents a possible decision
occurrence or reaction so in here we
have a bowl of fruit and if you look at
that it looks like they switched from
lemons to oranges we have oranges
cherries and apples and the first
decision of the decision tree might be
is a diameter greater than or equal to
three and if it says false it knows that
they're cherries because everything else
is bigger than that so all the cherries
fall into that decision so we have all
that data we're training we can look at
that we know that that's what's going to
come up
is the color orange well goes hmm orange
or red well if it's true
then it comes out as the orange and if
it's false that leaves apples
so in this example it sorts out the
fruit in the bowl or the images of the
fruit a decision tree these are very
important terms to know because these
are very central to understanding the
decision tree and when working with them
the first is entropy
everything on the decision tree and how
it makes this decision is based on
entropy entropy is a measure of
randomness or unpredictability in the
data set then they also have information
gain
the leaf node the decision node and the
root node we'll cover these other four
terms as we go down the tree but let's
start with entropy
so starting with entropy we have here a
high amount of randomness what that
means is that whatever is coming out of
this decision if it was going to guess
based on this data
it wouldn't be able to tell you whether
it's a lemon or an apple it would just
say it's a fruit
so the first thing we want to do is we
want to split this apart and we take the
initial data set we're going to create a
data set one and a data set two we just
split it in two and if you look at these
new data sets after splitting them the
entropy of each of those sets is much
less
so for the first one whatever comes in
there it's going to sort that data and
it's going to say okay if this data goes
this direction it's probably an apple
and if it goes into the other direction
it's probably a lemon so that brings us
up to information gain it is the measure
of decrease in the entropy after the
data set is split what that means in
here is that we've gone from
one set which has a very high entropy to
two lower sets of entropy and we've
added in the values of e1 for the first
one and e2 for the second two which are
much lower and so that information gain
is increased greatly in this example and
so you can find that the information
grain simply equals
decision e1
minus e2 as we're going down our list of
definitions we'll look at the leaf node
and the leaf node
carries the classification or the
decision
so we look down here to the leaf node we
finally get to our set one or our set
two
when it comes down there and it says
okay this object's gone into set one
if it's gone into set one it's going to
be split by some means and we'll either
end up with apples on the leaf node or a
lemon on the leaf node and on the right
it'll either be an apple or lemons those
leaf nodes are those final decisions or
classifications
that's the definition of leaf node in
here if we're going to have a final leaf
where we make the decision
we should have a name for the nodes
above it and they call those decision
nodes
a decision node decision node has two or
more branches and you can see here where
we have the uh five apples and one lemon
and in the other case the five lemons in
one apple they have to make a choice of
which tree it goes down
based on some kind of measurement or
information given to the tree
and that brings us to our last
definition
the root node the top most decision node
is known as the root node and this is
where you have all of your data and you
have your first decision it has to make
or the first split in information
so far we've looked at a very general
image
with the fruit being split let's look
and see exactly what that means to split
the data and how do we make those
decisions on there
let's go in there and find out how does
a decision tree work
so let's try to understand this and
let's use a simple example and we'll
stay with the fruit we have a bowl of
fruit and so let's create a problem
statement and the problem is we want to
classify the different types of fruits
in the bowl based on different features
the data set in the bowl is looking
quite messy and the entropy is high in
this case so if this ball was our
decision maker it wouldn't know what
choice to make it has so many choices
which one do you pick apple
grapes or lemons and so we look in here
we're going to start with the dra a
training set
so this is our data that we're training
our data with and we have a number of
options here we have the color and under
the color we have red yellow purple
we have a diameter
three three one three three one and we
have a label apple lemon grapes apple
lemon grapes and how do we split the
data we have to frame the conditions to
split the data in such a way that the
information gain is the highest
it's very key to note that we're looking
for the best gain we don't want to just
start sorting out the smallest piece in
there we want to split it the biggest
way we can and so we measure this
decrease in entropy that's what they
call it entropy there's our entropy
after splitting and now we'll try to
choose a condition that gives us the
highest gain we will do that by
splitting the data using each condition
and checking the gain that we get out of
them the conditions that give us the
highest gain will be used to make the
first split so let's take a look at
these different conditions we have color
we have diameter and if we look
underneath that we have a couple
different values we have diameter equals
three color equals yellow red diameter
equals one and when we look at that
you'll see over here we have one two
three four threes that's a pretty hearty
selection so let's say the condition
gives us the maximum gain of three so we
have the most pieces fall into
that range so our first split from our
decision node is we split the data based
on the diameter is it greater than or
equal to three if it's not that's false
it goes into the grape bowl and if it's
true it goes into a bowl fold of lemon
and apples the entropy after splitting
has decreased considerably so now we can
make two decisions if you look at
they're very
much less chaos going on there this note
has already attained an entropy value of
0 as you can see there's only one kind
of label left for this branch so no
further splitting is required for this
node however this node on the right is
still requires a split to decrease the
entropy further so we split the right
node further based on color if you look
at this if i split it on color that
pretty much cuts it right down the
middle it's the only thing we have left
in our choices of color and diameter too
and if the color is yellow it's going to
go to the right bowl and if it's false
it's going to go to the left bowl so the
entropy in this case is now zero so now
we have three bowls with zero entropy
there's only one type of data in each
one of those bowls so we can predict a
lemon with a hundred percent accuracy
and we can predict the apple also with
100 accuracy along with our grapes up
there in this example last week my son
and i visited a fruit shop dad is that
an apple or a strawberry so the question
comes up what fruit do they just pick up
from the fruit stand after a couple of
seconds you could figure out that it was
a strawberry so let's take this model a
step further and let's uh why not build
a model which can predict an unknown
data and in this we're going to be
looking at some sweet strawberries or
crispy apples we want to be able to
label those two and decide what the
fruit is and we do that by having data
already put in so we already have a
bunch of strawberries we know our
strawberries and they're already labeled
as such we already have a bunch of
apples we know our apples and are
labeled as such then once we train our
model that model then can be given the
new data and the new data is this image
in this case you can see a question mark
on it and it comes through and goes it's
a strawberry in this case we're using
the support vector machine model svm is
a supervised learning method that looks
at data and sorts it into one of two
categories and in this case we're
sorting the strawberry into the
strawberry site at this point you should
be asking the question how does the
prediction work before we dig into an
example with numbers let's apply this to
our fruit scenario we have our support
vector machine we've taken it and we've
taken labeled sample of data
strawberries and apples and we draw on a
line down the middle between the two
groups this split now allows us to take
new data in this case an apple and a
strawberry and place them in the
appropriate group based on which side of
the line they fall in and that way we
can predict the unknown as colorful and
tasty as the fruit example is let's take
a look at another example with some
numbers involved and we can take a
closer look at how the math works in
this example we're going to be
classifying men and women and we're
going to start with a set of people with
a different height and a different
weight and to make this work we'll have
to have a sample data set of female we
have their height and weight 174 65 174
88 and so on and we'll need a sample
data set of the male they have a height
179 90 180 to 80 and so on let's go
ahead and put this on a graph so we have
a nice visual so you can see here we
have two groups based on the height
versus the weight and on the left side
we're going to have the women on the
right side we're going to have the men
now if we're going to create a
classifier let's add a new data point
and figure out if it's male or female so
before we can do that we need to split
our data first we can split our data by
choosing any of these lines
in this case we draw in two lines
through the data in the middle that
separates them in from the women but to
predict the gender of a new data point
we should split the data in the best
possible way and we say the best
possible way because this line has a
maximum space that separates the two
classes here you can see there's a clear
split between the two different classes
and in this one there's not so much a
clear split this doesn't have the
maximum space that separates the two
that is why this line best splits the
data we don't want to just do this by
eyeballing it and before we go further
we need to add some technical terms to
this we can also say that the distance
between the points and the line should
be as far as possible in technical terms
we can say the distance between the
support vector and the hyperplane should
be as far as possible and this is where
the support vectors are the extreme
points in the data set and if you look
at this data set they have circled two
points which seem to be right on the
outskirts of the woman and one on the
outskirts of the men and hyperplane has
a maximum distance to the support
vectors of any class now you'll see the
line down the middle and we call this
the hyperplane because when you're
dealing with multiple dimensions it's
really not just a line but a plane of
intersections and you can see here where
the support vectors have been drawn in
dashed lines the math behind this is
very simple we take d plus the shortest
distance to the closest positive point
which would be on the min side and d
minus is the shortest distance to the
closest negative point which is on the
women's side the sum of d plus and d
minus is called the distance margin or
the distance between the two support
vectors that are shown in the dashed
lines and then by finding the largest
distance margin we can get the optimal
hyperplane once we've created an optimal
hyperplane we can easily see which side
the new data fits in and based on the
hyperplane we can say the new data point
belongs to the male gender hopefully
that's clear how that works on a visual
level as a data scientist you should
also be asking what happens if the
hyperplane is not optimal if we select a
hyperplane having low margin then there
is a high chance of misclassification
this particular svm model the one we
discussed so far is also called referred
to as the ls vm so far so clear but a
question should be coming up we have our
sample data set but instead of looking
like this what if it looked like this
where we have two sets of data but one
of them occurs in the middle of another
set you can see here where we have the
blue and the yellow and then blue again
on the other side of our data line in
this data set we can't use a hyperplane
so when you see data like this it's
necessary to move away from a 1d view of
the data to a two-dimensional view of
the data and for the transformation we
use what's called a kernel function the
kernel function will take the 1d input
and transfer it to a two-dimensional
output as you can see in this picture
here the 1d when transferred to a
2-dimensional makes it very easy to draw
a line between the two data sets what if
we make it even more complicated how do
we perform an svm for this type of data
set here you can see we have a two
dimensional data set where the data is
in the middle surrounded by the green
data on the outside in this case we're
going to segregate the two classes we
have our sample data set and if you draw
a line through it's obviously not an
optimal hyperplane in there so to do
that we need to transfer the 2d to a 3d
array and when you translate it into a
three-dimensional array using the kernel
you can see where you can place a
hyperplane right through it and easily
split the data before we start looking
at a programming example and dive into
the script let's look at the advantage
of the support vector machine we'll
start with high dimensional input space
or sometimes referred to as the curse of
dimensionality we looked at earlier one
dimension two dimension three dimension
when you get to a thousand dimensions a
lot of problems start occurring with
most algorithms that have to be adjusted
for the svm automatically does that in
high dimensional space one of the high
dimensional space one high dimensional
space that we work on is sparse document
vectors this is where we tokenize the
words and document so we can run our
machine learning algorithms over them
i've seen ones get as high as 2.4
million different tokens that's a lot of
vectors to look at and finally we have
regularization parameter the relation
parameter or lambda is a parameter that
helps figure out whether we're going to
have a bias or overfitting of the data
whether it's going to be overfitted to a
very specific instance or is going to be
biased to a high or low value with the
svm it naturally avoids the overfitting
and bias problems that we see in many
other algorithms these three advantages
of the support vector machine make it a
very powerful tool to add to your
repertoire of machine learning tools now
we did promise you a used case study
we're actually going to dive in to some
python programming and so we're going to
go into a problem statement and start
off with the zoo so in the zoo example
we have family members going to the zoo
when we have the young child going dead
is that a group of crocodiles or
alligators well that's hard to
differentiate and zoos are a great place
to start looking at science and
understanding how things work especially
as a young child and so we can see the
parents sitting here thinking well what
is the difference between a crocodile
and an alligator well one crocodiles are
larger in size alligators are smaller in
size snout width the crocodiles have a
narrow snout and alligators have a wider
snout and of course in the modern day
and age the father is sitting here
thinking how can i turn this into a
lesson for my son and he goes let a
support vector machine segregate the two
groups i don't know if my dad ever told
me that but that would be funny now in
this example we're not going to use
actual measurements and data we're just
using that for imagery and that's very
common in a lot of machine learning
algorithms and setting them up but let's
roll up our sleeves and we'll talk about
that more in just a moment as we break
into our python script so here we arrive
in our actual coding and i'm going to
move this into a python editor in just a
moment but let's talk a little bit about
what we're going to cover first we're
going to cover in the code the setup how
to actually create our svm and you're
going to find that there's only two
lines of code that actually create it
and the rest of it is done so quick and
fast that it's all here in the first
page and we'll show you what that looks
like as far as our data because we're
going to create some data i talked about
creating data just a minute ago and so
we'll get into the creating data here
and you'll see this nice correction of
our two blobs and we'll go through that
in just a second and then the second
part is we're going to take this and
we're going to bump it up a notch we're
going to show you what it looks like
behind the scenes but let's start with
actually creating our setup i like to
use the anaconda jupiter notebook
because it's very easy to use but you
can use any of your favorite python
editors or setups and go in there but
let's go ahead and switch over there and
see what that looks like so here we are
in the anaconda python notebook or
anaconda jupiter notebook with python
we're using python 3. i believe this is
3.5 but it should be work in any of your
3x versions and
you'd have to look at the sklearn and
make sure if you're using a 2x version
an earlier version let's go and put our
code in there and one of the things i
like about the jupyter notebook is i go
up to view and i'm going to go ahead and
toggle the line numbers on to make it a
little bit easier to talk about and we
can even increase the size because this
is edited in this case i'm using google
chrome explorer and that's how it opens
up for the editor although anyone any
like i said any editor will work now the
first step is going to be our imports
and we're going to import four different
parts the first two i want you to look
at are line one and line two are numpy
as np and matplot library dot pi plot as
plt now these are very standardized
imports when you're doing work the first
one is the numbers python we need that
because part of the platform we're using
uses that for the numpy array and i'll
talk about that in a minute so you can
understand why we want to use a numpy
array versus the standard python array
and normally it's pretty standard setup
to use np for numpy the map plot library
is how we're going to view our data so
this has uh you do need the np for the
sklearn module but the map plot library
is purely for our use for visualization
and so you really don't need that for
the svm but we're going to put it there
so you have a nice visual aid and we can
show you what it looks like that's
really important at the end when you
finish everything so you have a nice
display for everybody to look at and
then finally we're going to i'm going to
jump one ahead to line number four
that's the sklearn.datasets.com
import make blobs and i told you that we
were going to make up data and this is a
tool that's in the sk learning to makeup
data i personally don't want to go to
the zoo get in trouble for jumping over
the fence and probably get eaten by the
crocodiles or alligators as i work on
measuring their snouts and width and
length
instead we're just going to make up some
data and that's what that make blobs is
it's a wonderful tool if you're ready to
test your your setup and you're not sure
about what data you're going to put in
there you can create this blob and it
makes it really easy to use and finally
we have our actual svm the sklearn
import svm on line three so that covers
all our imports we're going to create
remember i use the make blobs to create
data and we're going to create a capital
x and a lowercase y equals make blobs in
samples equals 40. so we're going to
make 40 lines of data it's going to have
two centers with a random state equals
20. so which each each group is going to
have 20 different pieces of data in it
and the way that looks is that we'll
have under x
an x y plane so i have two numbers under
x and y will be 0 1 that's the two
different centers so we have yes or no
in this case alligator or crocodile
that's what that represents and then i
told you that the actual sk learner the
svm is in two lines of code and we see
it right here with clf equals svm dot
svc kernel equals linear and i set sql
to one although in this example since we
are not uh regularizing the data because
we want to be very clear and easy to see
i went ahead you can set it to a
thousand a lot of times when you're not
doing that but for this thing linear
because it's a very simple linear
example we only have the two dimensions
and it'll be a nice linear hyperplane
will be a nice linear line instead of a
full plane so we're not dealing with a
huge amount of data and then all we have
to do is do clf dot fit x comma y and
that's it clf has been created and then
we're going to go ahead and display it
and i'm going to talk about this display
here in just a second but let me go
ahead and run this code and this is what
we've done is we've created two blobs
you'll see the blue on the side and then
kind of an orangish
on the other side that's our two sets of
data they represent one represents
crocodiles and one represents alligators
and then we have our measurements in
this case we have like the width and
length of the snout and i did say i was
going to come up here and talk just a
little bit about our plot and you'll see
plt that's what we imported we're going
to do a scatter plot that means we're
just putting dots on there and then look
at this notation i have the capital x
and then in brackets i have a colon
comma 0. that's from numpy if you did
that in a regular array you'll get an
error in a python array you have to have
that in a numpy array it turns out that
our make blobs returns a numpy array and
this notation is great because what it
means is the first part is the colon
means we're going to do all the rows
that's all the data in our blob we
created under capital x and then the
second part has a comma 0. we're only
going to take the first value and then
if you notice we do the same thing but
we're going to take the second value
remember we always start with 0 and then
one
so we have column zero and column one
and you can look at this as our x y
plots the first one is the x plot and
the second one is the y plot so the
first one is on the bottom zero two four
six eight and ten and then the second
one x of the one is the 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
going up the left hand side s equals 30
is just the size of the dots we can see
them it says real tiny dots and then the
c map equals plt.cm.p
and you'll also see the c equals y
that's the color we're using two colors
zero one and that's why we get the nice
blue and the two different colors for
the alligator and the crocodile now you
can see here that we did this the actual
fit was done in two lines of code a lot
of times there'll be a third line where
we regularize the data we set it between
like minus one and one and we reshape it
but for this it's not necessary and it's
also kind of nice because you can
actually see what's going on and then if
we wanted to we wanted to actually run a
prediction let's take a look and see
what that looks like and to predict some
new data and we'll show this again as we
get towards the end of digging in deep
you can simply assign your new data in
this case i am giving it a width and
length 3 4 and a width and length 5 6.
and note that i put the data as a set of
brackets and then i have the brackets
inside and the reason i do that is
because when we're looking at data it's
designed to process a large amount of
data coming in we don't want to just
process one line at a time and so in
this case i'm processing two lines and
then i'm just going to print and you'll
see clf dot predict new data so the clf
and the dot predict part is going to
give us an answer and let's see what
that looks like and you'll see 0 1 so
predicted the first one the 3 4 is going
to be on the one side and the 5 6 is
going to be on the other side so one
came out as an alligator and one came
out as a crocodile now that's pretty
short explanation for the setup but
really we want to dug in and see what's
going on behind the scenes and let's see
what that looks like
so the next step is to dig in deep and
find out what's going on behind the
scenes and also put that in a nice
pretty graph
we're going to spend more work on this
and we did actually generating the
original model and you'll see here that
we go through a few steps and i'll move
this over to our editor in just a second
we come in we create our original data
it's exactly identical to the first part
and i'll explain why we redid that and
show you how not to redo that and then
we're going to go in there and add in
those lines we're going to see what
those lines look like and how to set
those up and finally we're going to plot
all that on here and show it and you'll
get a nice graph with the what we saw
earlier when we were going through the
theory behind this where it shows the
support vectors and the hyperplane and
those are done where you can see the
support vectors as the dashed lines and
the solid line which is the hyperplane
let's get that into our jupiter notebook
before i scroll down to a new line i
want you to notice line 13 has plot show
and we're going to talk about that here
in just a second but let's scroll down
to a new line down here and i'm going to
paste that code in and you'll see that
the plot show has moved down below let's
scroll up a little bit and if you look
at the top here of our new section one
two three and four is the same code we
had before and let's go back up here and
take a look at that we're going to fit
the values on our svm and then we're
going to plot scatter it and then we're
going to do a plot show so you should be
asking why are we redoing the same code
well when you do the plot show that
blanks out what's in the plot so once
i've done this plot show i have to
reload that data now we could do this
simply by removing it up here re-running
it and then coming down here and then we
wouldn't have to rerun these first four
lines of code now in this it doesn't
matter too much and you'll see the plot
show was down here and then removed
right there on line five i'll go ahead
and just delete that out of there
because we don't want to blank out our
screen we want to move on to the next
setup so we can go ahead and just skip
the first four lines because we did that
before and let's take a look at the ax
equals plt.gca
now right now we're actually spending a
lot of time just graphing that's all
we're doing here okay so this is how we
display a nice graph with our results in
our data ax is very standard used
variable when you talk about plt and
it's just setting it to that axis the
last axis in the plt it can get very
confusing if you're working with many
different layers of data on the same
graph and this makes it very easy to
reference the ax so this reference is
looking at the plt that we created and
we already mapped out our two blobs on
and then we want to know the limits so
we want to know how big the graph is we
can find out the x limit and the y limit
simply with the get x limit and get y
limit commands which is part of our
metplot library and then we're going to
create a grid and you'll see down here
we have we've set the variable x equal
to np dot line space x limit zero x
limit one comma thirty and we've done
the same thing for the y space and then
we're gonna go in here and we create a
mesh grid and this is a numpy command so
we're back to our numbers python let's
go through what these numpy commands
mean with the line space in the mesh
grid we've taken x x small s x x equals
np line space and we have our x limit 0
and our x limit 1 and we're going to
create 30 points on it and we're going
to do the same thing for the y axis now
this has nothing to do with our
evaluation it's all we're doing is we're
creating a grid of data and so we're
creating a set of points between 0 and
the x limit we're creating 30 points and
the same thing with the y and then the
mesh grid loops those all together so it
forms a nice grit so if we were going to
do this say between the limit 0 and 10
and do 10 points we would have a zero
zero one one zero one zero two zero
three zero four to ten and so on you can
just imagine a point at each corner one
of those boxes and the mesh grid
combines them all so we take the y y and
the x x we created and creates the full
grid and we've set that grid into the yy
coordinates and the xx coordinates now
remember we're working with numbie and
python we like to separate those we like
to have instead of it being x comma 1
you know x comma y
and then x2 comma y2 and this in the
next set of data it would be a column of
x's and a column of y's and that's what
we have here is we have a column of y's
and we put it as a capital yy and a
column of x's capital xx with all those
different points being listed and
finally we get down to the numpy v stack
just as we created those in the mesh
grid we're now going to put them all
into one array x y array now that we've
created the stack of data points we're
going to do something interesting here
we're going to create a value z and the
z equals the clf that's our that's our
support vector machine we created and
we've already trained and we have a dot
decision function we're going to put the
x y in there so here we have all this
data we're going to put that x y in
there that data and we're going to
reshape it and you'll see that we have
the xx dot shape in here this literally
takes the xx resets it up connected to
the y
and the z value lets us know whether it
is the left hand side is going to
generate three different values the z
value does and it'll tell us whether
that data is a support vector to the
left the hyperplane in the middle or the
support vector to the right so it
generates three different values for
each of those points and those points
have been reshaped so they're right on a
line on those three different lines so
we've set all of our data up we've
labeled it to three different areas and
we've reshaped it and we've just taken
30 points in each direction if you do
the math you have 30 times 30 so it's
900 points of data and we separated
between the three lines and reshaped it
to fit those three lines we can then go
back to our map plot library we've
created the ax and we're going to create
a contour and you'll see here we have
contour capital xx capital yy these have
been reshaped to fit those lines z is
the labels so now we have the three
different points with the labels in
there and we can set the colors equals k
and i told you we had three different
labels but we have three levels of data
the alphas just makes it kind of see
through so it's only 0.5 of the value in
there so when we graph it the data will
show up from behind it wherever the
lines go and finally the line styles
this is where we set the two support
vectors to be dash dashed lines and then
a single one is just a straight line
that's what all that setup does and then
finally we take our ax dot scatter we're
going to go ahead and plot the support
vectors but we've programmed it in there
so that they look nice like the dash
dash line and the dashed line on that
grid and you can see here when we do the
clf dot support vectors we are looking
at column zero and column one and then
again we have the s equals 100 so we're
going to make them larger and the line
width equals one face colors equals none
let's take a look and see what that
looks like when we show it and you can
see we get down to our end result it
creates a really nice graph we have our
two support vectors and dashed lines and
they have the near data so you can see
those two points or in this case the
four points where those lines nicely
cleave the data and then you have your
hyperplane down the middle which is as
far from the two different points as
possible creating the maximum distance
so you can see that we have our nice
output for the size of the body and the
width of the snout and we've easily
separated the two groups of crocodile
and alligator congratulations you've
done it we've made it of course these
are pretend data for our crocodiles and
alligators but this hands-on example
will help you to encounter any support
vector machine projects in the future
and you can see how easy they are to set
up and look at in depth we're going to
cover the k nearest neighbors like
referred to as k n n and k n is really a
fundamental place to start in the
machine learning it's the basis of a lot
of other things and just the logic
behind it is easy to understand and
incorporated in other forms of machine
learning so today what's in it for you
why do we need k n n
what is k n
how do we choose the factor k
when do we use knn
how does knn algorithm work
and then we'll dive in to my favorite
part the use case predict whether a
person will have diabetes or not that is
a very common and popular used data set
as far as testing out models and
learning how to use the different models
in machine learning by now we all know
machine learning models make predictions
by learning from the past data available
so we have our input values our machine
learning model builds on those inputs of
what we already know and then we use
that to create a predicted output
is that a dog little kid looking over
there watching the black cat cross their
path no dear you can differentiate
between a cat and a dog based on their
characteristics
cats
cats have sharp claws uses to climb
smaller length of ears meows and purrs
doesn't love to play around dogs they
have dull claws bigger length of ears
barks loves to run around you usually
don't see a cat running around people
although i do have a cat that does that
where dogs do and we can look at these
we can say we can evaluate the sharpness
of the claws how sharp are their claws
and we can evaluate the length of the
ears and we can usually sort out cats
from dogs based on even those two
characteristics
now tell me if it is a cat or a dog not
question usually little kids know cats
and dogs by now unless they live a place
where there's not many cats or dogs so
if we look at the sharpness of the claws
the length of the ears and we can see
that the cat has smaller ears and
sharper claws than the other animals its
features are more like cats it must be a
cat
sharp claws length of ears and it goes
in the cat group because knn is based on
feature similarity we can do
classification using knn classifier so
we have our input value the picture of
the black cat it goes into our trained
model and it predicts that this is a cat
coming out so what is knn what is the k
n algorithm
k nearest neighbors is what that stands
for is one of the simplest supervised
machine learning algorithms mostly used
for classification so we want to know is
this a dog or is not a dog is it a cat
or not a cat it classifies a data point
based on how its neighbors are
classified knn stores all available
cases and classifies new cases based on
a similarity measure and here we've gone
from cats and dogs right into wine
another favorite of mine k n stores all
available cases and classifies new cases
based on a similarity measure and here
you see we have a measurement of sulfur
dioxide versus the chloride level and
then the different wines they've tested
and where they fall on that graph based
on how much sulfur dioxide and how much
chloride k and k n is a perimeter that
refers to the number of nearest
neighbors to include in the majority of
the voting process and so if we add a
new glass of wine there red or white we
want to know what the neighbors are in
this case we're going to put k equals 5
we'll talk about k in just a minute a
data point is classified by the majority
of votes from its five nearest neighbors
here the unknown point would be
classified as red since four out of five
neighbors are red
so how do we choose k
how do we know k equals five i mean
that's what's the value we put in there
so we're going to talk about it how do
we choose a factor k k n algorithm is
based on feature similarity choosing the
right value of k
is a process called parameter tuning and
is important for better accuracy so at k
equals 3 we can classify
we have a question mark in the middle as
either a as a square or not is it a
square or is it in this case a triangle
and so if we set k equals to 3 we're
going to look at the three nearest
neighbors we're going to say this is a
square and if we put k equals to 7 we
classify as a triangle depending on what
the other data is around and you can see
as the k changes depending on where that
point is that drastically changes your
answer and we jump here we go how do we
choose the factor of k you'll find this
in all machine learning choosing these
factors that's the face you get it's
like oh my gosh did i choose the right k
did i set it right my values in whatever
machine learning tool you're looking at
so that you don't have a huge bias in
one direction or the other and in terms
of k n n the number of k if you choose
it too low the bias is based on it's
just two noises it's it's right next to
a couple things and it's going to pick
those things and you might get a skewed
answer and if your k is too big then
it's going to take forever to process so
you're going to run into processing
issues and resource issues so what we do
the most common use and there's other
options for choosing k is to use the
square root of n so it is a total number
of values you have you take the square
root of it in most cases you also if
it's an even number so if you're using
like this case squares and triangles if
it's even you want to make your k value
odd that helps it select better so in
other words you're not going to have a
balance between two different factors
that are equal so usually take the
square root of n and if it's even you
add one to it or subtract one from it
and that's where you get the k value
from that is the most common use and
it's pretty solid it works very well
when do we use knn we can use knn when
data is labeled so you need a label on
it we know we have a group of pictures
with dogs dogs cats cats data is noise
free and so you can see here when we
have a class and we have like
underweight 140 23 hello kitty normal
that's pretty confusing we have a high
variety of data coming in so it's very
noisy and that would cause an issue data
set is small so we're usually working
with smaller data sets where you might
get into a gig of data if it's really
clean doesn't have a lot of noise
because k n is a lazy learner i.e it
doesn't learn a discriminative function
from the training set so it's very lazy
so if you have very complicated data and
you have a large amount of it you're not
going to use the knn but it's really
great to get a place to start even with
large data you can sort out a small
sample and get an idea of what that
looks like using the knn and also just
using for smaller data sets k n works
really good how does a k n algorithm
work consider a data set having two
variables height in centimeters and
weight in kilograms and each point is
classified as normal or underweight so
we see right here we have two variables
you know true false they're either
normal or they're not they're
underweight on the basis of the given
data we have to classify the below set
as normal or underweight using knn so if
we have new data coming in this says 57
kilograms and 177 centimeters is that
going to be normal or underweight to
find the nearest neighbors we'll
calculate the euclidean distance
according to the euclidean distance
formula the distance between two points
in the plane with the coordinates x y
and a b is given by distance d equals
the square root of x minus a squared
plus y minus b squared and you can
remember that from the two edges of a
triangle we're computing the third edge
since we know
the x side and the y side let's
calculate it to understand clearly so we
have our unknown point and we placed it
there in red and we have our other
points where the data is scattered
around the distance d1 is the square
root of 170 minus 167 squared plus 57
minus 51 squared which is about 6.7 and
distance 2 is about 13. and distance 3
is about
13.4 similarly we will calculate the
euclidean distance of unknown data point
from all the points in the data set and
because we're dealing with small amount
of data that's not that hard to do it's
actually pretty quick for a computer and
it's not a really complicated mass you
can just see how close is the data based
on the euclidean distance hence we have
calculated the euclidean distance of
unknown data point from all the points
as shown where x1 and y1 equal 57 and
170 whose class we have to classify so
now we're looking at that we're saying
well here's the euclidean distance who's
going to be their closest neighbors now
let's calculate the nearest neighbor at
k equals three and we can see the three
closest neighbors puts them at normal
and that's pretty self-evident when you
look at this graph it's pretty easy to
say okay what you know we're just voting
normal normal normal three votes for
normal this is going to be a normal
weight so majority of neighbors are
pointing towards normal hence as per k n
algorithm the class of 57 170 should be
normal so a recap of knn positive
integer k is specified along with a new
sample we select the k entries in our
database which are closest to the new
sample we find the most common
classification of these entries this is
the classification we give to the new
sample so as you can see it's pretty
straightforward we're just looking for
the closest things that match what we
got so let's take a look and see what
that looks like in a use case in python
so let's dive into the predict diabetes
use case so use case predict diabetes
the objective predict whether a person
will be diagnosed with diabetes or not
we have a data set of 768 people who
were or were not diagnosed with diabetes
and let's go ahead and open that file
and just take a look at that data and
this is in a simple spreadsheet format
the data itself is comma separated very
common set of data and it's also a very
common way to get the data and you can
see here we have columns a through i
that's what one two three four five six
seven eight
eight columns with a particular
attribute and then the ninth column
which is the outcome is whether they
have diabetes as a data scientist the
first thing you should be looking at is
insulin well you know if someone has
insulin they have diabetes because
that's why they're taking it and that
could cause issue in some of the machine
learning packages but for a very basic
setup this works fine for doing the k n
and the next thing you notice is it
didn't take very much to open it up i
can scroll down to the bottom of the
data there's 768.
it's pretty much a small data set you
know at 769 i can easily fit this into
my ram on my computer i can look at it i
can manipulate it and it's not going to
really tax just a regular desktop
computer you don't even need an
enterprise version to run a lot of this
so let's start with importing all the
tools we need and before that of course
we need to discuss what ide i'm using
certainly can use any particular editor
for python but i like to use for doing
very basic visual stuff the anaconda
which is great for doing demos with the
jupiter notebook and just a quick view
of the anaconda navigator which is the
new release out there which is really
nice you can see under home i can choose
my application we're going to be using
python36 i have a couple different
versions on this particular machine if i
go under environments like create a
unique environment for each one which is
nice and there's even a little button
there where i can install different
packages so if i click on that button
and open the terminal i can use a simple
pip install to install different
packages i'm working with let's go ahead
and go back under home and we're going
to launch our notebook and i've already
you know kind of like
the old cooking shows i've already
prepared a lot of my stuff so we don't
have to wait for it to launch because it
takes a few minutes for it to open up a
browser window in this case it's going
to open up chrome because that's my
default that i use and since the script
is pre-done you'll see have a number of
windows open up at the top the one we're
working in and since we're working on
the k n predict whether a person will
have diabetes or not let's go and put
that title in there and i'm also going
to go up here and click on cell
actually we want to go ahead and first
insert a cell below and then i'm going
to go back up to the top cell and i'm
going to change the cell type to
markdown that means this is not going to
run as python it's a markdown language
so if i run this first one it comes up
in nice big letters which is kind of
nice remind us what we're working on and
by now you should be familiar with doing
all of our imports we're going to import
the pandas as pd import numpy is np
pandas is the pandas data frame and
numpy is a number array very powerful
tools to use in here so we have our
imports so we've brought in our pandas
our numpy our two general python tools
and then you can see over here we have
our train test split by now you should
be familiar with splitting the data we
want to split part of it for training
our thing and then training our
particular model and then we want to go
ahead and test the remaining data to see
how good it is pre-processing a standard
scalar preprocessor so we don't have a
bias of really large numbers remember in
the data we had like number of
pregnancies isn't going to get very
large where the amount of insulin they
take can get up to 256. so 256 versus 6
that will skew results so we want to go
ahead and change that so they're all
uniform between -1 and 1. and then the
actual tool this is the k neighbors
classifier we're going to use
and finally the last three are three
tools to test all about testing our
model how good is it we just put down
test on there and we have our confusion
matrix our f1 score and our accuracy so
we have our two general python modules
we're importing and then we have our six
modules specific from the
learn setup and then we do need to go
ahead and run this so these are actually
imported there we go and then move on to
the next step and so in this set we're
going to go ahead and load the database
we're going to use pandas remember
pandas is pd and we'll take a look at
the data in python we looked at it in a
simple spreadsheet but usually i like to
also pull it up so we can see what we're
doing so here's our data set equals
pd.read csv that's a pandas command and
the diabetes folder i just put in the
same folder where my ipython script is
if you put in a different folder you
need the full length on there we can
also do a quick length of the data set
that is a simple python command len for
length we might even let's go ahead and
print that we'll go print and if you do
it on its own line link that data set
the jupyter notebook it'll automatically
print it but when you're in most of your
different setups you want to do the
print in front of there and then we want
to take a look at the actual data set
and since we're in pandas we can simply
do data set head and again let's go
ahead and add the print in there
if you put a bunch of these in a row you
know the data set one head data set two
head it only prints out the last one so
i usually always like to keep the print
statement in there but because most
projects only use one data frame panda's
data frame doing it this way doesn't
really matter the other way works just
fine and you can see when we hit the run
button we have the 768 lines which we
knew and we have our pregnancies it's
automatically given a label on the left
remember the head only shows the first
five lines so we have zero through four
and just a quick look at the data you
can see it matches what we looked at
before we have pregnancy glucose blood
pressure all the way to age and then the
outcome on the end and we're going to do
a couple things in this next step we're
going to create a list of columns where
we can't have zero there's no such thing
as zero skin thickness or zero blood
pressure zero glucose uh any of those
you'd be dead so not a really good
factor if they don't if they have a zero
in there because they didn't have the
data and we'll take a look at that
because we're going to start replacing
that information with a couple of
different things and let's see what that
looks like so first we create a nice
list as you can see we have the values
talked about glucose blood pressure skin
thickness
and this is a nice way when you're
working with columns is to list the
columns you need to do some kind of
transformation on a very common thing to
do and then for this particular setup we
certainly could use the there's some
panda tools that will do a lot of this
where we can replace the n a but we're
going to go ahead and do it as a data
set column equals data set column dot
replace this is this is still pandas you
can do a direct there's also one that's
that you look for your nan a lot of
different options in here but the nan
numpy nan is what that stands for is
none it doesn't exist so the first thing
we're doing here is we're replacing the
zero with a numpy none there's no data
there that's what that says that's what
this is saying right here so put the
zero in and we're going to play zeroes
with no data so if it's a zero that
means the person's well hopefully not
dead hope they just didn't get the data
the next thing we want to do is we're
going to create the mean which is the
integer from the data set from the
column dot mean where we skip n a's we
can do that that is a pandas command
there the skip n a so we're going to
figure out the mean of that data set and
then we're going to take that data set
column and we're going to replace all
the n p n a n with the means why did we
do that and we could have actually just
taken this step and gone right down here
and just replaced zero and skip anything
were except you could actually there's a
way to skip zeros and then just replace
all the zeros but in this case we want
to go ahead and do it this way so you
can see that we're switching this to a
non-existent value then we're going to
create the mean well this is the average
person so if we don't know what it is if
they did not get the data and the data
is missing one of the tricks is you
replace it with the average what is the
most common data for that this way you
can still use the rest of those values
to do your computation and it kind of
just brings that particular value of
those missing values out of the equation
let's go ahead and take this and we'll
go ahead and run it doesn't actually do
anything so we're still preparing our
data if you want to see what that looks
like we don't have anything in the first
few lines just not going to show up but
we certainly could look at a row let's
do that let's go into our data set with
printed data set
and let's pick in this case let's just
do
glucose and if i run this this is going
to print all the different glucose
levels going down and we thankfully
don't see anything in here that looks
like missing data at least on the ones
it shows you can see it skipped a bunch
in the middle that's what it does if you
have too many lines in jupiter notebook
it'll skip a few and go on to the next
in a data set let me go and remove this
and we'll just zero out that and of
course before we do any processing
before proceeding any further we need to
split the data set into our train and
testing data that way we have something
to train it with and something to test
it on and you're going to notice we did
a little something here with the pandas
database code there we go my drawing
tool we've added in this right here
off the data set and what this says is
that the first one in pandas this is
from the pd pandas it's going to say
within the data set we want to look at
the eye location and it is all rows
that's what that says so we're going to
keep all the rows but we're only looking
at 0 column 0 to 8. remember column 9
here it is right up here we printed it
in here is outcome well that's not part
of the training data that's part of the
answer yes column 9 but it's listed as
eight number eight so zero to eight is
nine columns so eight is the value and
when you see it in here zero this is
actually zero to seven it doesn't
include the last one and then we go down
here to y which is our answer and we
want just the last one just column eight
and you can do it this way with this
particular notation and then if you
remember we imported the train test
split that's part of the sklearn right
there and we simply put in our x and our
y we're going to do random state equals
zero you don't have to necessarily seat
it that's a seed number i think the
default is one when you seed it i have
to look that up and then the test size
test size is 0.2 that simply means we're
going to take 20 of the data and put it
aside so that we can test it later
that's all that is and again we're going
to run it not very exciting so far we
haven't had any printout other than to
look at the data but that is a lot of
this is prepping this data once you prep
it the actual lines of code are quick
and easy and we're almost there with the
actual writing of our knn we need to go
ahead and do a scale the data if you
remember correctly we're fitting the
data in a standard scalar which means
instead of the data being from you know
5 to 303 in one column and the next
column is one to six we're going to set
that all so that all the data is between
minus one and one that's what that
standard scalar does keeps it
standardized and we only want to fit the
scalar with the training set but we want
to make sure the testing set is the x
test going in is also transformed so
it's processing it the same so here we
go with our standard scalar we're going
to call it sc underscore x for the
scalar and we're going to import the
standard scalar into this variable and
then our x train equals sc underscore x
dot fit transform so we're creating the
scalar on the x train variable and then
our x test we're also going to transform
it so
we've trained and transformed the x
train and then the x test
isn't part of that training it isn't
part of that of training the transformer
it just gets transformed that's all it
does and again we're going to go and run
this and if you look at this we've now
gone through these steps all three of
them we've taken care of replacing our
zeros for key
columns that shouldn't be zero and we
replace that with the means
of those columns that way that they fit
right in with our data models we've come
down here we split the data so now we
have our test data and our training data
and then we've taken and we've scaled
the data so all of our data going in no
no we don't we don't train the y part
the y train and y test that never has to
be trained it's only the data going in
that's what we want to train in there
then define the model using k neighbors
classifier and fit the train data in the
model so we do all that data prep and
you can see down here we're only going
to have a couple lines of code where
we're actually building our model and
training it that's one of the cool
things about python and how far we've
come it's such an exciting time to be in
machine learning because there's so many
automated tools let's see before we do
this let's do a quick length of and
let's do y we want let's just do length
of y
and we get 768 and if we import
math we do math dot square root let's do
y
train there we go it's actually supposed
to be x train
before we do this let's go ahead and do
import math and do math square root
length of y test and when i run that we
get 12.409
i want to show you where this number
comes from we're about to use 12 is an
even number so if you know if you're
ever voting on things remember the
neighbors all vote don't want to have an
even number of neighbors voting so we
want to do something odd and let's just
take one away we'll make it 11. let me
delete this out of here that's one of
the reasons i love jupiter notebook is
you can flip around and do all kinds of
things on the fly so we'll go ahead and
put in our classifier we're creating our
classifier now and it's going to be the
k neighbors classifier n neighbors equal
11. remember we did 12 minus 1 for 11 so
we have an odd number of neighbors p
equals 2 because we're looking for is it
are the diabetic or not and we're using
the euclidean metric there are other
means of measuring the distance you
could do like square square means values
all kinds of measure this but the
euclidean is the most common one and it
works quite well it's important to
evaluate the model let's use the
confusion matrix to do that and we're
going to use the confusion matrix
wonderful tool and then we'll jump into
the f1 score
and finally accuracy score which is
probably the most commonly used quoted
number when you go into a meeting or
something like that so let's go ahead
and paste that in there and we'll set
the cm equal to confusion matrix why
test y predict so those are the two
values we're going to put in there and
let me go ahead and run that and print
it out and the way you interpret this is
you have the y predicted which would be
your title up here you could do uh let's
just do p r e d
predicted across the top
and actual going down actual
it's always hard to to write in here
actual that means that this column here
down the middle that's the important
column and it means that our prediction
said 94 and prediction in the actual
agreed on 94 and 32. this number here
the 13 and the 15 those are what was
wrong so you could have like three
different if you're looking at this
across three different variables instead
of just two you'd end up with the third
row down here in the column going down
the middle so in the first case we have
the the and i believe the zero has a 94
people who don't have diabetes the
prediction said that 13 of those people
did have diabetes and were at high risk
and the 32 that had diabetes it had
correct
but our prediction said another 15 out
of that 15 it classified as incorrect so
you can see where that classification
comes in and how that works on the
confusion matrix then we're going to go
ahead and print the f1 score let me just
run that and you see we get a 0.69 in
our f1 score
the f1 takes into account both sides of
the balance of false positives where if
we go ahead and just do the accuracy
account and that's what most people
think of is it looks at just how many we
got right out of how many we got wrong
so a lot of people when you're a data
scientist and you're talking to other
data scientists they're going to ask you
what the f1 score the f score is if
you're talking to the general public or
the decision makers in the business
they're going to ask what the accuracy
is and the accuracy is always better
than the f1 score but the f1 score is
more telling it lets us know that
there's more false positives than we
would like on here but 82 percent not
too bad for a quick flash look at
people's different statistics and
running an sk learn and running the k n
n the k nearest neighbor on it so we
have created a model using knn which can
predict whether a person will have
diabetes or not or at the very least
whether they should go get a checkup and
have their glucose checked regularly or
not the print accuracy score we got the
0.818 was pretty close to what we got
and we can pretty much round that off
and just say we have an accuracy of 80
tells us it is a pretty fair fit in the
model what is k-means clustering k-means
clustering is an unsupervised learning
algorithm in this case you don't have
labeled data unlike in supervised
learning so you have a set of data and
you want to group them and as the name
suggests you want to put them into
clusters which means objects that are
similar in nature similar in
characteristics need to be put together
so that's what k means clustering is all
about the term k is basically is a
number so we need to tell the system how
many clusters we need to perform so if k
is equal to two there will be two
clusters if k is equal to three three
clusters and so on and so forth that's
what the k stands for and of course
there is a way of finding out what is
the best or optimum value of k for a
given data we will look at that so that
is k means clustering so
let's take an example k-means clustering
is used in many many scenarios but let's
take an example of cricket the game of
cricket let's say you received
data of a lot of players from maybe all
over the country or all over the world
and this data has information about
the runs scored by the people ordered by
the player and the wickets taken by the
player and based on this information we
need to cluster this data into two
clusters batsman and bowlers so this is
an interesting example let's see how we
can perform this so we have the data
which consists of primarily two
characteristics which is the runs and
the wickets so the bowlers basically
take wickets and the batsmen score runs
there will be of course a few bowlers
who can
score some runs and similarly there will
be some batsmen who will who would have
taken a few wickets but with this
information we want to cluster those
players into batsmen and bowlers so how
does this work let's say this is how the
data is so there are information there
is information on the y-axis about the
run scored and on the x-axis about the
wickets taken by the players so if we do
a quick plot this is how it would look
and
when we do the clustering we need to
have the clusters like shown in the
third diagram rtms we need to have a
cluster which consists of people who
have scored high runs which is basically
the batsman and then we need a cluster
with people who have taken a lot of
wickets which is typically the bowlers
there may be a certain amount of overlap
but we will not talk about it right now
so with k-means clustering we will have
here that means k is equal to 2 and we
will have two clusters which is batsman
and bowlers so how does this work the
way it works is the first step in
k-means clustering is the allocation of
two centroids randomly so two points are
assigned as so-called centroids so in
this case we want two clusters which
means k is equal to two so two points
have been randomly assigned as centroids
keep in mind
these points can be anywhere there are
random points they are not initially
they are not really the centroids
centroid means it's a central point of a
given data set but in this case when it
starts off it's not really the centroid
okay so these points though in our
presentation here we have shown them one
point closer to these data points and
another closer to these data points they
can be assigned randomly anywhere okay
so that's the first step the next step
is to determine the distance of each of
the data points
from each of the
randomly assigned centroids so for
example we take this point and find the
distance from this centroid and the
distance from this centroid this point
is taken and the distance is found from
this centroid and the center and so on
and so forth so
for every point the distance is measured
from both the centroids
and then
whichever distance is less that point is
assigned to that centroid so for example
in this case visually it is very obvious
that all these data points are assigned
to this centroid and all these data
points are assigned to this centroid and
that's what is represented here in blue
color and in this yellow color the next
step is to actually determine
the central point or the actual centroid
for these two clusters so we have this
one
initial cluster this one initial cluster
but as you can see these points are not
really the centroid centroid means it
should be the
central position of this data set
central position of this data set so
that is what needs to be determined as
the next step so the central point of
the actual centroid is determined and
the original randomly allocated centroid
is repositioned to the actual centroid
of these new clusters and this process
is actually repeated now what might
happen is some of these points may get
reallocated in our example that is not
happening probably but it may so happen
that the distance is found between each
of these data points once again with
these centroids and if there is if it is
required some points may be reallocated
we will see that in a later example but
for now we will keep it simple so this
process is continued till the centroid
repositioning stops and that is our
final cluster so this is our so after
iteration we come to this position this
situation where the centroid doesn't
need any more repositioning and that
means our algorithm has converged
convergence has occurred and we have the
cluster two clusters we have the
clusters with a centroid so this process
is repeated the process of calculating
the distance and repositioning the
centroid is repeated till the
repositioning stops which means that the
algorithm has converged and we have the
final cluster with the data points and
the centroids so this is what you're
going to learn from this session we will
talk about the types of clustering what
is k-means clustering application of
k-means clustering k-means clustering is
done using distance measure so we will
talk about the common distance measures
and then we will talk about how k-means
clustering works and go into the details
of k-means clustering algorithm and then
we will end with a demo and a use case
for k-means clustering so let's begin
first of all what are the types of
clustering there are primarily two
categories of clustering hierarchical
clustering and then partitional
clustering and each of these categories
are further subdivided into
agglomerative and divisive clustering
and k-means and fuzzy c means clustering
let's take a quick look at what each of
these types of clustering are
in hierarchical clustering the clusters
have a tree-like structure and
hierarchical clustering is further
divided into agglomerative and divisive
the glomerative clustering is a
bottom-up approach we begin with each
element as a separate cluster and merge
them into successively larger clusters
so for example we have a b c d e f we
start by combining b and c form one
cluster d e and e form one more then we
combine d e and f one more bigger
cluster and then add bc to that and then
finally a to it compared to that
divisive clustering or divisive
clustering is a top down approach we
begin with the whole set and proceed to
divide it into successively smaller
clusters so we have abcdef we first take
that as a single cluster and then break
it down
into a b c d
e and f
then we have partitional clustering
split into two subtypes k means
clustering and fuzzy c means in k means
clustering the objects are divided into
the number of clusters mentioned by the
number k that's where the k comes from
so if we say k is equal to 2 the objects
are divided into two clusters c1 and c2
and the way it is done is the features
or characteristics are compared and all
objects having similar characteristics
are clubbed together so that's how k
means clustering is done we will see it
in more detail as we move forward and
fuzzy c means is very similar to k means
in the sense that it clubs objects that
have similar characteristics together
but while in k means clustering two
objects cannot belong to or any object a
single object cannot belong to two
different clusters in c means objects
can belong to more than one cluster so
that is the primary difference between
k-means and fuzzy c means
so what are some of the applications of
k-means clustering k-means clustering is
used in a variety of examples or variety
of business cases in real life
starting from academic performance
diagnostic systems search engines and
wireless sensor networks and many more
so let us take a little deeper look at
each of these examples academic
performance so based on the scores of
the students students are categorized
into a b c and so on clustering forms a
backbone of search engines when a search
is performed the search results need to
be grouped together the search engines
very often use clustering to do this
and similarly in case of wireless sensor
networks the clustering algorithm plays
the role of finding the cluster heads
which collects all the data in its
respective cluster so clustering
especially k means clustering uses
distance measure so let's take a look at
what is distance measure so while these
are the different types of clustering in
this video we will focus on k-means
clustering so distance measure tells
how similar some objects are so the
similarity is measured using what is
known as distance measure and what are
the various types of distance measures
there is euclidean distance there is
manhattan distance then we have squared
euclidean distance measure and cosine
distance measure these are some of the
distance measures supported by k-means
clustering let's take a look at each of
these
what is euclidean distance measure this
is nothing but the distance between two
points so we have learnt in high school
how to find the distance between two
points this is a little sophisticated
formula for that but we know a simpler
one is square root of y2 minus y1 whole
square plus x2 minus x1 whole square so
this is an extension of that formula so
that is the euclidean distance between
two points what is the squared euclidean
distance measure it's nothing but the
square of the euclidean distance as the
name suggests so instead of taking the
square root we leave the square as it is
and then we have manhattan distance
measure in case of manhattan distance it
is the sum of the distances across the
x-axis and the y-axis
and note that we are taking the absolute
value so that the negative values don't
come into play so that is the manhattan
distance measure then we have cosine
distance measure in this case we take
the angle between the two vectors formed
by joining the points from the origin so
that is the cosine distance measure okay
so that was a quick overview about the
various distance measures that are
supported by k-means now let's go and
check how exactly k-means clustering
works
okay so this is how k-means clustering
works this is like a flowchart of the
whole process there is a starting point
and then we specify the number of
clusters that we want now there are a
couple of ways of doing this we can do
by trial and error so we specify a
certain number maybe k is equal to 3 or
4 or 5 to start with and then as we
progress we keep changing until we get
the best clusters or there is a
technique called elbow technique whereby
we can determine the value of k what
should be the best value of k how many
clusters should be formed so once we
have the value of k we specify that and
then the system will assign that many
centroids so it picks randomly that to
start with randomly that many points
that are considered to be the centroids
of these clusters and then it measures
the distance of each of the data points
from these centroids and assigns those
points to the corresponding centroid
from which the distance is minimum so
each data point will be assigned to the
centroid which is closest to it and
thereby we have k number of initial
clusters however this is not the final
clusters the next step it does is
for the new groups for the clusters that
have been formed it calculates the main
position thereby calculates the new
centroid position the position of the
centroid moves compared to the randomly
allocated one so it's an iterative
process once again the distance of each
point is measured from this new centroid
point and if required the data points
are reallocated to the new centroids and
the mean position or the new centroid is
calculated once again if the centroid
moves then the iteration continues which
means the convergence has not happened
the clustering has not converged so as
long as there is a movement of the
centroid this iteration keeps happening
but once the centroid stops moving which
means that the cluster has converged or
the clustering process has converged
that will be the end result so now we
have the final position of the centroid
and the data points are allocated
accordingly to the closest centroid i
know it's a little difficult to
understand from this simple flowchart so
let's do a little bit of visualization
and see if we can explain it better
let's take an example if we have a data
set for a grocery shop so let's say we
have a data set for a grocery shop and
now we want to find out how many
clusters this has to be spread across
so how do we find the optimum number of
clusters there is a technique called the
elbow method so when these clusters are
formed there is a parameter called
within sum of squares and the lower this
value is the better the cluster is that
means
all these points are very close to each
other so we use this within sum of
squares as a measure to find the optimum
number of clusters that can be formed
for a given data set so we create
clusters or we let the system create
clusters of a variety of numbers maybe
of 10
10 clusters and for each value of k the
within ss is measured and the value of k
which has the least amount of within ss
or wss that is taken as the optimum
value of k so this is the diagrammatic
representation so we have on the y axis
the within sum of squares or wss and on
the x-axis we have the number of
clusters so as you can imagine if you
have k is equal to 1 which means all the
data points are in a single cluster the
within s value will be very high because
they are probably scattered all over the
moment you split it into two there will
be a drastic fall in the within ss value
that's what is represented here but then
as the value of k increases the decrease
the rate of decrease
will not be so high it will continue to
decrease but probably the rate of
decrease will not be high so that gives
us an idea so from here we get an idea
for example
the optimum value of k should be
either 2 or 3 or at the most 4 but
beyond that
increasing the number of clusters is not
dramatically changing the value in wss
because that pretty much gets stabilized
okay now that we have got the value of k
and let's assume that these are our
delivery points the next step is
basically
to assign two centroids randomly so
let's say c1 and c2 are the centroids
assigned randomly now the distance of
each
location from the centroid is measured
and each point is assigned to the
centroid which is closest to it so for
example
these points are very obvious that these
are closest to c1 whereas this point is
far away from c2 so these points will be
assigned which are close to c1 will be
assigned to c1 and these points or
locations which are close to c2 will be
assigned to c2 and then so this is the
how the initial grouping is done this is
part of c1 and this is part of c2 then
the next step is to calculate the actual
centroid of this data because remember
c1 and c2 are not the centroids they
have been
randomly assigned points and only thing
that has been done was the data points
which are closest to them have been
assigned
but now in this step the actual centroid
will be calculated which may be for each
of these data sets somewhere in the
middle so that's like the main point
that will be calculated
and the centroid will actually be
positioned
or repositioned there
same with c2
so the new centroid for this group is c2
in this new position and c1 is in this
new position
once again
the distance of each of the data points
is calculated from these centroids now
remember it's not necessary that the
distance still remains the or each of
these data points still remain in the
same group by recalculating the distance
it may be possible that some points get
reallocated like so you see this
so this point earlier was closer to c2
because c2 was here
but after recalculating repositioning it
is observed that this is closer to c1
than c2 so this is the new grouping so
some points will be reassigned and again
the centroid will be calculated and if
the centroid doesn't change so that is
the repetitive process iterative process
and if the centroid doesn't change once
the centroid stops changing that means
the algorithm has converged and this is
our final cluster with this as the
centroid c1 and c2 as the centroids
these data points as a part of each
cluster so i hope this helps in
understanding the whole process
iterative process of k-means clustering
so let's take a look at the k-means
clustering algorithm let's say we have
x1 x2 x3 n number of points as our
inputs and we want to split this
into k clusters or we want to create k
clusters so the first step is to
randomly pick k points and call them
centroids they are not real centroids
because centroid is supposed to be a
center point but they are just called
centroids and we calculate the distance
of each and every input point from each
of the centroids so the distance of x1
from c1 from c2 c3 each of the distances
we calculate and then find out which
distance is the lowest and assign x1 to
that particular random centroid repeat
that process for x2 calculate its
distance
from each of the centroids c1 c2 c3 up
to ck and find which is the lowest
distance and assign x2 to that
particular centroid same with x3 and so
on so that is the first round of
assignment that is done now we have k
groups because there are we have
assigned the value of k so there are k
centroids
and so there are k groups all these
inputs have been split into k groups
however remember we picked the centroids
randomly so they are not real centroids
so now what we have to do we have to
calculate the actual centroids for each
of these groups which is like the mean
position which means that the position
of the randomly selected
centroids will now change
and they will be
the main positions of these newly formed
k groups and once that is done we once
again repeat this process of calculating
the distance right so this is what we
are doing as a part of step four we
repeat step two and three so we again
calculate the distance of x1
from
the centroid c1
c2 c3 and then c which is the lowest
value and assign x1 to that
calculate the distance of x2 from c1 c2
c3 or whatever
up to ck and find whichever is the
lowest distance and assign x2 to that
centroid and so on in this process there
may be some reassignment x1 pro was
probably assigned to cluster c2 and
after doing this calculation maybe now
x1 is assigned to c1 so that kind of
reallocation may happen so we repeat the
steps 2 and 3 till the position of the
centroids don't change or stop changing
and that's when we have convergence
so let's take a detailed look at each of
these steps so we randomly pick k
cluster centers we call them centroids
because they are not initially they are
not really the centroids so we let us
name them c1 c2 up to ck and then step
two we assign each data point to the
closest center so what we do we
calculate the distance of each x value
from each c value so the distance
between
x1 c1 distance between x1 c2 x1 c3 and
then we find which is the lowest value
right that's the minimum value we find
and assign x1 to that particular
centroid then we go next to x2 find the
distance of x2 from c1 x2 from c2 x2
from c3 and so on up to ck and then
assign it to the point or to the
centroid which has the lowest value and
so on so that is step number two in step
number three we now find the actual
centroid for each group so what has
happened as a part of step number two
we now have all the points all the data
points
grouped into k groups because we we
wanted to create k clusters right so we
have k groups each one may be having a
certain number of input values they need
not be equally distributed by the way
based on the distance we will have k
groups but remember the initial values
of the c1 c2 were not really the
centroids of these groups right we
assigned them randomly so now in step 3
we actually calculate the centroid of
each group which means the original
point which we thought was the centroid
will shift to the new position which is
the actual centroid for each of these
groups okay and we again calculate the
distance so we go back to step two which
is what we calculate again the distance
of each of these points from the newly
positioned centroids and if required we
reassign these points to the new
centroids so as i said earlier there may
be a reallocation so we now have a new
set or a new group we still have k
groups
but the number of items and the actual
assignment may be different from what
was in step
two here okay so that might change then
we perform step three once again to find
the new centroid of this new group so we
have again a new set of clusters new
centroids and new assignments
we repeat this step two again once again
we find and then it is possible that
after iterating through three or four or
five times the centroid will stop moving
in the sense that when you calculate the
new value of the centroid that will be
same as the original value or there will
be very marginal change so that is when
we say convergence has occurred and that
is our final cluster that's the
formation of the final cluster
all right so let's see a couple of demos
of k-means clustering we will actually
see some live demos in
python notebook using pattern notebook
but before that let's find out what's
the problem that we are trying to solve
the problem statement is let's say
walmart wants to open a chain of stores
across the state of florida and
it wants to find the optimal store
locations now the issue here is if they
open too many stores close to each other
obviously they will not make profit but
if they if the stores are too far apart
then they will not have enough sales
so how do they optimize this now
for an organization like walmart which
is an e-commerce giant
they already have the addresses of their
customers in their database so they can
actually use this information or this
data and use k-means clustering to find
the optimal location now before we go
into the python notebook and show you
the live code
i wanted to take you through very
quickly a summary of the code in the
slides and then we will go into the
python notebook so in this
block we are basically
importing all the required libraries
like numpy
matplotlib and so on
and we are loading the data that is
available in the form of let's say the
addresses
for simplicity's sake we will just take
them as some data points then the next
thing we do is quickly do a scatter plot
to see
how they are
related to each other with respect to
each other so in the scatter plot we see
that there are a few distinct
groups
already being formed so you can actually
get an idea about how the cluster would
look and how many clusters what is the
optimal number of clusters and then
starts the actual
k-means clustering process
so we will assign
each of these points to the centroids
and then check whether they are
the optimal distance which is the
shortest distance and assign each of the
points data points to the centroids and
then go through this iterative process
till the whole process converges and
finally we get an output like this so we
have four distinct clusters
and
which is we can say that this is how the
population is probably distributed
across florida state and
these centroids are
like the location where the store should
be the optimum location where the store
should be so that's the way we determine
the best locations for the store and
that's how we can help walmart find the
best locations for their stores in
florida so now let's
take this into python notebook let's see
how this looks when we are running
running the code live all right so this
is the code for k-means clustering in
jupiter notebook we have a few examples
here which we will demonstrate how
k-means clustering is used and even
there is a small implementation of
k-means clustering as well okay so let's
get started okay so this block is
basically importing the various
libraries that are required like
matplotlib and numpy and so on and so
forth which would be used as a part of
the code then we are going and creating
blobs which are similar to clusters now
this is a very neat feature which is
available in scikit-learn make blobs is
a nice feature which creates clusters of
data sets so that's a wonderful
functionality that is readily available
for us to create some test data kind of
thing okay so that's exactly what we are
doing here we are using make blobs and
we can specify how many clusters we want
so centers we are mentioning here so it
will go ahead and so we just mentioned
four so it will go ahead and create some
test data for us
and this is how it looks as you can see
visually also we can figure out that
there are four distinct classes or
clusters in this data set and that is
what make blobs really provides
now from
here onwards we will basically
run the standard k-means functionality
that is readily available so we really
don't have to implement k-means itself
the k-means functionality or the
function is readily available you just
need to feed the data and we'll create
the clusters so this is the code for
that
we import k-means and then we create an
instance of k-means and we specify the
value of k this n underscore clusters is
the value of k remember k means in k
means k is basically the number of
clusters that you want to create and it
is a
integer value so this is where we are
specifying that so we have k is equal to
and so that instance is created we take
that instance and as
with any other machine learning
functionality fit is what we use the
function or the method rather fit is
what we use to train the model here
there is no real training uh kind of
thing but that's the call okay so we are
calling fit and what we are doing here
we are just passing the data so x has
these values the data that has been
created
right so that is what we are passing
here
and
this will go ahead and create the
clusters and
then we are using
after doing uh fit we run the predict
which uh basically assigns for each of
these observations which cluster where
it belongs to all right so it will name
the clusters maybe this is cluster one
this is two 3 and so on or i will
actually start from 0 cluster 0 1 2 and
3 maybe and then for each of the
observations it will assign based on
which cluster it belongs to it will
assign a value so that is stored in
y underscore k means when we call
predict that is what it does
and we can take a quick look at these uh
y underscore k means solve with the
cluster numbers that have been assigned
for each observation so this is the
cluster number assigned for observation
1 maybe this is for observation 2
observation 3 and so on so we have how
many about i think 300 samples right so
all the 300 samples there are 300 values
here each of them the cluster number is
given and the cluster number goes from 0
to 3 so there are four clusters so the
numbers go from 0 1 2 3. so that's what
is seen here okay now so this was a
quick example of generating some dummy
data and then clustering that okay and
this can be applied if you have proper
data you can just load it up into x for
example here and then run the cable so
this is the central part of the k-means
clustering program example so you
basically create an instance and you
mention how many clusters you want by
specifying this parameter and underscore
clusters and that is also the value of k
and then pass the data to get the values
now the next section of this code is the
implementation of a k-means now this is
kind of a rough implementation of the
k-means algorithm so we will just walk
you through i will walk you through the
code uh at each step what it is doing
and then we will see a couple of more
examples of how k-means clustering uh
can be used in maybe some real life
examples real-life use cases all right
so in this case here what we are doing
is basically implementing k means
clustering and there is a function or a
library calculates for a given two pairs
of points it will calculate the the
distance between them and see which one
is the closest and so on so this is like
this is pretty much like what k means
does right so it calculates the distance
of each point or each data set from
predefined centroid and then based on
whichever is the lowest this particular
data point is assigned to that centroid
so that is basically available as a
standard function and we will be using
that here so as explained in the slides
the first step that is done in case of
k-means clustering is to randomly assign
some centroids so as a first step we
randomly allocate a couple of centroids
which we call here we are calling as
centers
and then we put this in a loop and we
take it through an iterative process
for each of the data points we first
find out using this function pairwise
distance argument for each of the points
we find out which one which center or
which randomly selected centroid is the
closest and accordingly we assign the
data or the data point to that
particular centroid or cluster and once
that is done for all the data points
we calculate the new centroid by finding
out the mean position because the center
position right so we calculate the new
centroid and then we check if the new
centroid is the coordinates or the
position is the same as the previous
centroid the positions we will compare
and if it is the same that means the
process has converged so remember we do
this process till the centroids or the
centroid doesn't move anymore right so
the centroid gets relocated each time
this reallocation is done so the moment
it doesn't change anymore the position
of the centroid doesn't change anymore
we know that convergence has occurred so
till then so you see here this is like
an infinite loop while true is an
infinite loop it only breaks when the
centers are the same the new center and
the old center positions are the same
and once that is done we return the
centers and the labels now of course as
explained this is not a very
sophisticated and advanced
implementation very basic implementation
because one of the flaws in this is that
sometimes what happens is the centroid
the position
will
keep moving but in the change will be
very minor so in that case also with
that is actually convergence right so
for example the change is 0.0001
we can consider that as convergence
otherwise what will happen is this will
either take forever or it will be never
ending so that's a small flaw here so
that is something additional checks may
have to be added here but again as
mentioned this is not the most
sophisticated implementation uh this is
like a kind of a rough implementation of
the k means clustering okay so if we
execute this code this is what we get as
the output so this is the definition of
this particular function and then we
call that find underscore clusters and
we pass our data x and the number of
clusters which is four and if we run
that and plot it this is the output that
we get so this is of course each cluster
is represented by a different color so
we have a cluster in green color yellow
color and so on and so forth and these
big points here these are the centroids
this is the final position of the
centroids and as you can see visually
also this appears like a kind of a
center of all these points here right
similarly this is like the center of all
these points here and so on so this is
the example or this is an example of an
implementation of k means clustering
and
next we will move on to see a couple of
examples of how k means clustering is
used in maybe some real life scenarios
or use cases in the next example or demo
we are going to see how we can use
k-means clustering to perform color
compression we will take a couple of
images so there will be two examples and
we will try to use k-means clustering to
compress the colors this is a common
situation
in image processing when you have an
image with millions of
colors but then you cannot render it on
some devices which may not have enough
memory uh so that is the
scenario where where something like this
can be used
so
before again we go into the python
notebook let's take a look at quickly
the the code
as usual we import the libraries and
then we import the image and
then we will flatten it so the reshaping
is basically we have the image
information is stored in the form of
pixels and if the image is like for
example 427 by 640 and it has three
colors so that's the overall dimension
of the of the initial image we just
reshape it and
then feed this to our algorithm
and this will then create clusters of
only 16 clusters so this this colors
there are millions of colors and now we
need to bring it down to 16 colors so we
use k is equal to 16
and
this is how when we visualize this is
how it looks there are these are all
about 16 million possible colors the
input color space has 16 million
possible colors and we just
sub compress it to 16 colors so this is
how it would look when we compress it to
16 colors and this is how the original
image looks and
after compression to 16 colors this is
how the new image looks as you can see
there is not a lot of
information that has been lost
though
the image quality is definitely reduced
a little bit
so this is
an example which we are going to now see
in python notebook let's go into the
python node and once again as always we
will import some libraries and
load this image called
flower dot jpg okay so let we load that
and this is how it looks this is the
original image which has i think 16
million colors and this is the shape of
this image which is basically what is
the
shape is nothing but the overall size
right so this is 427 pixel by 640 pixel
and then there are three layers which is
this three basically is for rgb which is
red green blue so color image will have
that right so that is the shape of this
now what we need to do is data let's
take a look at how data is looking so
let me just create a new cell and show
you
what is in data basically we have
captured this information
so data is what let me just show you
here
all right so
let's take a look at
china what are the values in china and
if we see here this is how the data is
stored this is nothing but the pixel
values okay so this is like a matrix and
each one has about four for this 427 by
640 pixels all right so this is how it
looks now the issue here is these values
are large the numbers are a large so we
need to normalize them to between zero
and one right so that's why we will
basically create one more variable which
is data which will contain the values
between zero and one and the way to do
that is divide by 255 so we divide china
by 255 and we get the new values in data
so let's just run this piece of code and
this is the shape so we now have also
yeah what we have done is we changed
using reshape we converted into the
three-dimensional into a two-dimensional
data set and let us also take a look at
how
let me just insert
uh probably a cell here
and take a look at how data is looking
all right so this is how data is looking
and now you see this is
the values are between zero and one
right so if you earlier noticed in case
of china the values were large numbers
now everything is between 0 and 1. this
is one of the things we need to do all
right so after that the next thing that
we need to do is to visualize this and
we can take random set of maybe 10 000
points and plot it and check and see how
this looks let us just plot this
and so this is how the original the
color the pixel distribution is these
are two plots one is red against green
and another is red against blue and this
is the original distribution of the
color so then what we will do is we will
use k means clustering to create just 16
clusters for the various colors and then
apply that to the image now
what will happen is since the data is
large because there are millions of
colors using regular k-means may be a
little time consuming so there is
another version of k-means which is
called mini batch gaming so
we will use that which is which
processes in the overall concept remains
the same but this basically processes it
in smaller batches that's the only thing
okay so the results will pretty much be
the same so let's go ahead and execute
this piece of code and also visualize
this so that we can see that there are
these this is how the 16 colors
would look
so this is red against green and this is
red against blue there is uh quite a bit
of similarity between this original
color schema and the new one right so it
doesn't look very very completely
different or anything like that now we
apply this the newly created colors to
the image and we can take a look uh how
this is looking now we can compare both
the images so this is our original image
and this is our new image so as you can
see there is not a lot of information
that has been lost it pretty much looks
like the original image yes we can see
that for example here there is a little
bit it appears a little dullish compared
to this one right because we kind of
took off some of the finer details of
the color but
overall the high level information has
been maintained at the same time the
main advantage is that now this can be
this is an image which can be rendered
on a device which may not be that very
sophisticated now let's take one more
example with a different image in the
second example we will take an image of
the summer palace in china and we repeat
the same process this is a
high definition color image with
millions of colors and also
three dimensional
now we will reduce that to 16 colors
using k means clustering
and
we do the same process like before we
reshape it and then we cluster the
colors to 16 and then we render the
image once again and we will see that
the color the quality of the image
slightly deteriorates as you can see
here this has much finer details in this
which are probably missing here but then
that's the compromise because there are
some devices which may not be able to
handle
this kind of high density images
so let's run this chord in python
notebook all right so let's apply the
same technique for another picture which
is
even more intricate and has probably
much complicated color schema so this is
the image now once again we can take a
look at the shape which is 427 by 640 by
and this is the new data would look
somewhat like this compared to the
flower image so we have some new values
here
and we will also bring this as you can
see the numbers are much big so we will
much bigger so we will now have to scale
them down to values between 0 and 1 and
that is done by
dividing by 255 so let's go ahead and do
that
and reshape it okay so we get a
two-dimensional matrix
and we will then as a next step we will
go ahead and visualize this how it looks
those the 16 colors
and this is basically how it would look
16 million colors and now we can
create the clusters
out of this the 16
k means clusters we will create so this
is how the distribution of the pixels
would look with 16 colors and then we go
ahead and
apply this
and visualize how it is looking for
with the new just the 16 color so once
again as you can see this looks much
richer in color but at the same time and
this probably doesn't have as we can see
it doesn't look as rich as this one but
nevertheless the information is not lost
the shape and all that stuff and this
can be also rendered on a slightly a
device which is probably
not that sophisticated okay so that's
pretty much it so we have seen two
examples of how color compression can be
done
using k-means clustering
and we have also seen in the previous
examples of how to implement k-means the
code to roughly how to implement k-means
clustering and we use some sample data
using blob to just execute the k-means
clustering we're going to cover
mathematics for machine learning so
today's agenda is going to cover data
and its types and we're going to dive
into linear algebra and its concepts
calculus statistics for machine learning
probability for machine learning
hands-on demos
and of course thrown in there in the
middle is going to be your matrixes and
a few other things to go along with all
this
data in its types
data denotes the individual pieces of
factual information collected from
various sources it is stored processed
and later used for analysis
and so we see here just a huge grouping
of information a lot of tech stuff money
dollar signs numbers
and then you have your performing
analytics to drive insights and
hopefully you have a nice share your
shareholders gather it at the meeting
and you're able to explain it in
something they can understand so we talk
about data types of data
we have in our types of data we have a
qualitative categorical
you think nominal or ordinal
and then you have your quantitative or
numerical which is discrete or
continuous
and let's look a little closer at those
data type vocabulary always people's
favorite is the vocabulary words okay
not mine
but let's dive into this what we mean by
nominal
nominal they are used to label various
uh label our variables without providing
any measurable value
country gender race hair color etc it's
something that you either mark true or
false this is a label it's on or off
either they have a red hat on or they do
not
so a lot of times when you're thinking
nominal data
labels
think of it as a true false kind of
setup and we look at ordinal this is
categorical data with a set order or a
scale to it
and you can think of salary range as a
great one
movie ratings etc you can see here the
salary range if you have 10 000 to 20
000 number of employees earning that
rate is 150 20 000 to 30 thousand a
hundred and so forth some of the terms
you'll hear is bucket uh this is where
you have 10 different buckets and you
want to separate it into something that
makes sense into those 10 buckets
and so when we start talking about
ordinal a lot of times when you get down
to the breast bones again we're talking
true false uh so if you're a member of
the 10 to 20k reigns
uh so forth those would each be either
part of that group or you're not but now
we're talking about buckets and we want
to count how many people are in that
bucket
quantitative numerical data
falls into two classes discrete or
continuous
and so data with a final set of values
which can be categorized class strength
questions answered correctly and runs
hit and cricket
a lot of times when you see this you can
think integer
and a very restricted integer i.e
you can only have a hundred questions um
on a test so you can it's very discreet
i only have a hundred different values
that it can attain
so think usually you're talking about
integers but within a very small range
they don't have an open end or anything
like that
so discrete is very solid
simple to count
set number
continuous on the other hand continuous
data can take any numerical value within
a range so water pressure weight of a
person etc
usually we start thinking about float
values where they can get phenomenally
small in their in what they're worth
and there's a whole series of values
that falls right between discrete and
continuous
you can think of the stock market you
have dollar amounts it's still discrete
but it starts to get complicated enough
when you have like you know jump in the
stock market from
525.33 to
580.67
there's a lot of point values in there
it'd still be called discrete but you
start looking at it as almost continuous
because it does have such a variance in
it now we talked about no we did we went
over nominal and ordinal
almost true false charts and we looked
at quantitative and numerical data which
were starting to get into numbers
discrete you can usually a lot of times
discrete will be put into it could be
put into true false but usually it's not
so we want to address this stuff and the
first thing you want to look at is the
very basic which is your algebra so
we're going to take a look at linear
algebra you can remember back when your
euclidean geometry we have a line well
let's go through this we have a linear
algebra is the domain of mathematics
concerning linear equations
and their representations in vector
spaces and through matrixes i told you
we're going to talk about matrix is
so a linear equation
is simply
2x plus 4y minus 3z equals 10. very
linear 10x plus 12.4y equals z and now
you can actually solve these two
equations by combining them
and that's we're talking about a linear
equation
in the vectors we have a plus b equals c
now we're starting to look at a
direction
and these values usually think of an x y
z plot
so each one is a direction and the
actual distance of like a triangle a b
is c
and then your matrix can describe all
kinds of things
i find matrixes
confuse a lot of people
not because they're particularly
difficult but because
of the magnitude and the different
things they're used for
and a matrix is a chart
or a you know think of a spreadsheet but
you have your rows and your columns
and you'll see here we have a times b
equals c
very important to know your counts
so depending on how the math is being
done what you're using it for making
sure you have the same rows and number
of columns or a single number there's
all kinds of things that play in that
that can make matrixes confusing
but really it has a lot more to do with
what domain you're working in are you
adding in
multiple polynomials where you have like
a x squared plus b y plus you know you
start to see that it can be very
confusing versus a very straightforward
matrix
and let's just go a little deeper into
these because these are such primary
this is what we're here to talk about is
these different math mathematical
computations that come up
so we're looking at linear equations
let's dig deeper into that one an
equation having a maximum order of 1 is
called a linear equation
so it's linear because when you look at
this we have a x plus b equals c which
is a one variable
we have uh two variable a x plus b y
equals c a x plus b y plus z c z equals
d
and so forth but all of these
are to the power of 1 you don't see x
squared you don't see x cubed so we're
talking about linear equations that's
what we're talking about in their
addition
if you have already dived into say
neural networks you should recognize
this ax plus b y plus cz
setup plus the intercept
which is basically your your neural
network each node adding up all the
different inputs and we can drill down
into that most common formula is your y
equals mx plus c
so you have your uh y
equals the m which is your slope
your x value plus c
which is your
y-intercept you kind of labeled it wrong
here uh
threw me for a loop but the the c would
be your y-intercept so when you set x
equal to zero y equals c and that's
that's your y-intercept right there
uh and that's they just had reversed
value of y when x equals 0
equals the y-intercept which is c and
your slow gradient line which is your m
so you get your y equals 2x plus 3.
and there's lots of easy ways to compute
this this way this is why we always
start with the most basic one when we're
solving one of these problems and then
of course the
one of the most important takeaways is
the slope gradient of the line
so the slope is very important that m
value
in this case we went ahead and solved
this
if you have y equals 2x plus 3 you can
see how it has a nice line graph here on
the right
so matrixes a matrix refers to a
rectangular representation of an array
of numbers arranged in columns and rows
so we're talking m rows by n columns
here a11 is denotes the element of the
first row in the first column similarly
a12 and it's really pronounced a11 in
this particular setup so it's a row one
column one a 12 is a
row one column two
first row and second column and so on
and there's a lot of ways to denote this
i've seen these as like a capital letter
a smaller case a for the top row or i
mean you can see where they can go all
kinds of different directions as far as
the value
you just take a moment to realize
there's need to be some designation as
far as what row it's in and what column
it's in
and we have our basic operations we have
addition so when you think about
addition you have
two matrixes of two by two and you just
add each individual number in that
matrix and then when you get to the
bottom you have in this case the
solution is 12 10 plus 2 is 12 5 plus 3
is 8 and so on and the same thing with
subtraction
now again your counting matrix is you
want to check your
dimensions of the matrix
the shape you'll see shape come up a lot
in programming so we're talking about
dimensions we're talking about the shape
if the two shapes are equal
this is what happens when you add them
together or subtract them
and we have multiplication when you look
at the multiplication you end up with a
very a slightly different setup going
now
if we look at our last one we're
we're like why
this always gets to me when we get to
matrixes they don't really say why you
multiply matrixes
you know my first thought is 1 times 2 4
times 3 but if you look at this we get 1
times 2 plus 4 times 3
1 times three plus four times five
uh six times two plus three times three
six times three plus three times five if
you're looking at these matrixes uh
think of this more as an equation
and so we have if you remember we went
back up here for our multiple line
equations let's just go back up a couple
slides where we were looking at a two
variable so this is a two variable
equation a x plus b y equals c
and this is a way to make it very quick
to solve these variables and that's why
you have the matrix and that's why you
do
the multiplication the way they do
and this is the dot product of 1 times 2
plus 4 times three
one times three plus four times five
uh six times two plus three times three
six times three plus three times five
and it gives us a nice little
14 23 21 and 33 over here which then can
be used and reduced down to a sample
formula as far as solving the variables
as you have enough inputs
and then in matrix operations when
you're dealing with a lot of matrixes
now keep in mind multiplying matrixes is
different than finding the product of
two matrixes okay so we're talking about
multiplication we're talking about
solving
for equations when you're finding the
product you are just finding 1 times 2.
keep that in mind because that does come
up i've had that come up a number of
times where i am altering data and i get
confused as to what i'm doing with it
transpose flipping the matrix over is
diagonal comes up all the time where you
have you still have 12 but instead of it
being 12 8 it's now 12 14
8 21 you're just flipping the columns
and the rows
and then of course you can do an inverse
changing the signs of the values across
this main diagonal
and you can see here we have the inverse
a to the minus 1 and ends up with
instead of 12 8 14 12 it's now minus 22
minus 12.
vectors
vector just means we have
a value and a direction
and we have down four numbers here on
our vector
in mathematics a one dimensional matrix
is called a vector
so
if you have your x plot and you have a
single value that values along the x
axis and it's a single dimension
if you have two dimensions you can think
about putting them on a graph you might
have x and you might have y and each
value denotes a direction and then of
course the actual distance is going to
be the hypothesis of that triangle
and you can do that with three
dimensionals x y and z
and you can do it all the way to nth
dimensions so when they talk about the k
means
for categorizing and how close data is
together they will compute that based on
the pythagorean theorem so you would
take
the square of each value add them all
together and find the square root and
that gives you a distance
as far as where that point is where that
vector exists or an actual point value
and then you can compare that point
value to another one it makes a very
easy comparison versus comparing 50 or
60 different numbers
and that brings us up to i gene vectors
and i gene values
uh i gene vectors the vectors that don't
change their span while transformation
and i gene values the scalar values that
are associated to the vectors
conceptually
you can think of the vector as your
picture you have a picture it's uh
two dimensions x and y
and so when you do those two dimensions
and those two values or whatever that
value is
that is that point but the values change
when you skew it and so
if we take and we have a vector a
and that's a set value
b is
your is your you have a and b which is
your i gene vector 2 is the i gene value
so we're altering
all the values by 2. that means we're
maybe we're stretching it out one
direction making it tall if you're doing
picture editing
that's one of the places this comes in
but you can see when you're transforming
uh your different information how you
transform it is then your hygiene value
and you can see here uh vector after
line transit transition uh we have three
a a is the hygiene vector three is the i
aging value so a doesn't change that's
whatever we started with that's your
original picture
and three
is skewing it one direction and maybe uh
a b is being skewed another direction
and so you have a nice tilted picture
because you altered it by those by the
aging values
so let's go ahead and pull up a demo on
linear algebra and to do this i'm going
to go through my trusted anaconda into
my jupiter notebook
and we'll create a new
notebook called linear algebra
since we are working in python we're
going to use our numpy i always import
that as np or numpy array probably the
most popular
module for doing matrixes and things in
given that this is part of a series i'm
not going to go too much into numpy we
are going to go ahead and create two
different variables a for a numpy array
10 15 and b 29.
we'll go ahead and run this and you can
see there's our two arrays 10 15 29 and
i went and added a space there in
between
so it's easier to read
and since it's the last line we don't
have to put the print statement on it
unless you want we can simply but we can
simply do a plus b so when i run this
we have 10 15 29 and we get 30 24 which
is what you expect 10 plus 20 15 plus
nine
you could almost look at this addition
as being um
just adding up the columns on here
coming down and if we wanted to do it a
different way we could also do a dot t
plus b dot t
remember that t flips them and so if we
do that we now get them uh we now have
30 24 going the other way
we could also do something kind of fun
there's a lot of different ways to do
this
as far as a plus b i can also do a plus
b
dot t and you're gonna see that that
will come out the same the 30 24 whether
i transpose a and b or transpose them
both at the end
and likewise we can very easily subtract
two vectors i can go a minus b
and we run that and we get minus 10 6.
now remember this is the last line in
this particular section that's why not
to put the print around it
and just like we did before
we can transpose either the individual
or we can transpose the main set up and
then we get a minus 10 6 going the other
way
now we didn't mention this in our notes
but you can also do a scalar
multiplication
and just put down scalar so you can
remember that
uh what we're talking about here is i
have
this
array here u
and if i go a
times u
we'll take the value 2 we'll multiply it
by every value in here so 2 times 30 is
60 2 times 15
and just like we did before
this happens a lot because when you're
doing matrixes you do need to flip them
you get 60 30 coming this way
so in numpy uh we have they called dot
product
and uh with this this is in a two
dimensional vectors it is the equivalent
of two matrix multiplication remember we
were talking about matrix multiplication
uh where it is the
well let's walk through it
we'll go ahead and start by defining two
um
numpy arrays we'll have uh 10 20 25 6 or
our u and our v uh and then we're going
to go ahead and do
if we take
the values and if you remember correctly
an array like this would be 10 times 25
plus 20 times 6.
we'll go ahead and
print that
there we go
and then we'll go ahead and do the np
dot dot
of u comma
v
and we'll find when we do this we go and
run this
we're going to get
370.
so this is a strain multiplication where
they use it to solve
linear algebra when you have multiple
numbers going across and so this could
be very complicated we could have a
whole string of different variables
going in here but for this we get a nice
value for our dot multiplication
and we did
addition earlier which is just your
basic addition
uh and of course the matrix you can get
very complicated on these or
in this case we'll go ahead and do
let's create two
complex matrixes
this one is a matrix of um you know 12
10 4 6 4 31. we'll just print out a so
you can see what that looks like here's
print
a
we print a out you can see that we have
two by three
layer matrix for a
and we can also put together
always kind of fun when you're playing
with print values uh we could do
something like this we could go in here
there we go
we could print a we have it end with uh
equals a
run
and this kind of gives it a nice look uh
here's your matrix that's all this is
comma n means it just tags it on the end
that's all all that is doing on there
and then we can simply add in what is a
plus b and you should already guess
because this is the same as what we did
before there's no difference
we do a simple vector addition we have
12 plus 2 is 14 10 plus 8 is 18 and so
on
and just like we did the matrix addition
we can also do a minus b
and do our matrix subtraction
and we look at this we have what 12
minus 2 is 10 10 minus 8 um where are we
oh there we go 8 minus
confusing what i'm looking at i should
have reprinted out the original numbers
but we can see here 12 minus 2 is of
course 10 10 minus 8 is 2
4 minus 46 is minus 42 and so forth so
same as a subtraction as before we just
call it matrix subtraction it's
identical
now if you remember up here we had a
scalar addition we're adding just one
number
to a matrix you can also do scalar
multiplication
and so simply if you have a single value
a and you have b which is your array we
can also do a times b
when we run that
you can see here we have 2 times 4 is 8.
5 times 4 is 20 and so forth you're just
multiplying the four across each one of
these values
and this is an interesting one that
comes up
a little bit of a brain teaser is matrix
and vector multiplication
and so when we're looking at this
we are
just do a regular array it doesn't
necessarily have to be a numpy array
we have a
which has our
array of arrays and b which is a single
array and so we can from here
do the dot
a b
and this is going to return two values
and the first value is that is you could
say it's like uh
we're doing the
this array b array
first with a and then with a second one
and so it splits it up so you have a
matrix of vector multiplication and you
can mix and match
when you get into really complicated uh
back end stuff this becomes more common
because you're now you've got layers
upon layers of data and so you you'll
end up with a matrix and a set of bolt
vector matrices do you want to multiply
now keep in mind
that if you're doing data science a lot
of times you're not looking at this this
is what's going on behind the scenes so
if you're in
the scikit looking at sk learn where
you're doing linear regression models
this is some of the math that's hidden
behind the scenes that's going on
other times you might find yourself
having to do part of this and manipulate
the data around so it fits right and
then you go back in and you run it
through the psi kit and if we can do
up here where we did a
matrix in vector multiplication we can
also do matrix two matrix multiplication
and if we run this we have the two
matrixes uh you can see we have a very
complicated array that of course comes
out on there for our dot
and just to reiterate it we have our
transposer matrix which is your dot t
and so if we create a matrix a and we do
transpose it you can see how it flips it
from
5 10 15 20 25 30 to 5 15 25
10 20 30 rows and columns
and certainly with the math this comes
up a lot
it also comes up a lot with xy plotting
when you put in the pi plot you have one
format where they're looking at pairs
and numbers and then they want all of
x's and all y's so you know the
transpose is an important tool both for
your math and for plotting and all kinds
of things
another tool that we didn't discuss
is your identity matrix
uh and this one is more definition
uh the identity matrix um we have here
one where we just did uh two
so it comes down as one zero zero one
one zero zero zero one zero it creates a
diagonal of one and what that is is when
you're doing your identities you could
be comparing
all your different features to the
different features and how they
correlate and of course when you have
feature one compared to feature one to
itself it is always
one
uh where
usually it's between zero one depending
on how well correlates so when we're
talking about identity matrix that's
what we're talking about right here is
that you create this preset matrix and
then you might adjust these numbers
depending on what you're working with
and what the domain is
and then another thing we can do
to kind of wrap this up we'll hit you
with the most complicated uh
piece of this
puzzle here is an inverse
a matrix
and let's just go ahead and put the um
it's a lengthy description
let's go and put the description this is
straight out of the
the website for
numpy
so given a square matrix a here's our
square matrix a which is 2 1 0 0 1 0 1 2
1. keep in mind 3 by 3 is square it's
got to be equal it's going to return the
matrix a inverse satisfying dot a
a inverse so here's our matrix
multiplication
and then of course it equals the dot uh
yeah a inverse of a
with an identity shape of uh a dot
shaped zero this is just reshaping the
identity
that's a little complicated there uh so
we're going to have our here's our array
uh we'll go ahead and run this
and you can see what we end up with
is we end up with uh an array 0.5 minus
0.5 and so forth with our 2 1 1 going
down 2 1 0 zero one zero one two one
um
getting into a little deep on the math
understanding
when you need this is probably really is
is what's really important when you're
doing data science
versus uh handwriting this out and
looking up the math and handwriting all
the pieces out you do need to know about
the linear algorithm inverse of a
so if it comes up you can easily pull it
up or at least remember where to look it
up we took a look at the algebra side of
it let's go ahead and take a look at the
calculus side of what's going on here
with the machine learning so
calculus oh my goodness and differential
equations you got to throw that in there
because that's all part of the
bag of tricks especially when you're
doing large neural networks but also
comes up in many other areas the good
news is most of it's already done for
you in the back end
so when it comes up you really do need
to understand from the data science not
data analytics data analytics means
you're digging deep into
actually solving these math equations
and a neural network is just a giant
differential equation
uh so we talk about calculus uh we're
going to go ahead
and understand it by talking about cars
versus time and speed
uh so helps to calculate the spontaneous
rate of change
uh so suppose we plot a graph of the
speed of a car with respect to time
so as you can see here going down the
highway probably merged into the highway
from an on-ramp so i had to accelerate
so my speed went way up
stuck in traffic merged into the traffic
traffic opens up and i accelerate again
up to the speed limit
and
maybe peter's off up there so you can
look at this is as
the speed versus time i'm getting faster
and faster because i'm continually
accelerating and if i hit the brakes you
go the other way
so the rate of change of speed with
respect of time is nothing but
acceleration how fast are we
accelerating
the acceleration is the area between the
star point of x and the endpoint of
delta x
uh so we can calculate a simple if you
had x and delta x we could put a line
there
and that slope of the line is our
acceleration
now that's pretty easy when you're doing
linear algebra but i don't want to know
it just for that line in those two
points i want to know across the whole
of what i'm working with
that's where we get into calculus
so we talk about the distance between x
and delta x it has to be the smallest
possible near to zero in order to
approximate the acceleration
so the idea is instead of i mean if you
ever did took a basic calculus class
they would draw bars down here and you
would divide this area up
let's go back up the screen you divide
this area of this time period up into
maybe 10 sections and you'd use that and
you could calculate the acceleration
between each one of those 10 sections
kind of thing
and then we just keep making that space
smaller and smaller until delta x is
almost
infinitesimally small
and so we get a function of a
equals a limit as h goes to 0 of a
function of a plus h minus a function of
a over h and that is you're
computing the slope of the line
we're just computing that slope and
they're smaller and smaller and smaller
samples
and that's what calculus is calculus is
the integral you can see down here we
have our nice uh integral sign looks
like a giant s
and that's what that means is that we've
taken this down to as small as we can
for that sampling
so we're talking about calculus we're
finding the area under the slope is the
main process in the integration
similar small intervals are made of the
smallest possible length of x plus delta
x where delta x approaches almost an
infinitesimally small space
and then it helps to find the overall
acceleration by summing up all the links
together uh so we're summing up all the
accelerations from the beginning to the
end
and so here's our integral we sum of a
of x times d of x
equals a plus c
that is our basic calculus here
so when we talk about multivariate
calculus
multivariate calculus deals with
functions that have multiple variables
and you can see here we start getting
into some very complicated equations um
uh change in w over change of time
equals change of w over change of z
the differential of z to dx differential
of x to dt it gets pretty complicated uh
it really translates into the
multivariate integration using double
integrals and so you have the the sum of
the sum of f of x of y of d of a equals
the sum from c to d and a to b of f of x
y d x d y equals
the sum of a to b sum of c to d of f x
of y d y d x
understanding the very specifics of
everything going on in here and actually
doing the math is use the calculus 1
calculus 2 and differential equations
so you're talking about three full
length courses to dig into
and solve these math equations
what we want to take from here is we're
talking about calculus we're talking
about summing of all these different
slopes and so we're still solving a
linear uh expression we're still solving
y equals m x plus b
but we're doing this for infinitesimally
small x's and then we want to sum them
up that's what this integral sign means
the sum of a of x d of x equals a plus c
and when you see these very complicated
multivariate differentiation using the
chain rule uh when we come in here and
we have the change of w to the change of
t equals the change of w dz
uh and so forth that's what's going on
here that's what these means we're
basically looking for the area under the
curve which really comes to
how is the change changing speeds going
up how is that changing and then you end
up with a multiple layer so if i have
three layers of neural networks how is
the third layer changing based on the
second layer changing which is based on
the first layer changing and you get the
picture here that now we have a very
complicated
multivariate integration
with integrals
the good news is we can solve this
mathematically and that's what we do
when you do neural networks and reverse
propagation
so the nice thing is that you don't have
to solve this on paper unless you're a
data analysis and you're working on the
back end of integrating these formulas
and building the script to actually
build them so we talk about applications
of calculus it provides us the tools to
build an accurate predictive model
so it's really behind the scenes we want
to guess at what the change of the
change of the change is
that's a little goofy i know i just
threw that out there it's kind of a meta
term but if you can guess how things are
going to change then you can guess what
the new numbers are
multivariate calculus explains the
change in our target variable in
relation to the rate of change in the
input variables
so there's our multiple variables going
in there if one variable is changing how
does it affect the other variable
and then in gradient descent calculus is
used to find the local and global maxima
and this is really big uh we're actually
going to have a whole section here on
gradient descent because it is
really i mean i talked about neural
networks and how you can see how the
different layers go in there but
gradient descent is one of the most key
things for trying to guess the best
answer to something
so let's take a look at the code behind
gradient descent
and before we open up the code let's
just do real quick
uh gradient descent
let's say we have a curve like this and
most common
is that this is going to represent your
error oops
error there we go there
hard to read there and i want to make
the error as low as possible
and so what i'm looking at it is i want
to find this line here
which is the
minimum value so we're looking for the
minimum
and it does that by
sampling there
and then based on this it guesses it
might be someplace here and it goes hey
this is still going down
it goes here and then goes back over
here and then goes a little bit closer
and it's just playing a high low until
it gets to that spot that bottom spot
and so we want to minimize the error and
on the flip note you could also want to
be maximizing something you want to get
the best output of it
that's simply
minus the value
so if you're looking for where the peak
is
this is the same as a negative
for where the valley is i'm looking for
that valley
that's all that is and this is a way of
finding it so
the cool thing is all the heavy lifting
is done
i actually
ended up putting together one of these a
while back as uh when i didn't know
about sidekick and i was just starting
uh boy it's a long while back
and uh
is playing high low how do you play high
low not get stuck in the valleys figure
out these curves and things like that
well you do that and the back end is all
the calculus and differential equations
to calculate this out
the good news is you don't have to do
those
so instead we're going to put together
the code and let's go ahead
and see what we can do with that
so
guys in the back put together a nice
little piece of code here which is kind
of fun
some things we're going to note and this
is this is really important stuff
because when you start doing your data
science and digging into your machine
learning models
you're going to find
these things are stumbling blocks
the first one is current x where do we
start at
keep in mind
your model that you're working with is
very generic so whatever you use to
minimize it the first question is where
do we start
and we started at this because the
algorithm starts at x equals three
so we arbitrarily picked five
learning rate is uh how many bars to
skip going one where the other i'm in
fact i'm going to separate that a little
bit because these two are really
important
if we're dealing with something like
this where we're talking about um well
here's our here's the function we're
going to use our
gradient of our function
2 times x plus 5 keep it simple so
that's a function we're going to work
with so if i'm dealing with increments
of a thousand point one is going to be a
very long time
and if i'm dealing with increments of
0.001
uh 0.1 is going to skip over my answer
so i won't get a very good answer and
then we look at precision this tells us
when to stop the algorithm so again
very specific to what you're working on
if you're working with money
and
you don't convert it into a float value
you might be dealing with 0.01 which is
a penny that might be your precision
you're working with
and then of course the previous step
size max iterations we want something to
cut out at a certain point usually
that's built into a lot of minimization
functions
and then here's our actual
formula we're going to be working with
and then we come in we go while previous
step size is greater than precision and
it is less than max and max iters
say that 10 times fast
um
we're just saying if it's uh if we're if
we're still greater than our precision
level we still got to keep digging
deeper
and then we also don't want to go past a
thou or whatever this is a million or
ten thousand uh running that's actually
pretty high i almost never do max
iterations more than like a hundred or
two hundred
rare occasions you might go up to four
or five hundred if it's uh depending on
the problem you're working with uh so we
have our previous equals our current
that way we can track time wise
uh the current now equals the current
minus the rate times the formula of our
previous x
so now we've generated our new version
uh previous step size equals the
absolute current previous
uh so we're looking for the change in x
errors equals iterations plus one that's
so we know to stop if we get too far and
then we're just going to print the local
minimum occurs at
x on here and if we go ahead and run
this
you can see right here it gets down to
this point and it says hey
local minimum is minus
3.3222 for this particular series we
created uh this is created off of our
formula here lambda x2 times x plus 5.
now
when i'm running this stuff you'll see
this come up a lot
in
with the sk learn kit
and one of the nice reasons of breaking
this down the way we did
is i could go over those top pieces
those top pieces are everything when you
start looking at these minimization
toolkits in built-in code and so from
we'll just do it's actually
docs
dot
scipy.org
and we're looking at
the scikit
there we go
optimize minimize
you can only minimize one value
you have the function that's going in
this function can be very complicated
so we used a very simple function up
here
it could be
there's all kinds of things that could
be on there and there's a number of
methods to solve this as far as how they
shrink down
and your x naught there's your there's
your start value so your function your
start value
there's all kinds of things that come in
here that you can look at which we're
not going to
optimization automatically creates
constraints bounds
some of this it does automatically but
you really the big thing i want to point
out here is you need to have a starting
point you want to start with something
that you already know is mostly the
answer
if you don't then it's going to have a
heck of a time trying to calculate it
out
or you can write your own little script
that does this and does a high-low
guessing and tries to find the max value
that brings us to statistics what this
is kind of all about is figuring things
out a lot of vocabulary and statistics
uh so statistics well i guess it's all
relative it's definitely not an edel
class
so a bunch of stuff going on statistics
statistics concerns with the collection
organization analysis interpretation
and presentation of data
that is a mouthful
so we have from end to end
where does it come from is it valid what
does it mean how do we organize it
how do we analyze it then you gotta take
those analysis and interpret it into
something that uh people can use kind of
reduce it to
understandable
um and nowadays you have to be able to
present it if you can't present it then
no one else is gonna understand what the
heck you did
so we look at the terminologies
there is a lot of terminologies
depending on what domain you're working
in
so clearly if you're working in
a domain that deals with
viruses and t cells and and
how does you know where does that come
from when you're studying the different
people then you can have a population
if you are working with um
mechanical gear
a little bit different if you're looking
for the wobbling statistics to know when
to replace a rotor on a machine or
something like that
that can be a big deal you know we have
these huge fans that turn
in our sewage processing systems and so
those fans they start to wobble and hum
and do different things that the sensors
pick up at one point do you replace them
instead of waiting for it to break in
which case it costs a lot of money
instead of replacing a bushing you're
replacing the whole fan unit an
interesting project that came up for our
city a while back
so population all objects are
measurements whose properties are being
observed
so that's your population all the
objects it's easy to see it with people
because we have our population in large
but in the case of the sewer fans we're
talking about the fan units that's the
population of fans that we're working
with
you have a parameter a matrix that is
used to represent a population or
characteristic
you have your sample a subset of the
population studied you don't want to do
them all because then you don't have a
if you come up with a conclusion for
everyone you don't have a way of testing
it so you take a sample
sometimes you don't have a choice you
can only take a sample of what's going
on you can't
study the whole population
and a variable a metric of interest for
each person or object in a population
types of sampling
we have a probabilistic approach
selecting samples from a larger
population using a method based on the
theory of probability
and we'll go into a little bit more
deeper on these we have random
systematic stratified
and then you have a non-probabilistic
approach selecting samples based on the
subjective judgment of the researcher
rather than random selection
it has to do with convenience trying to
reach a quota
or snowball
and they're very biased that's one of
the reasons you'll see this big stambon
that says biased so you gotta be very
careful on that
so probabilistic sampling when we talk
about a random sampling we select random
size samples from each group or category
so it's as random as you can get we talk
about systematic sampling
we're selecting random size samples from
each group or category with a fixed
periodic interval
so we kind of split it up this would be
like a time set up or different
categories
and you might ask your question what is
a category or a group
uh if you look at i'm going to go back a
window let's say we're studying um
economics of different of an area
um we know pretty much that based on
their culture where they came from
they might need to be separated and so
uh and when i say separated i don't mean
separated from their
place where they live i mean as far as
the analysis we want to look at the
different groups and make sure they're
all represented
so if we had like an 80 percent
of a group that is
say hispanic and
or indian and also in that same area we
have 20 20 percent who are
let's call our expatriates they left
america and they're nice and
your caucasian group we might want to
sample a group that is representative of
both
so we're talking about stratified
sampling and we're talking about groups
those are the groups we're talking about
and that brings us to stratified
sampling selecting approximately equal
size samples from each group or category
this way we can actually separate the
categories and give us an insight into
the different cultures and how that
might affect them in that area
so you can see these are very very
different kind of
depends on what you're working with
as far as your data and what you're
studying
and so we can see here just a little bit
more we'd have selecting 25 employees
from a company of 250 employees randomly
don't care anything about them what
groups are in which office they're in
nothing
and we might be selecting one employee
from every 50 unique employees in a
company of 250 employees
and then we have selecting one employee
from every branch in the company office
so we have all the different branches
there's our group or our categories by
the branch and the category could depend
on what you're studying so it has a lot
of variation on there
you see this kind of grouping and
categorizing is also used to generate a
lot of misinformation
so if you only study one group and you
say this is what it is
then everybody assumes that's what it is
for everybody and so you've got to be
very careful of that and it's very
unethical thing to kind of do
so types of statistics we talk about
statistics
we're going to talk about descriptive
and inferential statistics
there are so many different terms and
statistics to break it up
so we so we're talking about a
particular
setup so we're talking about descriptive
and inferential uh statistics
the base of the word describe
is pretty solid you're describing the
data what does it look like with
inferential statistics we're going to
take that from the small population to a
large population so if you're working
with a drug company you might look at
the data and say these people were
helped by this drug
they did
80 percent better
as far as their health or 80 percent
better survival rate than the people
who did not have the drug so we can
infer that that drug will work in the
greater populace and will help people so
that's where you get your inferential so
we are
predicting how it's going to affect the
greater population
so descriptive statistics it is used to
describe the basic features of data and
form the basis of quantitative analysis
of data
so we have a measure of central
tendencies we have your mean median and
mode
and then we have a measure of spread
like your range your interquartile range
your variance and your standard
deviation
and we're going to look at all these a
little deeper here in a second
but one of them you can think of is
how the data difference
differences you know what's the max min
range all that stuff is your spread and
anything that's just a single number is
usually your central uh tendencies
measure of central tendencies
so we talk about the mean it is the
average of the set of values considered
what is the average outcome of whatever
is going on
and then your median
separates the higher half and the lower
half of data
so where's the center point of all your
different data points
so your mean might have some a couple
really big numbers that skew it
so that the average is much higher than
if you took those outliers out where the
median would by separating the high from
the low might give you a much lower
number you might look at and say oh
that's that's odd why is the average so
much higher than the median well it's
because you have some outliers or why is
it so much lower
and then the mode is the most frequent
appearing value
this is really interesting if you're
studying economics and how people are
doing you might find that the most
common
income like in the u.s was
1.24 000 a year
where the average was closer to 80 000
and it's like wow what a difference well
there's some people have a lot of money
and so that skews that way up so the
average person is not making that kind
of money and then you look at the median
income and you're like well the median
income is a little bit closer to the
average so it does create a very
interesting way of looking at the data
again these are all
central tendencies single numbers you
can look at for the whole spread of the
data
and we look at the measure of central
tendencies the mean is the average marks
of a students in a classroom so here we
have the mean sum of the marks of the
students total number of students and as
we talked about the median
if we have
0 through 10 and we take half the
numbers and put them on one side of the
line half the numbers on the other side
of the line
we end up with 5 in the middle and then
the mode what mark was scored by most of
the students in a test in a simple case
where most people scored like an 82
percent and got certain problems wrong
easy to figure out uh not so easy when
you have different areas where like you
have like the um oh let's go back to
economy a little bit more difficult to
calculate if you have a large group that
scores that makes 30 000
and a slightly bigger group that makes
26 000. so what do you put down for the
mode
certainly there's a number of ways to
calculate that and there's actually
different variations depending on what
you're doing
so now we're looking at a measure of
spread uh range what's the difference
between the highest and the lowest value
first thing you want to look at you know
it's uh we had everybody in the test
score between 60 and 100 percent
somebody got a hundred percent or maybe
sixty to ninety percent it was so hard
that a lot of people could not get a
hundred percent
um you have your
inter-quartile range quartiles divide a
rank ordered data set into four equal
parts
very common thing to do as part of all
the basic packages whether you're
working in uh
data frames with pandas whether you're
working in scala whether you're working
in r
you'll see this come up where they have
range your min your max and then it'll
have your interquartile range how does
it look like in each quarter of data
variance measures how far each number in
the set is from the mean and therefore
from every other number in the set
so you have like a how much turbulence
is going on in this data
and then the standard deviation
it is to measure the variance or the
dispersion of a set of values from the
mean
and you'll usually see if i'm doing a
graph i might have the value graphed
and then based on the the error i might
graph graph the standard deviation in
the error on the graph as a background
so you can see how far off it is
so standard deviation deviations used a
lot
so measurement of spread uh marks of a
student out of a hundred uh we have here
from 50 to 63 or 50 to 90.
so the range maximum marks minimum marks
we have 90 to 45 and the spread of that
is 45 90 minus 45. and then we have the
interquartile range using the same marks
over there you can see here where the
median is
and then there's the first quarter the
second quarter and the third quarter
based on splitting it apart by those
values
and to understand the variance and
standard deviation we first need to find
out the mean uh so here's our our you
know calculating the average there we
end up at approximately 66 for the
average and then we look at that the
variance once we know the means we can
do equals the marks minus the mean
squared
why is it squared uh because one you
want to make sure it's you don't have
like if you if you're
putting all this stuff together you end
up with an error as far as one's
negative one's positive one's a little
higher one's a little lower
so you always see
the squared value and over the total
observations
and so the standard deviation equals the
square root of the variance which is
approximately 16.
and if you were looking at
a predictable model you would be looking
at the deviation based on the error how
much error does it have
and that's again
really important to know if your if your
prediction is predicting something
what's the chance of it being way off or
just a little bit off
now that we've looked at the
tools as far as some of the basics for
doing your statistics and we're talking
about
let's go ahead and pull up a little demo
and show you what that looks like in
python code
so you can get some little hands on here
for that let's go and back into our
jupyter notebook and python now almost
all of this you can do in numpy last
time we worked in numpy this time we're
going to go ahead and use pandas
and if you remember from pandas on here
this is basically a data frame rows
columns let's just go ahead and do a
print
df.head
and run that
and you can see we have the name jane
michael william rosie hannah's out and
their salaries on here and of course
instead of having to do all those hand
calculations and add everything together
and divide by the total
we can do something very simple on this
like
use the command mean in pandas and so if
i go ahead and do this print df
pick our column salary because we want
to find the means of that calorie
we want to find the means of that column
uh and we go and print this out and you
can see that the
average income on here is 71 000.
and let's just go ahead and do this
we'll go ahead and put in
means
and if we're going to do that we also
might want to find the median
and the median is very similar
except it actually is just median uh
we're used to means in average it's kind
of interesting that those are they use
the two different words
uh there can be in some computation
slight differences but for the most part
the means is the average uh and then the
median
oops just put a
median here
do you have salary that way it displays
a little better we can see the median is
000. so the halfway mark is
significantly below the average why
because we have somebody in here makes
189 000.
darn you rosie for throwing off our
numbers
but that's something you'd want to
notice this is this is the difference
between these is huge and so is what is
the meaning behind that when you're
studying a populace and looking at
the different data coming in and of
course we also want to find out hey
what's the most uh common
income that people make
in this little tiny sample and so we'll
go ahead and do the mode
and you can see here with the mode uh
it's at 50 000.
so this is this is very telling that
most people are making 50 000
the middle point is at 54 000. so half
the people are making more than that
what that tells me is that if the most
common income is weight is below the
median
then
there's a few there's a skill there's a
lot of high salaries going up but
there's some really low salaries in
there
and so this trend which is very common
in statistics when you're analyzing
the economy and different people's
income is pretty common and the bigger
difference between these is also very
important when we're studying statistics
and when you hear someone just say hey
the average income was you might start
asking questions at that point why
aren't you talking about the median
income why aren't you talking about the
mode the most common income what are you
hiding uh and if you're doing these
analysis you should be looking at these
saying hey why are these discrepancies
why are these so different and of course
with any analysis it's important to find
out the minimum
and the maximum so we'll go ahead it's
just simply uh
dot min
it'll pull up your minimum and then dot
max pulls up the maximum
pretty straightforward on as far as
translating it and knowing which you
know what the
lowest value what your highest value is
here
which you'll use to generate like a
spread later on and real quick on no
mode note that it puts mode 0. like i
said there's a couple different ways you
can compute the mode
um although the standard one is pretty
good we can of course do the range
which is your max minus your min so now
we have a range of 149 000 between the
upper end and the lower end and you
might want to be looking at the
individual values on all of these but it
turns out there is a describe
feature in pandas
and so in pandas we can actually do df
salary describe and if we do this you
can see we have that there's seven uh
setups here's our mean
our standard deviation which we didn't
compute yet which would just be a dot
std
and you got to be a little careful
because when it computes it it looks for
axes and things like that
we have our minimum value and here's our
quartiles
our maximum value and then of course the
name salary
so these are the these are the basic
statistics you can pull them up and like
just describe
this is a dictionary so i could actually
do something like
in here i could actually go
count
and run
and now it just prints the count
so because this is a dictionary you can
pull any one of these values out of here
it's kind of a quick and dirty way to
pull all the different information and
then split it up and depending on what
you need
now if i just walked in and gave you
this information
in a meeting
at some point you would just kind of
fall asleep
that's what i would do anyway
so we want to go ahead and see about
graphing it here and we'll go ahead and
put it into a histogram and plot that
graph on it
of the salaries and let's just go ahead
and put that in here so
we do our map plot inline remember
that's a jupiter's notebook thing a lot
of the new version of the matplot
library does it automatically
but just in case i always put it in
there import matplot library pipeline is
plt that's my plotting
and then we have our data frame i don't
i guess i really don't need to respell
the data frame
maybe we could just remind ourselves
what's in it so we'll go ahead and just
print
df
that way we still have it
and then we have our salary df salary
salary.plot history title salary
distribution color gray
plot ax v line salary the mean value so
we're going to take the mean value
color violet
line style dash this is just all making
it pretty
what color dash line line width of 2
that kind of thing
and the median and let's go ahead and
run this just so you can see what we're
talking about
and so up here we are taking on our plot
so here's the data here's our our data
frame print it out so you can see it
with the salaries we'll look at the
salary distribution and just look at
this the way the salary is distributed
you have our
in this case we did
let's see we had red for the median
we have violet
for our average or mean
and you can just see how it really
i mean here's our outlier here's our
person who makes a lot of money here's
the
average and here's a median
and so as you look at this you can say
wow
based on the average it really doesn't
tell you much about what people are
really taking home all it does is tell
you
how much money is in this you know what
the average salary is
so
some of the things you want to take away
in addition to this is that it's very
easy to plot
an axv line
these are these up and down lines for
your markers
and as you just display the data i mean
you can add all kinds of things to this
and get really complicated keeping it
simple is pretty straightforward i look
at this and i can see we have a major
outlier out here we can definitely do a
histogram and stuff like that
but you know pictures worth a thousand
words
what you really want to make sure you
take away is that we can do a basic
describe
which pulls all this information out and
we can print any of the individual
information from the describe
because this is a dictionary
and so if we want to go ahead and look
up
the mean value we can also do describe
mean so if you're doing a lot of
statistics
being able to
[Music]
it doesn't have the print on there so
it's only going to print the last one
which happens to be the mean
uh you can very easily reference any one
of these and then you can also if you're
doing something a little bit more
complicated and you don't need just the
basics you can come through and pull any
one of the individual
references from the from the pandas on
here so now we've had a chance to
describe our data
let's get into inferential statistics
inferential statistics allows you to
make predictions or inferences from data
and you can see here we have a nice
little picture movie ratings and
if we took this group of people and said
hey how many people like the movie
dislike it can't say and then you ask
just a random person who comes out of
the movie who hasn't been in this study
uh you can infer that 55 chance of
saying liked
35 chance of saying disliked or a 10 or
11 percent chance of can't say so that's
real basics of what we're talking about
is you're going to infer that the next
person is going to follow these
statistics
uh so let's look at point estimation
it is a process of finding an
approximate value for a population's
parameter like mean
or average from random samples of the
population let's take an example of
testing vaccines for covid19
vaccines and flu bugs all that it's a
pretty big thing of how do you test
these out and make sure they're going to
work on the populace
a group of people are chosen from the
population medical trials are performed
results are generalized for the whole
population so here's our protected
there's our small group up here where
we've selected them we run medical
trials on them and then the results work
for the population
nice diagram with the arrows going back
and forth and the very scary coveted
virus in the middle of one
and let's take a look at the
applications of inferential statistics
very central is what they call
hypotheses testing
uh and the confidence interval which go
with that and then as we get into
probability we get into our binomial
theorem our normal distribution in
central limit theorem
hypothesis testing hypothesis testing is
used to measure the plausibility of a
hypothesis
assumption by using sample data
now
when we talk about theorems
theory
hypothesis
keep in mind that if you are in a
philosophy class
theory
is the same as hypothesis where theorem
is a scientific uh statement that is
something that has been proven
although it is always up for debate
because in science we always want to
make sure things are up to debate so
hypothesis is the same as a
philosophical class calling a theory
where theory in science is not the same
theory in science says this has been
well proven gravity is a theory so if
you want to debate the theory of gravity
try jumping up and down if you want to
have a theory about why the economy is
collapsing in your area
that is a philosophical debate
very important i've heard people mix
those up and it is a pet peeve of mine
we talk about hypotheses testing the
steps involved in hypotheses testing is
first we formulate a hypothesis
we figure out the right test to test our
hypothesis we execute the test and we
make a decision and so when you're
talking about hypothesis you're usually
trying to disprove it if you can't
disprove it
and it works for all the facts then you
might call that a theorem at some point
so in a use case let's consider an
example we have four students we're
given a task to clean a room every day
sounds like working with my kids they
decided to distribute the job of
cleaning the room among themselves they
did so by making four chits which has
their names on it and the name that gets
picked up has to do the cleaning for
that day
rob took the opportunity to make chits
and wrote everyone's name on it so
here's our four people nick rob emilia
emilia and summer
now rick emilia and summer are asking us
to decide whether rob has done some
mischief in preparing the chits i.e
whether rob has written his name on one
of the chit
for that we will find out the
probability of rob getting the cleaning
job on first day second day third day
and so on until 12 days the probability
of rob getting the job decreases every
day i.e his turn never comes up then
definitely he has done some mischief
while making the chits
so the probability of rob not doing work
on day one is three out of four there's
a .75 chance that he didn't do work
two days three fourths times three
fourths equals point five six
three days you have three fourths three
fourths three fourths which equals 0.42
when you get to day 12
it's 0.032 which is less than 0.05
remember this .05 that comes up a lot
when we're talking about
certain values when we're looking at
statistics
rob is cheating as he wasn't chosen for
12 consecutive days that's a very high
probability when
on day 12 he still hasn't gotten the job
cleaning the room
so we come up to our important important
terminologies we have null hypothesis
a general statement that states that
there is no relationship between two
measured phenomena or no
association among the groups
alternative hypothesis
contrary to the null hypothesis it
states whenever something is happening a
new theory is preferred instead of an
old one and so the two hypotheses go
hand in hand uh so your null this is
always interesting in and when talking
about data science and the math behind
it
it's about proving that the things have
no correlation null hypothesis says
these two have zero relation to each
other where the alternative hypothesis
says hey we found a relation this is
what it is
we have
p-value the p-value is a probability of
finding the observed or more extreme
results when the null hypothesis of a
study question is true
and the t-value it is simply the
calculated difference represented in
units of standard error the greater the
magnitude of t the greater the evidence
against the null hypothesis and you can
look at the t values being specific to
the test you're doing
where the p value is derived from your t
value and you're looking for what they
call the five percent or the 0.05
showing that it has a high correlation
so
digging in deeper let's assume that a
new drug is developed with the goal of
lowering the blood pressure more than
the existing drug and this is a good one
because the null value here isn't that
you don't have any drug the null value
here is that it's better than the
existing drug the new drug doesn't lower
the blood pressure more than the
existing drug
now if we get that that says our null
hypothesis is correct there is no
correlation and the new drug is not
doing its job the alternative hypothesis
the new drug does significantly lower
the blood pressure more than an existing
drug
yay we got a new drug out there and
that's our alternative hypothesis or the
h1 or ha
and we look at the p-value results from
the evidence like medical trial showing
positive results which will reject the
null hypothesis
and again they're looking for
a 0.05 or 5 percent and the t value
comparing all the positive test results
and finding means of different samples
in order to test hypothesis
so this is specific to the test how what
percentage of increase did they have
and this leads us to the confidence
intervals
a confidence interval is a range of
values we are sure our true values of
observations lie in
let's say you asked a dog owner around
you and asked them how many cans of food
do you buy for your per year for your
dog
through calculations you got to know
that the on an average around 95 of the
people bought around 200 to 300 cans of
food hence we can say that we have a
confidence interval of 2 300 where 95
percent of our values lie in that spring
data spread
and this the graph really helps a lot so
you can start seeing what you're looking
at here we have the 95 percent you have
your peak in this case it's a normal
distribution so you have a nice bell
curve equal on both sides it's not
asymmetrical and 95 of all the values
lie within a very small range and then
you have your outliers the 2.5 percent
going each way
so we touched upon hypothesis uh we're
going to move into probability so you
have your hypothesis once you've
generated your hypothesis we want to
know the probability of something
occurring probability is a measure of
the likelihood of an event to occur any
event can be predicted with total
certainty
and can only be predicted as a
likelihood of its occurrence so any
event cannot be predicted with total
certainty can only be predicted as a
likelihood of its occurrence
score prediction how good you're going
to do in whatever
sport you're in weather prediction stock
prediction
if you've studied physics and chaos
theory even the location of the chair
you're sitting on has a probability that
it might move three feet over
granted that probability is one in like
uh i think we calculated as under one in
trillions upon trillions so it's
the better the probability the more
likely it's going to happen there are
some things that have such a low
probability
that we don't see them
so we talk about random variable a
random variable is a variable whose
possible values are numerical outcomes
of a random phenomena so
we have the coin tossed how many heads
will occur in the series of 20 coin
flips probably you know the on average
they're 10 but you really can't know
because it's very random how many times
a red ball is picked from a bag of balls
if there's equal number of red balls and
blue balls and green balls in there how
many times the sum of digits on two dice
uh results are five each
um
so you know there's how often you're
going to roll two fives on your
paradigms
so in a use case let's consider the
example of rolling two dice we have a
random variable outcome equals y you can
take values two three four five six
seven eight nine ten eleven twelve
so we have a random variable and a
combination of dice
and instead of looking at how many times
both dice were roll five let's go ahead
and look at total sum of five and you
have in as far as your random variables
you can have a one four equals five four
one two three three two so four of those
rolls can be four if you look at all the
different options you have four of those
random rolls can be a five
and if we look at the total number
which happens to be 36 different options
you can see that we have 4 out of 36
chants every time you roll the dice that
you're gonna roll a total of five you
can have an outcome of five
and uh we'll look a little deeper as to
what that means but you could think of
that at what point if someone never
rolls a five or they always roll a five
can you say hey that person's probably
cheating
we'll look a little closer at the math
behind that but let's just consider this
is one of the cases is rolling two dice
and gambling
there's also binomial distribution it is
the probability of getting success or
failure as an outcome in an experiment
or trial that is repeated multiple times
and the key is is by meaning two
binomial so passing or failing an exam
winning or losing a game and getting
either head or tails so if you ever see
binomial distribution it's based on a
true false kind of set up you win or
lose
let's consider a
use case and let's consider the game of
football between two clubs
barcelona and dortmund the teams will
have to play a total of four matches and
we have to find out the chances of
barcelona winning the series
so we look at the total games and we're
looking at five different games or
matches
let's say that the winning chance for
barcelona is 75 or 0.75 that means that
each game they have a 75 chance that
they're going to win that game and
losing chances are 25 or 0.25
clearly 0.75 plus 0.25 equals 1. so that
accounts for 100 of the game probability
for getting k wins in in matches is
calculated
and we we're talking like so if you have
five games and you want to know if i
play um how many wins in those five
games should i get what's a percentage
on those and the probability for getting
k wins and in matches is calculated by p
x equals k equals n c k p to the k q to
the n minus k
here p is the probability of success and
q is the probability of failure and so
we can do total games of n equals five
where k equals zero one two three four
five
p which is the chance of winning is
point seven five q the chance of losing
equals one minus p
which equals 1 minus 0.075 which equals
0.25 the probability that barcelona will
lose all of the matches can then just
plug in the numbers
and we end up with a
five .00097656 two five so very small
chance they're gonna lose all their
matches
and we can plug in uh the value for two
probability that barcelona will win at
least two matches is
0.0878 and of course we can go on to the
probability that barcelona will win
three matches the 0.26 and of course
four matches and so on and it's always
nice to take this information um and
let's find the accumulated discrete
probabilities for each of the outcomes
where barcelona has won three or more
matches x equals three x equals four x
equals five
and we end up with the p equals point
two six four plus point three nine five
plus two three seven which equals 0.89
in reality
the probability of barcelona winning the
series is much higher than 0.75
and it's always nice to
put out a nice graph so you can actually
see the number of wins to the
probability and how that pans out with
our binomial case
continuing in our important terminology
location the location of the center of
the graph depends on the mean
value and this is some very important
things so much of the data we look at
and when you start looking at
probabilities almost always has a
normalized look like the graph in the
middle
but you do have left skewed where the
data is skewed off to the left and you
have more stuff happening off to the
left and you have right skewed data
and so when this comes up and these
probabilities come up where they're
skewed it's really important to take a
closer look at that
mostly you end up with a normalized set
of data but you've got to also be aware
that sometimes it's a skewed data
and then the height height of the slope
inversely depends upon the standard
deviation
so you can see down here the standard
deviation is really large it kind of
squishes it out and if the standard
deviation is small then most of your
data is going to hit right there in the
middle you can have a nice peak
and so being aware of this that you
might have a probability that fits
certain data but it has a lot of
outliers so you're if you have a really
high standard deviation
if you're doing stock market analysis
this means your predictions are probably
not going to make you much money
where if you have a very small deviation
you might be right on target and set to
become a millionaire
which leads us to the z-score z-score
tells you how far from the mean a data
point is
it is measured in terms of standard
deviations from the mean around 68
percent of the results are found between
one standard deviation
around 95 percent of the results are
found between two standard deviations
and you read the symbols of course they
love to throw some greek letters in
there we have mu minus two sigma
mu is just a quick way it's a kind of
funky u it just means the mean
uh and then the sigma is the standard
deviation and that's the o with the
little arrow off to the right or the
little
wagy tail going up the o with it with
the line on it uh so mu minus two sigma
is your
95 percent of the results are found
between two standard deviations
central limit theorem
this goes back to the skew if you
remember we were looking at the skew
values on this previous slide have left
skewed normalized and right skewed when
we're talking about it being skewed or
not skewed the distribution of the
sample means will be approximately
normally distributed evenly distributed
not skewed if you take large random
samples from the population with the
mean mu and the standard deviation sigma
with replacement
and you can see here
of course we have our
mu minus two sigma and the spread down
here the mean the median and the mode
and so you're talking about very large
populations
these numbers should come together and
you shouldn't have a skewed value if you
do that's a flag that something's wrong
that's why this is so important to be
aware of what's going on with your data
where your samples are coming from
and the math behind it
and if we're going to do all this we've
got to jump into conditional probability
the conditional probability of an event
a is the probability that the event will
occur
given the knowledge that an event b has
already occurred
and you'll see this as bayes theorem
b-a-y-e-s base
and this is red
i mean you have these funky looking
little
p
brackets a b
this is the probability of a being true
while b is already true
and you have the probability of b being
true when a is already true so p
b of a
probability of a being true divided by
the probability of b being true
and we talk about bayes theorem which
occurred back in the 1800s when he
discovered this this is such an
important formula and it's really it's
not if you actually do the math you
could just kind of do um
x y equals j k and then you divide them
out and you're going to see the same
math but it works with probabilities
which makes it really nice
and so if you have a set you might have
uh eight or nine different studies going
on in different areas different people
have done the studies they brought them
together
if we look at today's covet virus the
virus spread
certainly the studies done in china
versus the studies the way they're done
in the u.s
that data is different in each of those
studies but if you can find a place
where it overlaps
where they're studying the same thing
together you can then compute the
changes that you need to make in one
study to make them equal
and this is also true if you have a
study of
one group and you want to find out more
about it so this formula is very
powerful and it really has to do with
the data collection part of the math and
data science and understanding where
your data is coming from and how you're
going to combine different studies in
different groups
and we're going to go into a use case
let's find out the chance of a person
getting lung disease due to smoking
and this is kind of interesting the way
they word this let's say that according
to medical report provided by the
hospital states that around 10 percent
of all patients they treated suffered
lung disease
so we have kind of a generic medical
report
they further found out
by a survey that 15 of the patients that
visit them
smoke so we have 10 percent that are
lung disease and
15 of the patients smoke
and finally five percent of the people
continued smoke even when they had lung
disease uh not the brightest choice but
you know it is an addiction so it can be
really difficult to kick and so we can
look at the probability of a uh prior
probability of 10 people having lung
disease
and then probability b probability that
a patient smokes is 15 percent
uh and the probability of b
if b then a the probability of a patient
smokes even though they have lung
disease is 5
and probability of a is b probability
that the patient will have lung disease
if they smoke and then when you put the
formulas together you get a nice
solution here you get the probability of
a of b probability that the patient will
have lung disease if they smoke
and you can just plug the numbers right
in and we get a 3.33 percent chance
hence there is a 3.33 chance that a
person who smokes will get a lung
disease
so we're going to pull up a little
python code i'm always my favorite roll
up the sleeves
keep in mind we're going to be doing
this um kind of like the back end way
so that you can see what's going on and
then later on we're going to create um
we'll get into another demo which shows
you some of the tools are already
pre-built for this
let's start by creating a set so we're
going to create a set with curly braces
this means that our set has
only unique values so you have a list
uh you have your tuples which can never
change and then you have um in this case
the the set so four seven you can't
create a four seven comma four it'll
delete the four outs it's only unique
values
and if you use dictionaries
quick reminder this should look familiar
because it is a dictionary we have a
value and that value is assigned to or
that key is assigned to a value
so you could have a key value set up as
a dictionary so it's like a dictionary
without the value it's just the keys and
they all have to be unique
and if we run this we have a
set of four seven
we can also take a list a regular
setup and i'm gonna go ahead and just
throw in another number in here four
and run it
and you can see here if i take my list
one two three four four
and i convert it to a set and here it is
my set from list equals set my list
the result is one two three four so it
just deletes that last four right out of
there
and with the sets you can also go in
there and
print here is my set my set
uh three is in the set and then if you
do three in my set
that's going to be a logic function
uh and one in my set six is not in the
set and so forth if we run this
we get three is in the set true one is
in the set false because three five
seven is another one six is in the set
uh six is not in the set so not in my
set
you can also use this with the list we
could have just used three five seven
and it would have
the same response on there is three and
usually you do if three is in but three
in my set it still works on just a
regular list
and we'll go ahead and do a little
iteration we're going to do kind of the
dice one remember
one two three four five six and so we're
going to bring in the iteration tool and
import product as product
and i'll show you what that means in
just a second so we have our two dice we
have dice a
and it's going to be a set of values you
can only have one value for each one
that's why they put it in a set and if
you remember from range it is up to 7.
so this is going to be one two three
four five six it will not include the
seven and the same thing for our dice b
and then we're going to do is we're
going to create a list
which is the product
of a and b so what's a plus b
and if we go ahead and run this it'll
print that out and you'll see
in this case when they say product
because it's an iteration tool
we're talking about creating a tuple of
the two
so we've now created a tuple of all
possible outcomes of the dice where dice
a is one two three one to six and dice b
is one to six and you can see one to one
one to two one to three and so forth
you remember we had a slide on this
earlier where we talked about
the different all the different outcomes
of a dice we can play around with this a
little bit we can do in dice equals two
dice faces one two three four five six
uh another way of doing what we did
before and then we can create an event
space where we have a set which is the
product of the dice faces
repeat equals indice and we'll go and
just run this
and you can see here it just again puts
it through all the different possible
variables we can have
and then if we wanted to take the same
uh set on here and print them all out
like we had before
uh we can just go through for outcome
and event space outcome and equals
so the event space is creating
a sequence and as you can see here when
we print it out it stacks them versus
going through and putting them in a nice
line
and we'll go ahead and do something
let's go print
since we have the end printing with a
comma that just means it's just going to
it's not going to hit the return going
down to the next line
and we'll go ahead and do the length
of our event space that'll be an
important variable we're going to want
to know in a minute
and of course if i get carried away with
my typing of length we'll print it twice
and it'll give me an error
so we have 36 different possible
variations
here and we might want to calculate
something like
what about the multiple of 3 what if we
want to have
the probability of the multiple of 3 in
our setup
and so we can put together the code for
the outcome and event space of x y
equals outcome
if x plus y
remainder 3 so we're going to divide by
3 and look at the remainder and it
equals
0. then it's a favorable outcome we're
going to pop that outcome on the end
there
and we'll turn it into a set so the
favor outcome equals a set
not necessary
because we know it's not going to be
repeating itself but just in case we'll
go ahead and do that
and if we want to print out the outcome
we can go ahead and see what that looks
like and you can see here these are all
multiples of 3. 1 plus two is three five
plus four is nine which divided by three
is three and so forth
and just like we looked up the length of
the one before let's go ahead and print
the length
of our
f outcome
so we can see what that looks like
there we go
and of course i did forget to add the
print in the middle because we're
looping through and putting an end on
the on the setup on there so we're going
to put the print in there and if i run
this you can see
we end up with 12. so we have 36 total
options
we have 12 that are multiple that add up
to a multiple of three
and we can easily conv compute the
probability of this
uh by simply taking the length
of our favorable outcome over the length
of the event space
and if we print it out let me put that
in there
probability
last line so we just type it in we end
up with a 0.3333 chance that's roughly a
third
and we want to make this look nice so
let's go ahead and put in another line
there the probability of getting the sum
which is a multiple of three is
0.3333
we can compute the same thing for five
dice
and if we do this for five dice and go
and run it uh you can see we just have a
huge amount of choices
so just goes on and on down here and we
can look at
the length of the event space
and we have over 7 76
choices that's a lot of choices
and if we want to ask the question like
we did above uh
what is the sum where the sum is a
multiple of five but not a multiple of
three we can go through all of these
different options and then
you can see here
d1 d2 d3 d4 d5 equals the outcome
and if you add these all together and
the
division by five does not have a
remainder of zero
but the remainder is also of a division
by three is not equal to zero
so the multiple of five is equal to zero
but the multiple three is not we can
just append that on here and then we can
look at that uh favorable outcome
we'll go ahead and set that and we'll
just take a look at this what's our
length
of our favorable outcome
it's always good to see what we're
working with and so we have 904 out of
and then of course we can just do a
simple division to get the probability
on here what's the probability that
we're going to roll
a multiple of 5 when you add them
together
but not a multiple of 3.
and so we're just going to divide those
two numbers and you can see here we get
0.11625 or 11.62
and so you can really have a nice visual
that this is not really complicated math
right here on probabilities
it's just how many options do you have
and how many of those are you possibly
going to be able to come up with with
the solution you're looking for
and this leads us to a confusion matrix
a confusion matrix is a table which is
used to describe the performance of a
classification model on a set of test
data for which the true values are known
and so you'll see in the left we have
the predicted and the actual
and we have a negative
false negative positive true positive
um and then we have false positive and
true negative and you can think of this
as your predicted model what does that
mean that means if you divided your data
and you used two third of us to create
the model
you might then test it against an actual
case for the last third to see how well
it comes out how many times was it
true positive versus a
false positive it gave a false positive
response
and you can imagine in medical
situations this is a pretty big deal you
don't want to give a false positive so
you might adjust your model accordingly
so you don't have a false positive say
with a covavirus test it'd be better to
have a false negative and they go back
and get retested than to have 30 false
positives where then the test is pretty
much invalid
so in a use case like cancer prediction
let's consider an example where a cancer
prediction model is put to the test for
its accuracy and precision
actual result of a person's medical
report is compared with the prediction
made by the machine learning model
and so you can see here here's our
actual predicted whether they have
cancer or not you know cancer a big one
you don't want to have a
false positive i mean a false negative
in other words you don't want to have it
tell you that you don't have cancer when
you do so that would be something you'd
really be looking for in this particular
domain you don't want a false negative
and this is again you know you've
created a model you have hundreds of
people or thousands of pieces of data
that come in
there's a real famous case study where
they have the imagery and all the
measurements they take and there's about
36 different measurements they take
and then if you run the
a basic model you want to know just how
accurate it is how many negative results
do you have that are either telling
people they have cancer that don't or
telling people that don't have cancer
that they do and then we can take these
numbers and we can feed them into our
accuracy our precision and our recall
so accuracy precision and recall
accuracy metric to measure how
accurately the results are predicted and
this is your
total um true where you got the right
results you add them together the true
positive the two negative
over all the results so what percentage
of them were accurate versus what were
wrong we talked about precision is a
metric to measure how many of the
correctly predicted cases are actually
turned out to be positive
uh so we have a precision on
true positive again if you're talking
about like covet testing with the
viruses
you really want this to be a high number
you want this true
that to be the center point where you
might have the opposite if you're
dealing with cancer where you want no
false negatives
so this is your metric on here precision
is your test positive
true positive plus
false positive
and then your recall how many of the
actual positive cases we were able to
predict quickly with our model
so test positive is the test positive
plus the
false negative on there and we'll want
to go ahead and do a demo on the naive
bayes classifier before i get too far
into a naive bayes classifier because
we're going to pull it from the sk learn
or the scikit
let's go ahead kind of an interesting
page here for classifiers when you go
into the sk learn kit there's a lot of
ways to do classification and i'll just
zoom up in here so you can see some of
the titles
uh there's everything from the nearest
neighbor linear
but we're going to be focusing on the
naive bayes over here and this is just a
sample data set that they put together
and you can see how
some of these have a very different
output
the naive bayes remember is set up as
probably the most simplified
calculator or set of predictions out
there
and so what we've been talking about
with the true false and stuff like that
where there's a
and then a belief that there is a
independent assumption between the
features where the features are very
assumed to have some kind of connection
then we can go ahead and use that for
the prediction and so that's what we're
using is a naive bayes classifier versus
many of the other classifiers that are
out there
for this we're going to use uh the
social network ads it's a little data
set on here
and let me go and just open that up
the file
here we go it has user id gender age
estimated salary
purchased and so we have you can see the
user id
mail 19
estimated salary 19 000
and purchased zero so it's either going
to make a purchase or not
so look at that last one zero one we
should be thinking of binomials we
should be thinking of a simple naive
bayes classifier kind of setup
so if we close this out we're going to
go ahead and import our numpy as np
nice to have a good visual of our data
so we'll put in our matplot library
here's our pandas our data frame
and then we're going to go ahead and
import the data set and the data set is
going to be we're going to read it from
the social network ads.csv then we're
going to print the head just so you can
see it again
even though i showed you it in the file
and x equals the data set i location
2 3 values and y is going to be the 4
column 4. let me just run this it's a
little easier to go over that
you can see right here we're going to be
looking at
0 1 2 as age
and estimated salary so 2 3.
and that's what i location just means
that we're
looking at the number versus a regular
location a regular location you'd
actually say age and estimated salary
and then column four is did they make a
purchase they purchased something
so those are the three columns we're
going to be looking at when we do this
and we've gone ahead and imported these
and
imported the data so now our data set is
all set with this information in it
and we'll need to go ahead and split the
data up uh so we need our from the sk
learn model selection we can import
train test split
uh this does a nice job we can set the
random state so randomly picks the data
and we're just going to take 25 of it's
going to go into the test our x test and
our y test
and the 75 will go to x train and y
train
that way once we
create our model we can then have data
to see just how accurate or how well it
has performed with our prediction
the next step in pre-processing our data
is to go ahead and do feature scaling
now a lot of this to start to look
familiar if you've done a number of the
other modules and setup you should start
noticing that we
bring in our data we take a look at what
we're working with
we go ahead and split it up into
training and testing
in this case we're going to go ahead and
scale it scale it means we're putting it
between a value of minus one and one
or some place in the middle ground there
this way if you have any huge set you
don't have this huge
set up if we go back up to here where
salary the salary is
20 000 versus age 35.
well there's a good chance with a lot of
the back end math that 20 000 will skew
the results and the estimated salary
will have a higher impact than the age
instead of balancing them out and
letting the calculations weigh them
properly
and finally we get to actually create
our naive bayes model
and then we're going to go ahead and
import the gaussian naive bayes
and the gaussian is is the most basic
one that's what we're looking at now it
turns out though if you go to the sk
learn
kit
they have a number of different ones you
can pull in there there's a um bernoulli
i don't know i've never used that one
categorical
um complement and here's our gaussian
so there's a number of different options
you can look at
gaussian when you come to the naive
bayes is the most commonly used uh so
we're talking about the naive bayes
that's usually what people are talking
about when they when they're pulling
this in
and one of the nice things about the
gaussian if you go to their website
to sk learn the naive bayes gaussian
there's a lot of cool features one of
them is you can do partial fit on here
that means if you have a huge amount of
data you don't have to process it all to
want you once you can batch it into the
gaussian nb model and there's many other
different things you can do with it as
far as fitting the data and how you
manipulate it
we're just doing the basics so we're
going to go ahead and create our
classifier we're going to equal the
gaussian in b
and then we're going to do a fit we're
going to fit our training data and our
training solution so x train y train
and we'll go ahead and run this uh it's
going to tell us that it ran the code
right there
and now we have our trained classifier
model
so the next step is we need to go ahead
and run a prediction we're going to do
our y predict equals the
classifier.predict
x test so here we fit the data and now
we're going to go ahead and predict
and now we get to our confusion matrix
so from
the sk learn matrix metrics you can
import your confusion matrix
just as saves you from doing all the
simple math that does it all for you
and then we'll go ahead and create our
confusion metrics with the y test and
the y predict so we have our actual
and we have our predicted value and you
can see from here this is the chart we
looked at here's predicted so true
positive false positive false negative
true negative
and if we go ahead and run this there we
have it 65 3 7 25
and in this particular prediction we had
65 or predicted the truth as far as a
purchase they're going to make a
purchase
and we guessed three wrong
and then we had 25 we predicted would
not purchase and seven of them did so
there's our our confusion matrix
at this point if you were with your
shareholders or a board meeting
you would start to hear some snoozing if
they were looking at the numbers and you
say hey here's my confusion
matrix
so let's go ahead and visualize the
results
we're going to pull from the matplot
library colors import listed color map
um and this is actually my machine is
going to throw an error because this is
being
because of the way the setup is i have a
newer version on here than when they put
together the demo
and we need our x set and our y set
which is our x train and y train
and then we'll create our x1 x2
and we'll put that into a grid
uh and we set our xset minimum stop and
our xset max stop
and if you come all the way over here
we're going to step .01 this is going to
give us a nice line
is what that's doing and we're going to
plot the contour
plot the x limit plot the y limit
and put the scatter plot in there let's
go ahead and run this
to be honest when i'm doing these graphs
there's so many different ways to do
that there's so many different ways to
put this code together
to show you what we're doing it's a lot
easier to pull up the graph and then go
back up and explain it
so the first thing we want to note here
when we're looking at the data
is this is the training set
and so we have those who didn't make a
purchase we've drawn a nice area for
that
that's defined by the naive bayes setup
and then we have those who did make a
purchase the green and you can see that
some of the green drops fall into the
red area and some of the red dots fall
into the green
so even our training set isn't going to
be a hundred percent uh we couldn't do
that
and so we're looking at our different
data coming down
uh we can kind of arrange our x1 x2 so
we have a nice plot going on and we're
going to create the
contour
that's that nice line that's drawing
down the middle on here with the red
green
um that's where that's what this is
doing right here with the reshape and
notice that we had to
do the dot t if you remember from numpy
if you did the numpy module
you end up with pairs you know x
x1 x2
x1 x2 next row and so forth you have to
flip it so it's all one row you have all
your x1s and all your x2s so this is
what we're kind of looking for right
here on this setup
uh and then the scatter plot is of
course
your scattered data across there we're
just going through all the points that
puts these nice little dots on to our
setup on here and we have our estimated
salary and our h and then of course the
dots are did they make a purchase or not
and just a quick note this is kind of
funny you can see up here where it says
x set y set equals x train y train which
seems kind of a little weird to do
this is because this is probably
originally a definition
so it was its own module that could be
called over and over again
and which is really a good way to do it
because the next thing we're going to
want to do is do the exact same thing
but we're going to visualize the test
set results
that way we can see what happened with
our test group our 25 percent
and you can see down here we have the
test set
and it if you look at the two
graphs next to each other this one
obviously has
75 percent of the data so it's going to
show a lot more
this is only 25 of the data you can see
that there's a number that are kind of
on the edge as to whether they could
guess by age and income they're going to
make a purchase or not
but that said it still is pretty clear
it's pretty good as far as how much the
estimate is and how good it does
now
graphs are really effective for showing
people what's going on but you also need
to have the numbers and so we're going
to do from sklearn we're going to import
metrics
and then we're going to print our
metrics classification port from the y
test and the y predict
and you can see here we have precision
precision of zeros is 90 there's our
recall
0.96 we have an f1 score and a support
and we have our precision the recall on
getting it right
and then we can do our accuracy the
macro average and the weighted average
so you can see it pulls in
pretty good as far as
how accurate it is
you could say it's going to be about 90
is going to guess correctly um
that it that they're not going to
purchase and we had an 89 chance that
they are going to purchase
and then the other numbers as you get
down
have a little bit different meaning but
it's pretty straightforward on here
here's our accuracy
and here's our micro average and the
weighted average and everything else you
might need and if you forgot the exact
definition of accuracy it is the
true positive true negative over all of
the different setups
precision is your true positive overall
positives true and false
and recall is a true positive over true
positive plus false negative
and we can just real quick flip back
there
so you can see those numbers on here uh
here's our precision here's our recall
and here's our accuracy on this
we're going to cover reinforcement
learning today and what's in it for you
we'll start with why reinforcement
learning we'll look at what is
reinforcement learning
we'll see what the different kinds of
learning strategies are that are being
used today in computer models under
supervised versus unsupervised versus
reinforcement
we'll cover important terms specific to
reinforcement learning we'll talk about
markov's decision process and we'll take
a look at a reinforcement learning
example but we'll teach a tic-tac-toe
how to play
why reinforcement learning training a
machine learning model requires a lot of
data which might not always be available
to us
further the data provided might not be
reliable learning from a small subset of
actions will not help expand the vast
realm of solutions that may work for a
particular problem
you can see here we have the robot
learning to walk
very complicated setup when you're
learning how to walk and you'll start
asking questions like if i'm taking one
step forward and left what happens if i
pick up a 50 pound object how does that
change how a robot would walk
these things are very difficult to
program because there's no actual
information on it until it's actually
tried out learning from a small subset
of actions will not help expand the vast
realm of solutions that may work for a
particular problem
and we'll see here it learned how to
walk this is going to slow the growth
that technology is capable of machines
need to learn to perform actions by
themselves and not just learn off humans
and you see the objective climb a
mountain
a real interesting point here
is that as human beings we can go into a
very unknown environment
and we can adjust for it and kind of
explore and play with it
most of the models the non-reinforcement
models in computer
machine learning aren't able to do that
very well there's a couple of them that
can be used or integrated see how it
goes
is what we're talking about with
reinforcement learning so what is
reinforcement learning
reinforcement learning is a sub-branch
of machine learning that trains a model
to return an optimum solution for a
problem by taking a sequence of
decisions by itself
consider a robot learning to go from one
place to another
the robot is given a scenario must
arrive at a solution by itself the robot
can take different paths to reach the
destination
it will know the best path by the time
taken on each path it might even come up
with a unique solution all by itself
and that's really important is we're
looking for unique solutions we want the
best solution but you can't find it
unless you try it so we're looking at
our different
systems our different model we have
supervised versus unsupervised versus
reinforcement learning and with the
supervised learning that is probably the
most controlled environment we have a
lot of different supervised learning
models whether it's linear regression
neural networks
there's all kinds of things in between
decision trees
the data provided is labeled data with
output values specified
and this is important because we're
talking about supervised learning you
already know the answer for all this
information you already know the picture
has a motorcycle in it so you're
supervised learning you already know
that
the outcome for tomorrow for you know
going back a week you're looking at
stock
you can already have like the graph of
what the next day looks like so you have
an answer for it
and you have labeled data which is used
you have an external supervision and
solves problems by mapping labeled input
to no one output
so very controlled
unsupervised learning and unsupervised
learning is really interesting because
it's now taking part in many other
models they start with you can actually
insert an unsupervised learning model
in almost either supervised or
reinforcement learning is part of the
system which is really cool
data provided is unlabeled data the
outputs are not specified machine makes
its own predictions
used to solve association with
clustering problems unlabeled data is
used no supervision solves problems by
understanding patterns and discovering
output
so you can look at this and you can
think
some of these things go with each other
they belong together so it's looking for
what connects in different ways and
there's a lot of different algorithms
that look at this
when you start getting into those are
some really cool images that come up
of what unsupervised learning is how we
can pick out say
the area of a donut
one model will see the area of the donut
and the other one will divide it into
three sections based on its location
versus what's next to it so there's a
lot of stuff that goes in with
unsupervised learning
and then we're looking at reinforcement
learning probably the biggest industry
in today's market
in machine learning or growing market
it's very it's very infant stage
as far as how it works and what's going
to be capable of
the machine learns from its environment
using rewards and errors used to solve
reward based problems
no predefined data is used no
supervision
follows trail and error problem solving
approach
so again we have a random at first you
start with a random i try this it
works and this is my reward doesn't work
very well maybe or maybe it doesn't even
get you where you're trying to get it to
do
and you get your reward back and then it
looks at that and says well let's try
something else
and it starts to play with these
different things finding the best route
so let's take a look at important terms
in today's reinforcement
and this has become pretty standardized
over the last few years
so these are really good to know
we have the agent
agent is the model that is being trained
via reinforcement learning so this is
your actual
entity that has however you're doing it
whether you're using a neural network or
a
cue table or whatever combination
thereof
this is the actual agent that you're
using this is the model
and you have your environment
the training situation that the model
must optimize to is called its
environment
and you can see here i guess we have a
robot who's trying to get a chest full
of gyms or whatever and that's the
output
and then you have your action this is
all possible steps that can be taken by
the model and it picks one action and
you can see here it's picked three
different routes to get to the chest of
diamonds and gyms
we have a state the current position
condition returned by the
model
and you could look at this uh if you're
playing like a video game
this is the screen you're looking at so
when you go back here
the environment is a whole
game board so if you're playing one of
those mobius games
you might have the whole game board
going on but then you have your current
position where are you on that game
board what's around that what's around
you
if you were talking about a robot the
environment might be moving around the
yard
where it is in the yard and what it can
see what input it has in that location
that would be the current position
condition returned by the model and then
the reward to help the model move in the
right direction it is rewarded points
are given to it to appraise some kind of
action
so yeah you did good or
didn't do as good trying to maximize the
reward and have the best reward possible
and then policy policy determines how an
agent will behave at any time
it acts as a mapping between action and
present state
this is part of the model what is your
action that you're you're going to take
what's the policy you're using to have
an output from your agent
one of the reasons they separate
policy as its own entity
is that you usually have a prediction
of a different options
and then the policy well how am i going
to pick the best based on those
predictions i'm going to guess at
different options
and we'll actually weigh those options
in and find the best option we think
will work
so it's a little tricky but the policy
thing is actually pretty cool how it
works
let's go and take a look at a
reinforcement learning example
and just in looking at this we're going
to take a look consider what a dog
that we want to train
so the dog would be like the agent so
you have your your puppy or whatever
and then your environment is going to be
the whole
house or whatever it is where you're
training them
and then you have an action we want to
teach the dog to fetch
so action equals fetching
and then we have a little biscuit so we
can get the dog to perform various
actions by offering incentives such as a
dog biscuit as a reward
the dog will follow a policy to maximize
this reward and hence will follow every
command and might even learn new actions
like begging by itself uh so you have
you know so we start off with fetching
it goes oh i get a biscuit for that it
tries something else you get a handshake
or begging or something like that and it
goes oh this is also reward based and so
it kind of explores things to find out
what will bring is biscuit
and that's very much like how reinforced
model goes as it
looks for different rewards how do i
find can i try different things and find
a reward that works
the dog also will want to run around and
play an explorer's environment
this quality of model is called
exploration so there's a little
randomness going on in exploration
it explores new parts of the house
climbing on the sofa doesn't get a
reward in fact it usually gets kicked
off the sofa
so let's talk a little bit about
markov's decision process
is a reinforcement learning policy used
to map a current state to an action
where the agent continuously interacts
with the environment to produce new
solutions and receive rewards
and you'll see here's all of our
different
vocabulary we just went over we have a
reward our state our agent our
environment interaction and so even
though the environment kind of contains
everything
that you really when you're actually
writing the program your environment is
going to put out a reward and state that
goes into the agent
the agent then looks at this state or it
looks at the reward usually
first and it says okay i got rewarded
for whatever i just did or it didn't get
rewarded
and it looks at the state
and then it comes back and if you
remember from
policy the policy comes in
and then we have a reward the policy is
that part that's connected at the bottom
and so it looks at that policy and it
says hey
what's a good action that will probably
be similar to what i did or
sometimes they're completely random but
what's a good action that's going to
bring me a different reward
so taking the time to just understand
these different pieces as they go
is pretty important in most of the
models today
and so a lot of them actually have
templates
based on this you can pull in and start
using
pretty straightforward as far as once
you start seeing how it works
you can see your environment sends it
says hey this is the agent did this if
you're a character in a game this
happened and it shoots out a reward in a
state the agent looks at the reward
looks at the new state and then takes a
little guess and says i'm going to try
this action and then that action goes
back into the environment
it affects the environment the
environment then changes depending on
what the action was
and then it has a new state and a new
reward that goes back to the agent
so in the diagram shown we need to find
the shortest path between node a and d
each path has a reward associated with
it and the path with a maximum reward is
what we want to choose
the nodes a b c d denote the nodes to
travel from node uh a to b
is an action reward is the cost of each
path and policy is each path taken
and you can see here a can go uh to b or
a can go to c right off the bat or can
go right to d
and if explored all three of these
you would find that a going to d was a
zero reward
a going to c and d would generate a
different reward
or you could go a c b d there's a lot of
options here and so when we start
looking at this diagram you start to
realize
that even though today's reinforced
learning models do really good at
finding an answer
they end up trying almost all the
different directions you see
and so they take up a lot of work
or a lot of processing time for
reinforcement learning they're right now
in their infant stage and they're really
good at solving simple problems
and we'll take a look at one of those in
just a minute in the tic-tac-toe game
but you can see here
once it's gone through these and it's
explored it's going to find the a c d
is the best reward it gets a full 30
points for it so let's go ahead and take
a look at a reinforcement learning
demo
in this demo we're going to use
reinforcement learning to make a
tic-tac-toe game you'll be playing this
game against the machine learning model
and we'll go ahead we're doing it in
python so let's go ahead and go through
i always not always actually have a lot
of python tools let's go through
anaconda which will open up a jupiter
notebook seems like a lot of steps but
it's worth it to keep all my stuff
separate and it's also has a nice
display when you're in the jupiter
notebook for doing python
so here's our anaconda navigator i open
up the notebook which is going to take
me to a webpage and i've gone in here
and created a new uh python folder in
this case i've already done it and
enabled it to change the name to
tic-tac-toe and then for this example
we're going to go ahead and
import a couple things we're going to
import numpy as np we'll go ahead and
import pickle
numpy of course is our number array and
then pickle is just a nice way sometimes
for
storing different information different
states that we're going to go through on
here
and so
we're going to create a class called
state we're going to start with that
and there's a lot of lines of code to
this class that we're going to put in
here
don't let that scare you too much
there's not as much here
it looks like there's going to be a lie
here but there really is just a lot of
setup going on in the in our class state
and so we have up here we're going to
initialize it
we have our board
it's a tic tac toe board so we're only
dealing with nine spots on the board
uh we have player one player two
uh is end we're gonna create a board
hash
uh we'll look at that in just a minute
we're just gonna stir some information
in there symbol player equals one
so there's a few things going on as far
as the initialization
uh then something simple we're just
going to get the hash
of the board you get the information
from the board on there which is
columns and rows
we want to know when a winner occurs uh
so if you get three in a row that's what
this whole section here is for
uh let me go ahead and
scroll up a little bit
and you can get a copy of this code if
you send a note over to simplylearn
we'll send you over um this particular
file and you can play with it yourself
and see how it's put together
i don't want to spend a huge amount of
time on this because this is just some
real general python coding
but you can see here we're just going
through all the rows
and you add them together and if it
equals three three in a row same thing
with columns
diagonal so you gotta check the diagonal
that's what all this stuff does here is
it just goes through the different areas
actually let me go ahead and put
there we go
um and then it comes down here and we do
our sum and it says true
minus three just says did somebody win
or is it a tie
so you gotta add up all the numbers on
there anyway just in case they're all
filled up
and next we also need to know available
positions
these are ones that don't no one's ever
used before
this way when you try something or the
computer tries something it's not going
to give it an illegal move that's what
the available positions is doing
then we want to update our state
and so you have your position going in
we're just sending in the position that
you just chose and you'll see there's a
little user interface we put in there we
can
pick the row and column in there
and again
i mean this is a lot of code
so really it's kind of a thing you'd
want to go through and play with a
little bit and just read through it get
a copy of it a great way to understand
how this works
and here is a given reward
so we're going to give a reward
result equals self winner
this is one of the hearts of what's
going on here
is we have a result itself.winner
so if there's a winner then we have a
result that the result equals one here's
our feedback
if it doesn't equal one then it gets a
zero so it only gets a reward in this
particular case
if it wins
and that's important to know because
different
systems of reinforced learning
do rewarding a lot differently depending
on what you're trying to do this is a
very simple example with a
three by three board
imagine if you're playing a video game
certainly you only have so many actions
but your environment is huge you have a
lot going on in the environment and
suddenly a reward system like this
is going to be just
it's going to have to change a little
bit it's going to have to have different
rewards and different setup and there's
all kinds of advanced ways to do that as
far as weighing you add weights to it
and so
they can add the weights up depending on
where the reward comes in so it might be
that you actually get a reward in this
case you get the reward at the end of
the game
and i'm spending just a little bit of
time on this this is an important thing
to note but there's different ways to
add up those rewards it might have like
if you take a certain path
the first reward
is going to be weighed a little bit less
than the last reward because the last
reward is actually winning the game or
scoring or whatever it is
so this reward system gets really
complicated in some of the more advanced
setups
in this case though you can see right
here that they give a
a 0.1 and a 0.5 reward
just for getting picking the right value
and something that's actually valid
instead of picking an invalid value so
rewards again that's like key it's huge
how do you
feed the rewards back in
then we have a board reset that's pretty
straightforward it just goes back and
resets the board at the beginning
because it's going to try out all these
different things while it's learning
it's going to do it by trial and error
so you have to keep resetting it
and then of course there's the play we
want to go ahead and play rounds equals
depends on what you want to do on here
you can set this
different you obviously set that to
higher level but this is just going to
go through and you'll see in here
uh that we have player one and player
two
this is this is the computer playing
itself uh one of the more powerful ways
to learn to play a game or even learn
something that isn't a game is to have
two of these models
that are basically trying to beat each
other and so they always they keep
finding explore new things this one
works for this one so this one tries new
things it beats this we've seen this in
chess i think with some big one where
they had the two players in chess with
reinforcement learning
was one of the ways they trained one of
the top
computer chess playing algorithms
uh so this is just what this is it's
going to choose an action it's going to
try something and the more i try stuff
the more we're going to record the hash
we actually have a board hash where they
self get the hash
set up on here where it stores all the
information
and then once you get to a win
one of them wins it gets the reward uh
then we go back and reset and try again
and then kind of the fun part we
actually get down here is uh we're going
to play with a human so we'll get a
chance to come in here and see what that
looks like
when you put your own information in
and then it just comes in here and does
the same thing it did above it gives it
a reward for its things
or sees if it wins or ties
looks at available positions all that
fun of fun stuff
and then finally we want to show the
board
so it's going to print the board out
each time
really
as an integration is not that exciting
what's exciting
in here is one looking at this reward
system whoops play one more up the
reward system is really the heart of
this how do you reward the different
setup and the other
one is when it's playing it's got to
take an action
and so
what it chooses for an action is also
the heart of reinforcement learning how
do we choose that action
and those are really
key to right now where reinforcement
learning is
in
today's technology is
figuring this out
how do we reward it and how do we guess
the next best action so we have our
environment and you can see the
environment is we're going to be or the
state
which is kind of like what's going on
we're going to return the state
depending on what happens
and we want to go ahead and create our
agent in this case our player so each
one is let me go and grab that
until we look at a class player um
this is where a lot of the magic is
really going on is what how is this
player figuring out how to maneuver
around the board and then the board of
course returns a state
that it can look at and reward
so we want to take a look at this we
have name
self-state this is class player and when
you say class player we're not talking
about a human player we're talking about
just
the computer players
and this is kind of interesting so
remember i told you depending on what
you're doing there's going to be a decay
gamma
explore rate
these are what i'm talking about is how
do we train it
as you try different moves it gets to
the end the first move is important but
it's not as important as the last one
and so you could say that the last one
has the heaviest weight and then as you
as you get there the first one let's see
the first move gives you a five reward
the second gives you a two reward and
the third one gives you a 10 reward
because that's the final ending you got
it the 10 is going to count more than
the first step
and here's our we're going to get the
board information coming in and then
choose an action this was the second
part that i was talking about that was
so important
so once you have your training going on
we have to do a little randomness and
you can see right here is our np random
uniform so it's picking out a
random number
take a random action
this is going to just pick which row and
which column it is
and so choosing the action
this one you can see we're just doing
random states um choice length of
positions action position
and then it skips in there and takes a
look at the board uh for p in positions
it's actually storing the different
boards each time you go through
so it has a record of what it did so it
can properly weigh the values
and this simply just depends a hash
state what's the last date pinned it to
the
to our states on here
here's our feedback
rewards the reward comes in and it's
going to take a look at this and say is
it none
what is the reward and here is that
formula remember i was telling you about
up here
it was important because it has
decay gamma times the reward
this is where
as it goes through each step
and this is really important this is
this is kind of the heart of this of
what i was talking about earlier uh you
have step one
and this might have a reward of two
you have step two i should probably
should have done abc this has a step
three
uh step four
and so on until you get to step in
and this might have a reward of 10.
so reward a 10
we're going to add that but we're not
adding
let's say this one right here let's say
this reward here right before 10 was
um let's say it's also 10. it just makes
the
math easy
so we had 10 and 10.
we had 10 this is 10 and 10n whatever it
is
but it's time it's 0.9
so instead of putting a full 10 here
we only do 9 that's a
0.9
times
10.
and so this formula
um as far as the decay times the reward
minus the cell state value
uh it basically adds in it says here's
one or here's two i'm sorry i should
have done this abc would have been
easier
so the first move goes in here and it
puts 2 in here
then we have our self
setup on here you can see how this gets
pretty complicated in the math but this
is really the key is how do we train
our states and we want the the final
state the win to get the most points if
you win you get most points
and the first step gets the least amount
of points
so you're really training this almost in
reverse you're training you're training
it from the last place where you have
like it says okay this is now i was need
to sum up my rewards
and i want to sum them up going in
reverse and i want to find the answer in
reverse kind of an interesting
play on the mind when you're trying to
figure this stuff out
and of course we want to go ahead and
reset the board down here uh save the
policy
load policy
these are the different things that are
going in between the agent and the state
to figure out what's going on
let's go ahead and load that up
and then finally we want to go ahead and
create a human player
and the human player is going to be a
little different
in that
you choose an action row and column
here's your action
if action is
if action in positions meaning positions
that are available
you return the action
if not it just keeps asking you until
you get the action that actually works
and then we're going to go ahead and
append to the hash state which we don't
need to worry about because it returns
the action up here
and feed forward
again this is because it's a human
at the end of the game bat propagate and
update state values
this part isn't being done because
it's not programming uh
the model the model is getting its own
rewards
so we've gone ahead and loaded this in
here
so here's all our pieces and the first
thing we want to do
is set up p1 player 1
p2 player 2
and then we're going to send our players
to our state so now it has p1 p2
and it's going to play and it's going to
play 50 000 rounds
now we can probably do a lot less than
this and it's not going to get the full
results in fact you know what
let's go ahead and just do five
just to play with it because i want to
show you something here
oops
somewhere in there i forgot to load
something
there we go
i must have forgot to run this run
oops forgot a reference there for the
board rows and columns three by three
there is actually in the state it
references that we just tack it on on
the end it was supposed to be at the
beginning
so now i've only set this up
with
let's see where we go in here i've only
set this up to train
five times
and the reason i did that is we're going
to
come in and actually play it and then
i'm going to change that and we can see
how it differs on there
there we go and then you make it through
a run and we're going to go ahead and
save the policy
so now we have our player 1 and our
player 2 policy
the way we set it up it has two separate
policies loaded up in there
and then we're going to come in here and
we're going to do player 1 is going to
be the computer experience rate 0 load
policy 1
human player human and we're going to go
ahead and play this i remember only went
through it
just one round of training in fact
minimal training and so it puts an x
there and i'm going to go ahead and do
row 0
column 1.
you can see this is very
basic on here
and
so i put in my 0 and then i'm gonna go
zero block it zero
zero
and you can see right here it let me win
uh just like that i was able to win zero
two
and whoo human winds
so i only trained it five times we're
going to run this again
and this time
instead of five let's do 5 000 or 50 000
i think that's what the guys in the back
had
and this takes a while to train it
this is where reinforcement learning
really falls apart
look how simple this game is we're
talking about a three by three set of
columns
and so for me to train it on this
i could do a q table which would take
which would go much quicker
you could build a quick q table with
almost all the different options on
there
and uh
you would probably get a the same result
much quicker
we're just using this as an example
so when we look at reinforcement
learning you need to be very careful
what you apply it to it sounds like a
good deal until you do like a large
neural network
where you're doing you set the neural
network to a learning increment of one
so every time it goes through it learns
and then you do your actions you pick
from the learning
setup and you actually try actions on
the learning setup until you get what
you think is going to be the best action
so you actually feed what you think is
right back through the neural network
there's a whole layer there which is
really fun to play with
and then it has an output well think of
all those processes i mean that is just
a huge amount of work it's going to do
let's go ahead and skip ahead here give
it a moment it's going to take a
minute or two to go ahead and run
now to train it we went ahead and let it
run and it took a while this this took
um i got a pretty powerful processor and
it took about five minutes plus to run
it
and we'll go ahead and
run our player set up on here oops
brought in the last
whoops i brought in the last round so
give me just a moment to re
do the policy save there we go i forgot
to save the policy back in there
and then go ahead and run our player
again
so we've saved the policy then we want
to go ahead and load the policy for p1
as the computer
and we can see the computer's gone in
the bottom right corner i'm going to go
ahead and go 1-1 which is the center
and it's gone right up the top and if
you ever played tic-tac-toe you know the
computer has me but we'll go ahead and
play it out
row 0
column 2
there it is and then it's gone here and
so i'm going to go ahead and go row 0 1
no 0 1 there we go and column 0.
that's where i want it
oh and it says okay you your action
there we go boom
uh so you can see here we've got a
didn't catch the win on this it said tie
um kind of funny they didn't catch the
win on there
but if we play this a bunch of times
you'll find it's going to win more and
more the more we train it the more the
reinforcement happens
this lengthy training process
is really the stopper on reinforcement
learning
as this changes reinforcement learning
will be one of the more powerful
packages evolving over the next decade
or two
in fact i would even go as far as to say
it is the most important
machine learning tool and artificial
intelligence tool out there
as it learns not only a simple tic tac
toe board but we start learning
environments and the environment would
be like in language if you're
translating a language or something from
one language to the other so much of it
is lost if you don't know the context
it's in what's the environments it's in
and so being able to attach environment
and context and all those things
together is going to require
reinforcement learning to do
so again if you want to get a copy of
the tic tac toe board it's kind of fun
to play with run it you can test it out
you can do
you know test it for different uh values
you can switch from p1 computer
where we loaded the policy one to load
the policy two and just see how it
varies there's all kinds of things you
can do on there a quick
recap so we're going to go back and do a
reinforcement learning recap and you'll
remember we have our agent our action
our environment and our reward
and the state
and so reinforcement learning is a
branch of machine learning that trains a
model to come to an optimum solution for
a problem
by taking decisions by itself
so we look at it we analyze the data
make decisions solve problems
it consists of an environment
which an agent will interact with to
learn to reach a goal or perform an
action
you see here we have the dog and the
action equals fetching
and the first thing
you're going to notice here and i'll
talk a little bit more about this
is that our action is kind of a
singularity
the action isn't a regression type model
where we're looking at float numbers
or we're trying to predict something
or doing a reinforcement learning where
we're trying to guess the value of the
stock market where you have
5.33 5.33
this is very a little bit different and
you'll see why q learning is so powerful
but also where fall short
the agent is also given reward if the
action performed by it is bringing is
closer to the goal is leading to the
goal this is done to train the model in
the right direction you have a reward of
a hopefully a doggy cookie and action
equals fetching so gets a reward it gets
to go fetch the ball
reinforcement learning can be divided
based on whether the machine uses a
model to learn or learns by itself
so reinforcement learning it's model
based learn the model given model
and you can think of neural networks i
think are the most common right now used
for reinforcement learning there
certainly are a lot of other options out
there
but you have
this black box and you go back and you
send the error back up and it trains it
based on how much of an error the error
could be computed based on maybe a
maximum reward
um
subtraction or something like that so
the closer you get to uh the maximum
reward the better
and so we talk about a model free
you have your policy optimization and
your q learning
and
this is kind of the cool thing about q
learning is it can do it's very powerful
on certain things making it very quick
and easy to do a reinforcement learning
so what is q learning
q learning is reinforcement learning
policy which will fill the next best
action given a current state it chooses
this action at random and aims to
maximize the reward
and so you can see here's our standard
reinforcement learning graph
by now if you're doing any reinforcement
learning
you should
be familiar with this where you have
your agent your agent takes an action
the action affects the environment
and then the environment sends back the
reward or the feedback and the state
it's the new state the agent's in where
is it at on the chessboard where is it
at in the video game
if your robots out there picking trash
up off the side of the road where is it
at on the road
consider an ad recommendation system
usually when you look up a product
online
you get ads which will suggest the same
product over and over again
using q learning
we can make an ad recommendation system
which will suggest related products to
our previous purchase
the reward will be if user clicks on the
suggested product
and again you can see
you might have a lot of products on your
web advertisement or your pages but it's
still not a float number it's still a
set number and that's something to be
aware of when you're using q learning
and you can see here that if you have a
hundred people clicking on ads
and you click on one of the ads it might
go in there and say okay this person
clicked on this ad
what is the best set of ads based on
clicking on this ad or these two ads
afterwards based on where they are
browsing
so let's go ahead and look at some
important terms when we talk about q
learning
we have states the state s represents
the current position of an agent in an
environment
the action the action a is the step
taken by the agent when it is particular
state
rewards for every action the agent will
get a positive or negative reward
and again uh when we talk about states
we're usually not with when you're using
a q table you're not usually talking
about float variables you're talking
about true false
and we'll take a closer look at that in
a second
and episodes when an agent ends up in a
terminating state and can't take a new
action
uh this might be if you're playing a
video game your character stepped in and
is now dead or whatever
q values used to determine how good an
action a taken at a particular state s
is q a of s
and temporal difference a formula used
to find the q value by using the value
of the current state
and action and previous state in action
and various i mean there's bellman's
equation which basically is the equation
that
kind of covers what we just looked at in
all those different terms
the bellman equation is used to
determine the values of a particular
state and deduce how good it is to be in
take that state the optimal st the
optimal state will give us the highest
optimal value
factor influencing q values the current
state and action that's your essay so
your current state and your action
then you have your previous date in
action which is your s
i guess prime i'm not sure how they
reference that s prime a prime so this
is what happened before
uh then you have a reward for action so
you have your r reward
and you have your maximum expected
future reward
and you can see there's also a learning
rate put in there and a discount rate
so we're looking at these just like any
other model we don't want to have an
absolute
final value on here we don't want to if
you do absolute values instead of taking
smaller steps you don't really have that
approach to
the solution you just have a jump and
then pretty soon if you jump one
solution out that's what's going to be
the new solution whichever one jumps up
really high first
kind of ruining the whole idea of doing
a random selection i'll go into the
random selection just a second steps in
q learning
step one create an initial q table with
all values initialized to zero
again we're looking at
zero one uh so are you you know here's
our action we start we're an idol we
took a wrong action we took a correct
action and int
and then we have our actions fetching
sitting and running
of course we're just using the dog
example and choose an action and perform
it update values in the table and of
course when we're choosing an action
we're going to kind of do something
random and just randomly pick one so you
start out and you sit and you have then
then depending on that
action you took you can now update the
value for sitting after you start from
start to sitting
get the value of the reward and
calculate the value the value q value
using the bellman equation
and so now we attach a reward to sitting
and we attach all those rewards we
continue the same until the table is
filled with or an episode ends
and you and my machine is going to come
back to the random side of this and
there's a few different formulas they
use for the random
setup to pick it i usually look whatever
q model i'm using do their standard one
because someone's usually gone in and
done the math
for the optimal uh spread
but you can look at this if i have
running has a reward of 10 sitting as a
reward of seven fetching has a rewro or
to five
um
just kind of without doing like a
means to you know using the bell curve
for the means value and like i said
there's some math you can put in there
to pick um so that you're more like so
that writing has even a higher chance
but even if you were just going to do an
average on this
you could do an average a random number
by adding them all together uh so you
get 10 plus 7 plus 5 is
22 you could do 0 to 22
or 0 to 21 but 1 to 22
1 to 5 would be fetching uh and so forth
you know the last 10.
so you can just look at this as what
percentage are you going to go for that
particular option
and then that gets your random setup in
there and then as you slowly increment
these up
you see that
if you're idle
where's one here we go sitting at the
end
if you're at the end or wherever you're
at sitting gets a reward of one
um where's the good one on here oh wrong
action running for a wrong action gets
almost no reward
so that becomes very very less likely to
happen but it still might happen it
still might have a percentage of coming
up
and that's where the random programming
and q learning comes in the below table
gives us an idea of how many times an
action has been taken in how positively
correct action or negatively wrong
action it is going to affect the next
state
so let's go ahead and dive in and pull
up a little piece of code and see what
this looks like
[Music]
in python
in this demo we'll use q learning to
find the shortest path between two given
points
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit skill up by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know more
if you've seen my videos before
i like to do it in the
anaconda jupiter notebook
setup just because it's really easy to
see and it's a nice demo uh and so
here's my anaconda this one i'm actually
using a python36 environment that i set
up in here
and we'll go ahead and launch the
jupiter notebook on this
and once we're in our jupiter notebook
which has the kernel loaded with python3
we'll go ahead and create a new python 3
folder in here
and we'll call this
q
learning
and to start this demo
let's go ahead and import our numpy
array we'll just run that so it's
imported
and like a lot of these uh model
programs when you're building them you
spend a lot of time putting it all
together
and then you end up with this really
short answer at the end
and we'll we'll take a look at that as
we come into it so we go ahead and start
with our location to state uh so we have
l1 l2 these are our nine locations one
to nine
and then of course the state is going to
be zero one two three four it's just a
mapping of our location to a integer on
there and then we have our actions our
actions are simply
moving from
one location
to another so i can go to i can go to
location zero i can go to location one
two three four five six seven eight
so these are my actions i can choose
these are the locations of our state
and if you remember earlier i mentioned
that the limitation
is that you you don't want to put in
um a continually growing table because
you can actually create a dynamic cue
table where you continually add in new
values as they arise
because
if you have float values it just becomes
infinite and then your memory in your
computer is gone or you know does it's
not going to work
at the same time you might think well
that kind of really limits the the q uh
learning setup
but there are ways to use it in
conjunction with other systems
and so you might look at
well i do
i've been doing some work in stock
and one of the questions that comes out
is to buy or sell the stock
and the stake coming in
might be um you might take a concrete
way called buckets
where anything that you predict is going
to return more than a certain amount of
money
the error for that stock that you've had
in the past you put those in buckets and
suddenly you start putting creating
these buckets you realize you do have a
limited amount of information coming in
you no longer have a float number you
now have
bucket one two three and four
and then you can take those buckets
put them through a
q learning table
and come up with the best action which
stock should i buy it's like gambling
stock is pretty much gambling if you're
doing day trading you're not doing long
term
investments and so you can start looking
at it like that a lot of the
current fees say that the best
algorithms used for day traders redoing
it on your own
is really to ask the question do i want
to trade the stock yes or no and now you
have it in a q learning table and now
you can take it to that next level and
you can see where that can be a really
powerful tool at the end of doing a
basic linear regression model or
something
what is the best investment and you
start getting the best reward on there
and so if we're going to have rewards
these rewards we just create
it says uh if basically if you're
this should match our q table because
it's going to be uh you have your state
and you have your action across the top
if you remember from the dog
and so we have whatever state we're in
going down and then the next action and
what the reward is for it
and of course if you were actually doing
a
something more connected your reward
would be based on
the actual environment it's in
and then we want to go ahead and create
a state to location
so we can map the indexes
so just like we defined our rewards
we're going to go and do state to
location
and you can see here it's a dictionary
setup for location state in location to
state with items
and
we also need to
define what we want for
learning rates
you remember
we had our two different rates um as far
as like learning from the past and
learning from the current so we'll go
ahead and set those to 0.75 and the
alpha set to 0.9
and we'll see that when we do the
formula
and of course any of this code send a
note to our simply learn team they'll
get you a copy of this code
on here let's go ahead and pull
there we go
the next two sections
since we're going to keep it
short and sweet
here we go so let's go ahead and create
our agent
so our agent
is going to have our initialization
where we send it all the information uh
we'll define ourself gamma equals gamma
we could have just set the gamma rate
down here instead of submitting it
it's kind of nice to keep them separate
because you can play with these numbers
on our self alpha
then we have our location state we'll
set that in here we have our choice of
actions
um we're going to go ahead and just
embed the rewards right into the agent
so obviously this would be coming from
somewhere else
instead of from
self-generated and then a self-state to
location equals our state to location
dictionary
and we go ahead and create a q learning
table and i went ahead and just set the
q learning table up to
zero to zero what what what the setup is
location to state how many of them are
there
and this just creates an array of zero
to zero set up on there
and then the big part is the training we
have our rewards new equals a copy of
self.rewards
ending state equals the self-location
state in location so this is whatever we
end up at rewards new equals ending
state plus ending state equals 999 just
kind of goes
to a dead end
and
we start going through iterations
and we'll go ahead let's do this
so this we're going to come back and
we're going to call call it on here
let me just erase that
switch it to an arrow
there we go
uh so what we're doing is we're going to
send in here to train it we're going to
say hey
i want to iterate through this a
thousand times
and see what happens now this part would
actually be
instead of iterating you might have your
external environment and they're going
back and forth and you iterate through
outside of here
but just for ease of use our agent is
going to come in here and iterate
through this
sometimes i'll put this iteration in
here
and i'll have it call the environment
and say hey this is what i did what's
the next state and the environment does
this thing right in here as i iterate
through it
and then we want to go ahead and pick a
random state to start with
that's what's going on here you have to
start somewhere
and then you have your playable actions
we're going to start with just an empty
thing for playable actions and we'll
fill that up
so that's what choices i have
and so we're going to iterate through
the rewards matrix to get the states
directly reachable from the randomly
chosen current state assign those states
to a list named playable actions
and so you can see here we have a range
nine i usually use length of whatever
i'm looking at which is our locations
or states as they are
we have a reward
so we want to look at the current the
rewards uh the new reward
is our
is in our chart here of rewards
underscore new uh current state
plus j
j being what is the next date we want to
try
and so we go and do our playable actions
and we append j
and so we're doing is we're randomly
trying different things in here to see
what's going to generate a better reward
and then of course we go ahead and
choose our next state
so we have our random choice playable
actions
and if you remember
i mentioned on this let me just go ahead
and let's just do a free form
when we were talking about the next
state
this right here just does a random
selection
instead of a random
selection you might do something where
whatever the best selection is
which might be option three
here and then so you can see that it
might use a bell curve and then option
two over here might have a bell curve
like this oops and we start looking at
these averages and these spreads
or we can just add them all together and
pick the one that kind of goes in all of
those
so those are some of the options we have
in here we just go with a random choice
that's usually where you start play with
it
and then we have our
rewards section down here
and so we want to go ahead and find well
in this case the temporal difference
so you have your rewards new
plus the self gamma and this is the
formula we were looking at
this is bellman's equation here
uh so we have our current value our
learning rate our discount rate involved
in there the reward system coming in for
that
and we can add it all together
this is of course our uh maximum
expected future setup in here
uh so this is all of our our bellman's
equation that we're looking at here
and then we come up in here and we
update our q table that's all this is on
this one
and that's right here we have
self cue current state next date and we
add in our alpha because we don't want
to we don't want to train all of it at
once in case there's slight differences
coming in there we want to slowly
approach the answer
and then we have our route equals the
start location
and next location equals start location
so we're just incrementing we took a
step forward
and then finally
remember i was telling you how we're
gonna do all this and just have some
simple thing at the end or just
generates a simple path
we're gonna go ahead and get the optimal
route we wanna find the best route in
here and so we've created a definition
for the optimal route down here
just scroll down for that
and we get the optimal route we go ahead
and put the information in including the
queue table self
start location in location next location
route queue and it says while next
location is not equal to in location so
while we can still go
our start location equals self location
to state start location so we already
have our best value for the start
location
the next state looks at the q table and
says hey what's uh the next one with the
best value and then the next location we
go ahead and pull that in and we just
append it that's what's going on down
here
and then our start location equals the
next location and we just go through all
the steps and we'll go ahead and run
this
and now that we have our q table our
q agent loaded
we're going to go ahead and take our q
agent
load them up with our alpha gamma that
we set up above
along with the location step action
reward state to location
and
our goal is to
plot a course between l9 and l1
and we're going to go through a hundred
a thousand iterations on here
and so when i run that it runs pretty
quick
uh why is this so fast um
if you've been running neural networks
and you've been doing all these other
models you sit here and wait a long time
well we're very small amount of data
these are all integers these aren't
float values there's not a the math is
not heavy on the on the processing end
and this is where q tables are so
powerful if you have a small amount of
information coming in you very quickly
uh get an answer off of this even though
we went through it a thousand times to
train it and you'll see here we have l
nine eight five two and one and that's
based on our reward table we had set up
on there and this is the shortest path
going between these different uh setups
in here
and if you remember on our reward table
you can see that if you start here you
can go to here there's places you can't
go that's how this reward table was set
up so i can only go to certain places
uh so kind of a little maze set up in
there and you can play with it this is
really fun uh set up to play with
and you can see how you can take this
whole code and you can like i was saying
earlier you can embed it into another
setup and model and predictions where
you put things into buckets and you're
trying to guess the best investment the
best course of action
long as you can take that course into
action and
reduce it down to a yes no
or if you're using text
you can use a one hot encoder which word
is next there's all kinds of things you
can do with a cue table
depending on just how much information
you're putting in there
so that wraps up our demo in this demo
we've found the shortest distance
between two paths based on whatever
rules or state rewards we have to get
from point a to point b and what
available actions there are the
principal component
analysis we're going to cover
dimensionality reduction principle
component analysis what is it
important pca terminologies and you'll
see it abbreviated normally as pca
principal component analysis pca
properties pca example and then we'll
pull up some python code in our jupyter
notebook and have some hands-on demo on
the pca and how it's used dimensionality
reduction dimensionality reduction
refers to the technique that reduces the
number of input variables in a data set
and so you can see on the table on the
right shows the orders made at an
automobile parts retailer the retailer
sells different automobile parts from
different companies and you can see we
have company b-packs isomax and they
have the item the tire the axle an order
id a price number and a quantity in
order to predict the future cells
we find out that using correlation
analysis
that we just need three attributes
therefore we have reduced the number of
attributes from five to three
and clearly we don't really care about
the part number i don't think the part
number would have an effect on how many
tires are bought
and even the store who's buying them
probably does not have an effect on that
in this case that's what they've
actually done is remove those and we
just have the item the tire the price
and the quantity one of the things you
should be taking away from this is in
the scheme of things
we are in the descriptive phase we're
describing the data and we're
pre-processing the data what can we do
to clean it up
why dimensionality reduction
well number one less dimensions for a
given data set means less computation or
training time
that can be really important if you're
trying a number of different models
and you're re-running them over and over
again and even if you have seven
gigabytes of data that can start taking
days to go through all those different
models
so this is huge this is probably the
hugest part as far as reducing
our data set
redundancy is removed after removing
similar entries from the data set
again pre-processing some of our models
like a neural network if you put in two
of the same data it might give them a
higher weight than they would if it was
just once we want to get rid of that
redundancy
it also increases the processing time if
you have multiple
data coming in
space required to store the data is
reduced
so if we're committing this into a big
data pool we might not send the company
that bought it why would we want to
store two whole extra columns when we
added into that pool of data
makes the data easy for plotting in 2d
and 3d plots this is my favorite part
very important you're in your
shareholder meeting
you want to be able to give them a
really good
clear
and simplified version you want to
reduce it down to something people can
take in
it helps to find out the most
significant features and skip the rest
which also comes in in post scribing
leads to better human interpretation
that kind of goes with number four what
makes data easy for plotting you have a
better interpretation when we're looking
at it principle component analysis
so what is it
uh principle component analysis is a
technique for reducing the
dimensionality of data sets increasing
interpretability but at the same time
minimizing information loss so we take
some very complex data set with lots of
variables we run it through the pca
we reduce the variables we end up with a
reduced variable setup
this is very confusing to look at
because if you look at the end result we
have the different colors all lined up
so what we're going to take a look at is
let's say we have a picture here
let's say you are asked to take a
picture of some toddlers and you are
deciding which angle would be the best
to take the picture from so if we come
up here we look at this we say okay this
is you know one angle uh we get the back
of a lot of heads not many faces
uh so we'll do it from here we might get
the one person up front smiling a lot of
the people in the class are missing so
we have a huge amount off to the right
of blank space maybe from up here again
we have the back of someone's head
and it turns out that the best angle to
click the picture from might be this
bottom left angle you look at it you say
hey that makes sense it's a good
configuration of all the people in the
picture now when we're talking about
data
it's not
you really can't do it by what you think
is going to be the best we need to have
some kind of mathematical formula so
it's consistent and so it makes sense in
the back end
one of the projects i worked on many
years ago
has something similar to the iris if
you've ever done the iris data sets
probably one of the
most common ones out there where they
have the flower
and they're measuring the stamen in the
petals and they have width and they have
length of the petal
instead of putting through the width and
the length of the petal we could just as
easily do the
width to length ratio we can divide the
width by the length and you get a single
number where you had two
that's the kind of idea that's going on
into this in pre-processing and looking
at what we can do to bring the data down
the very simplified example on my
iris
pedal example
when we look at the similarity in pca we
find the best picture or projection of
the data points
and so we look down at from one angle
we've drawn a line down there
we can see these data points based on in
this case just two variables now keep in
mind we're usually talking about 36 40
variables
almost all of your
business models usually have about 26 to
27 different variables they're looking
at
same thing with like a bank loan model
we're talking 26 to 36 different
variables they're looking at that are
going in
so we want to do is we want to find the
best view in this case we're just
looking at the x y
we look down at it and we have our
second
idea pc2 and again we're looking at the
x i this x y this time from a different
direction
here for our e's we can consider that we
get two principal components namely pc1
and pc2
comparing both the principal components
we find the data points are sufficiently
spaced in pc1
so if you look at what we got here we
have uh pc1 you can see along the line
how the data points are spaced versus
the spacing in pc2 and that's what
they're coming up with what is going to
give us the best look for these data
points when we combine them and we're
looking at them from just a single angle
whereas in pc2 they are less spaced
which makes the observation and further
calculations much more difficult
therefore we accept the pc1 and not the
pc2 as the data points are more spaced
now obviously the back end calculations
are a little bit more complicated when
we get into the math of how they decide
what is more valuable
this gives you an idea though that when
we're talking about this we're talking
about the perspective which would help
in understanding how pca analysis works
we want to go ahead and do is dive into
the important terminologies under pca
and important terminologies are views
the perspective through which data
points are observed
and so you'll hear that if someone's
talking about a pca presentation and
they're not taking the time to reduce it
to something that the average person
shareholders can understand you might
hear them refer to it as the different
views what view are we taking
dimension number of columns in a data
set are called the dimensions of that
data set
and we talked about you'll hear features
dimensions
i was talking about features there's
usually when you're running a business
you're talking 25 26 27 different
features minimal and then you have the
principal component new variables that
are constructed as linear combinations
or mixtures of the initial variables
principal component is very important
it's a combination if you remember my
flower example it would be the
width over the length of the petal as
opposed to putting both width and length
in you just put in the
ratio instead which is a single number
versus two separate numbers
projections
the perpendicular distance between the
principal component and the data points
and that goes to that line we had
earlier it's that right angle line of
where those point how those points fall
onto the line
important properties important
properties number of principal
components is always less than or equal
to the number of attributes
that just makes common sense you're not
going to do
10 principal properties with only three
features
you're trying to reduce them so it's
just kind of goofy but it is important
to remember that people will throw
weird code out there and just randomly
do stuff with instead of really thinking
it through principal components are
orthogonal
and this is what we're talking about
that right angle from the line when we
when we do pc1 we're looking at how
those points fall on to that line
same thing with pc2
we want to make sure that pc1 does not
equal pc2 we don't want to have the same
two principal points
when we do two points
the priority of principal components
decreases as their numbers
increase
this is important to understand
if you're going to create
one principle
component
everything is summarized into that one
component as we go to two components the
priority
how much it holds value
decreases as we go down so if you have
five different points each one of those
points is going to have less value than
just the one point which has everything
summarized in it
how pca works
i said there was more in the back end we
talked about the math this is what we're
talking about is how does it actually
work
so now we have understanding that you're
looking at a perspective
now we want to see how that math side
works pca performs the following
operations in order to evaluate the
principal components for a given data
set
first we start with the standardization
then we have a covariance matrix
computation
and we use that to generate our i gene
vectors and i gene values
which is the feature vector and if you
remember the i gene vector is like a
translation for
moving the data
from x equals one to x equals two or
whatever we're altering it and the i
gene value is the final value that we
generate
we talk about standardization the main
aim of this step is to standardize the
range of the attributes so that each one
of them lie within similar boundaries
this process involves removal of the
mean from the variable values and
scaling the data with respect to the
standard deviation
and you can see here we have z equals
the variable values minus the mean over
the standard deviation
the covariance matrix computation
covariance matrix is used to express the
correlation between any two or more
attributes in multi-dimensional data set
the covariance matrix has the entries as
the variance and the covariance of the
tribute values the variance is denoted
by var and the covariance is denoted by
cov
on the right we can see the covariance
matrix for two attributes and their
values
when we do a hands-on and look at the
code we'll do a display of this so you
can see what we're talking about and
what that looks like
for now you can just notice that this is
a matrix that we're generating with the
variance and then the covariance of x to
y
on the right side we can see the
covariance
table for more than two attributes in a
multi-dimensional data set
this is what i was talking about we
usually are looking at not just one
feature or two features
we're usually looking at 25 30 features
going on
and so if we do i was set up like this
we should see all those different
features as the different variables
covariance matrix tells us how the two
or more variables are related positive
covariance indicate that the value of
one variable is directly proportional to
the other variable
negative covariance indicate that the
value of one variable is inversely
proportional to the other variable that
is always important to note whenever
we're doing any of these matrixes that
we're going to be looking at that
positive and negative whether it's
inverted or not
and then we have the i gene values and
the i gene vectors
i gene values and hygiene vectors are
the mathematical value
that are extracted from the covariance
table
they are responsible for the generation
of a new set of variables from the old
set of variables which further lead to
the construction of the principal
components
iogene vectors do not change directions
after linear
i transformation
values are the scalars or the magnitude
of the i gene vectors
and again this is just chain
transforming that data so we're going to
change uh the vector b
to the b
prime as denoted on the chart
and so when we have like multiple
variables how do we calculate that new
variable
and then we have feature vectors feature
vectors is simply a matrix that has igen
vectors of the components that we decide
to keep as the columns
here we decide whether we must keep or
discard the less significant principal
components that we have generated in the
above steps
this becomes really important as we
start looking at
the back end of this and we'll do this
in the demo
but one of the more important steps to
understand
and so we have the pca example consider
matrix x within rows or observations and
k columns or variables now for this
matrix we would construct a variable
space with as many dimensions as the
variable
but for our simplicity let's consider
this three dimensions for now
now each observation row of the matrix x
is placed in the k dimensional variable
space such that the rows in the data
table form a swarm of points in this
space
now we find the mean of all the
observations and then place it along the
data points on the plot
the first principal component
is a line that best accounts for the
shape of the point swarm it represents
the maximum variance direction in the
data
each observation may be projected onto
this line in order to get a coordinate
value along the pc1 this value is known
as a score
usually only one principal component is
insufficient to model the systematic
variation for a data set thus a second
principal axis is created
the second principle component is
oriented such that it reflects the
second largest source of variation in
the data while being orthogonal to pc1
pc2 also passes through the average
point
let's go ahead and pull this up and just
see what that means
inside our python scripting
i'm going to use the anaconda navigator
and i will be in python 3.6
for this example
i believe there's even like a 3.9 out
i tend to stay in 3.6 because a lot of
the models i use especially with the
neural networks are stable in three six
and then we open up our
jupiter i'm in chrome and we go ahead
and create a new python three
and for ease of use uh our team in the
back was nice enough to put this
together for me
and we'll go and start with the
libraries
the first thing i like to do whenever
i'm looking at
any new setup
uh well you know what let's do let's do
the libraries first we're going to do
our basic libraries which is matplot
library uh the plt from the matplot
library pandas our data frame
pd numpy our numbers array np
seaborn for graphing sns that goes with
the plot that actually sits on matplot
library so the seaborn sits on there
and then we have our amber sign because
we're in jupiter notebook map plot
library in line the newer version
actually doesn't require that but i put
it in there either
anyway just because i'm so used to it
and then we want to go ahead and take a
look at the data
and in this case we're going to pull in
certainly you can have lots of fun with
different data but we're going to use
the cancer data set
and one of the reasons the cancer data
set is it has like 36 35 different
features
so it's kind of fun to use that as our
base for this
and we'll go ahead and run this and look
at our keys
and the first thing we notice in our
keys for the cancer data set
is we have our data we have our target
our frame target names description
feature names and file name
so
what we're looking for in all this
is um well let's take a look at the
description let's go in here and pull up
the description on here
i'm not going to spend a huge amount of
time on the description
because this is we don't want to get
into a medical domain we want to focus
on our pca setup
what's important is you start looking at
what the different attributes are what
they mean
if you were in the medical field you'd
want to note all these different things
whether what they're measuring where
it's coming from
you can actually see the actual
different
measurements they're taking
no missing
let attributes
page all the way to the bottom and
you're going to have your data in this
case our target
and if you dig deep enough to the target
let's actually do this
let's go ahead and print target names
real quick here i always like to just
take a look and see what's on the other
end of this
target
names
run that
yeah so the target name is is it
malignant or is it b9
so in other words is this
a dangerous growth or is it something we
don't have to worry about that's the
bottom line with the cancer in this case
and then we can go ahead and load our
data
and you know let me go up a just a notch
here for easy of reading
hard to get that just right that's all
you have to do
uh so let's go ahead and look at our
data uh our we're going to use our
pandas
and we're going to go ahead and do our
data frame it's going to equal cancer
data columns equals cancer feature
equals feature names so remember up here
we already loaded the the
names up of our of the features in there
what is going to come out of this let me
just see if we can get to that
it's at the top of target names
that's just this list of names here in
the setup
and we can go ahead and run this code
and it'll print the head
and you can see here we have the mean
radius the mean texture mean perimeter
i don't know about you this is a
wonderful data set if you're playing
with it because
like many of the data that cut most the
data that comes in half the time we
don't even know we're looking at
we're just handed a bunch of stuff as a
data scientist going what the heck is
this
and so this is a good place to start
because this has a number of different
features in there we have no idea what
these feature means or where they come
from we want to just look at the data
and figure that out
and now we actually are getting into the
pca side of it as we've noticed before
is difficult to visualize high
dimensional data
we can use pca to find the first two
principal components and visualize the
data this new two-dimensional space with
a single scatter plot
before we do this we need to go ahead
and scale our data
now
i haven't run this to see if you really
have to scale the data on this
but as just a general
run time i almost do that as the first
step of any modeling even if it's
pre-modeling as we're doing here
in neural networks that is so important
with pca visualization it's already
going to scale it when we do the means
and deviation inside the pca
but just in case it's always good to
scale it
and then we're going to take our pca
with the scikit learn uses very similar
process to other pre-processing
functions that come with scikit-learn
we instantiate a pca object find the
principal components using the fit
method then apply the rotation and
dimensionality reduction by calling
transform we can also specify how many
components we want to
keep when creating the pca object
and so the code for this
oops getting a little bit ahead
let me go and run this code
uh so the code for this
is
from sklearn decomposition import pca
pca equals pca in components equals two
and that's really important to note that
because we're only going to want to look
at two components
i would never go over four components
especially if you're going to demo this
with somebody else if you're showing
this to the shareholders the whole idea
is to reduce it to something people can
see
and then the pca fit we're going to is
going to take the scaled data that we
generated up here
and then you can see we've created our
pca model with in components equals two
now whenever i use a new tool
i like to go in there and actually see
what i'm using so let's go to the scikit
webpage for the pca
and you can see in here here's our call
statement it describes what all the
different setups you have on there
probably the biggest one to look at
would be
well the biggest one is your components
how many components do you want
which you have to put in there pretty
much and then you also might look at the
svd solver it's on auto right now but
you can override that and do different
things with it it does a pretty good job
as it is
and if we
go down all the way down to
there we go
to our methods
if you notice we have fit
and we have fit transform
nowhere in here is predict because this
is not used for prediction
it's used to look at the data again
we're in the describe setup
we're fitting the data we're taking a
look at it
we've already looked at our
minimum maximum we've already looked at
what's in each quarter we've done a full
description of the data this is part of
describing the data
that's the biggest thing i take away
when i come zooming in here and of
course i have examples of it down here
if you forget
and the biggest one of course is the
number of components
and then i mean the rest you can play
with
the actual solver whether you're doing a
full or randomize there's different
things it does pretty good on the auto
and now we can transform this data to
its first two principal components
and so we have our xpca
we're going to set that equal to pca
transform scaled data
so there we go there's our first
transformation
and let's just go ahead and print the
scaled data shape and the xpca data
shape
and the reason we want to do this is
just to show us
what's going on here we've taken 30
features i think i said 36 or something
like that but it's 30.
and we've compressed it down to two
features and we decided we wanted two
features and that's where this comes
from
we still have 569 data sets
i mean data rows data sets we still have
569 rows of data but instead of
computing 30 features we're now only
doing our model on two features
so let's go ahead and uh
plot these and take a look and see
what's going on
and
we're just going to use our plt figure
we'll set the figure size on here here's
our scatter plot
xpca
x underscore pca of
one these are two different
perceptions we're using
uh and then
you'll see right here c for color cancer
equals target
and so remember we have zero we have one
and if i remember correctly zero was
malignant one was b9
so everything in the zero column is
going to be one color and the other
color is going to be one and then we're
going to use the plasma map just kind of
telling you what color it is add some
labels first principle component second
principle component and we'll go ahead
and run this
and you can see here instead of having a
chart one of those heat maps with 30
different
columns in it
we can look at this and say hey this one
actually did a pretty good job
of separating the data
and a couple of things when i'm looking
at this that i notice is first
we have a very clear area where it's
clumped together
where it's going to be benign
and we have a huge area it's still
clumped together more spread out where
it's going to be malignant or i think i
had that backwards
and then in the middle
because we're dealing with something
in this particular case cancer
we would try to separate i would be
exploring how to separate this middle
group out
in other words there's an area where
everything overlaps and we're not going
to have a clear result on it
just because those are the people you
want to go in there and have extra tests
or treat it differently
versus going in and saying just cutting
into the can into the cancer so the body
absorbs it and it dissipates versus uh
actively going in there removing it
testing it going through chemo and all
the different things that's a big
difference you know as far as what's
going to happen here in that middle line
where the overlap is going to be huge
that's domain specific going back to the
data
we can see here
clearly by using these two components we
can easily separate these two classes
so the next step is what does that mean
interpreting the components
unfortunately with this great power of
dimensionality reduction comes the cost
of not being able to easily understand
what these components represent
i don't know what principle component
one looks work represents or second
principle
the components correspond to
combinations of original features the
components themselves are stored as an
attribute of the filtered pca object and
so we talk look at that we can go ahead
and do uh look at the pca components
this is in our model we built we've
trained it we can run that and you can
see here's the actual components uh it's
the two components have each have their
own array
and within the array you can see the
what the scores they're using
and these actually give weight to what
features are doing what so in this numpy
matrix array each row represents a
principal component and each column
relates back to the original features
what's really neat about this is we can
now go in reverse
and drop this onto a heat map
and start seeing uh what this means and
so let me go ahead and just put this
down up there to get it down here
uh we'll go ahead and put this in here
we're going to use our
df comp data frame and we do our pca
components
and i want you to notice how easy this
is uh
we're going to set our columns equal to
cancer feature names
that just makes it really easy
and we're dumping it into a data frame
what's needed about a data frame is when
we get to seaborn it will pull that data
frame apart and uh
and set it up for us we want
and so we're just going to do the see
the seaborn heat map
of our data frame composition and we'll
use the plasma coloring
and it creates a nice little
color graph here
you can see we have the mean radius and
all the different features along the
bottom
on the right we have a scale so we can
see we have the dark colors all the way
to the really light colors which are
what's really shining there this is like
the primary stuff we want to look at
so this heat map and the color bar
basically represent the correlation
between the various features and the
principal component itself
so you know very powerful map to look at
and then you can go in here and we might
notice that the mean radius
look how how on the bottom of the map it
is
on some of this
so you have some interesting
correlations here that change the
variations on that and what means what
this is more when you get to a post
scribe you can also use this to try to
guess as what these things mean and what
you want to change to get a better
result
regularization in machine learning
so our agenda on this one is fitting the
data
understanding linear regression
bias and variance
what is overfitting
what is underfitting and those are like
the biggest things right now in data
science is overfitting and underfitting
what does that mean
and what is regularization and then
we'll do a quick hands-on demo to take a
look at this
so fitting the data let's start with
fitting the data and we talk about
what is data fitting it's a process of
plotting a series of data points and
drawing the best fit line to understand
the relationship between the variables
and this is what we called data fitting
and you can see here we have a couple of
lines we've drawn on this graph we're
going to go in a little deeper on there
so we might have in this case just the
two dimensions we have an efficiency of
the car and we have the distance
traveled in 1 000 kilometers
and so what is data fitting well it's a
linear relationship and a linear
relationship
very specifically linear means line
the line used to represent the
relationship is a straight line that
passes through the data points and the
variables have linear relationship
linear regression
so let's start with how linear
regression works a linear regression
finds a line that best fits the data
point and gives a relationship between
the two
variables and so you can see here we
have the efficiency of the car
versus the distance traveled and you can
see this nice straight line drawn
through there
and when you talk about multiple
variables all you're doing is putting
this instead of a line that now becomes
a plane
it gets a little more complicated with
multiple variables but they all come
down to this linear kind of drawing a
line through your data and finding what
fits the the data the best
and so we can consider an example uh
let's say that we want to find the
relationship between the temperature
outside versus the sales of ice cream
and so we start looking at that we're
looking at the how many ice cream cones
we're selling or how much money we sold
in ice cream and we're looking at how
warm it is outside which would hopefully
draw a lot of people into the ice cream
store
and suppose we have two lines we're
going to draw l1 and l2 and we're going
to kind of guess which one we think is
the best fit
and which claim to describe the
relationship between the variables
and so first we find the square of the
distance between the line l1
and each data point and add them all and
find the mean distance
and i want you to think about that when
we
square something if it's a negative or
positive number it no longer matters
because a minus 2 squared is 4 2 squared
is 4. so we're removing what side of the
line it's on and we're just looking for
the error in this case the mean distance
of each of the little dotted lines you
see here
this way of calculating the square of
the distance adding them and then taking
the mean is called mean square error or
loss function
and we talk about loss how far off are
we that's what we're really talking
about what did we miss uh and we have a
positive distance and a negative
distance and of course when we square it
it is neither it just becomes a positive
error
and so we take the mean
square error and a lot of times you'll
see it referred to as mse
if i look in the code and i'm going
through my python code and i see mse i
know that's a mean squared error and we
take all the dotted lines and we
calculate this error we add them all
together and then we average it or find
the means
and in this case
they ran a demo on this and it was uh
1127.27
for our l1 line
now we find the loss function for line
l2 in a similar fashion and we get the
mean square error to be 6397
and it's computed the same way so maybe
you put this line just way outside the
data range and this is the error you get
by analyzing our results we find that
the loss function or the mean square
error is less for l1 than l2 hence l1 is
the best fit line
this process describes a lot of machine
learning processes it is we're going to
keep guessing and get as close as we can
to find the right answer we have to have
some way to invite algorithm has limited
flexibility to learn from data
variance defines the algorithm's
sensitivity to specific sets of data
let's start with bias and variance you
can see here we have the two different
setups
uh bias you can think is very
generalized where variance is very
specific
uh and so we talk about bias such models
pay very little attention to the
training data and over simplify the
model
therefore the validation error or
prediction error and training error
follow similar trends
and
with bias if you oversimplify it so much
you're going to miss
your
local
if if you have like a really
good fit you're going to miss it you're
you're going to just kind of
guess what the average is and that's
what your answer is going to be with
variance a model with a high variance
pays a lot of attention to training data
and does not generalize therefore the
validation error or prediction error are
far apart from each other
such models always lead to a high error
on training and test data as a bias does
where variants such models usually
perform very well on training data but
have high error rates on test data
and i want you to think about this
when we're talking about a bias uh the
error is going to be high both when
you're training it and you're testing it
why because we're just kind of
getting an average we're not really
fitting it close
with variance we're fitting it so close
that the test data does really good it's
going to nail it every time if you're
doing categorical testing that's a car
that's a truck that's a bicycle
but with variants
suddenly
a truck has to have certain features
and it might have to be red
because you had so many red pictures so
if it has if it's an 18 wheeler it has
to be red if it's blue then it has to be
a bicycle
that's the kind of variance we're
talking about where it picks up on
something and it it cannot get the right
answer unless it gets a very specific
data
and we see that so that as you're
testing it your models
and you programmed it you got to look
for
how i trained it what is coming out and
if it's not if it's not looking good on
either bias or if it's not looking good
on the training
or on the test data
then your bias then your bias in your
data
if it really looks good on the training
data then that's going to be your
variance you've over fitted the data
and those are very important things to
know when you are building your models
uh in regression of any kind or any kind
of setup for predicting
so in dark games if all the data found a
particular pointer this can be
considered as a biased throw and the
player aims for the particular score
for variance if all the darts fall in
different pointers and no two darts fall
on the same pointer then this can be
considered as a varied throw and the
player aims for various scores
again the bias sums everything up in one
point kind of averages it together where
the variance really looks for the
individual
predictions coming out
so let's go ahead and talk about
overfitting
when we talk about overfitting it's a
scenario where the machine learning
model tries to learn from the details
along with the noise and the data tries
to fit each data point on the curve
you can see that
if you plug in your coordinates you're
just going to get the whatever is fitted
every point on the data stream there's
no average there's no
two points that might have that you know
why might have two different answers
because
if the wind blows a certain way
in the efficiency of your car maybe you
have a headwind so your car might alter
how efficient it is as it goes and so
there's going to be this variance on
here and this says no you can't have any
variance with you know the this is it's
going to be exactly this it can't be any
you can't be the same speed or the same
car and have a slightly different
efficiency
so as the model has very less
flexibility it fails to predict new data
points and thus the model rejects every
new data point during the prediction
uh so you'll get like a really high
error on here
and so uh reasons for overfitting
data used for training is not cleaned
and contains noise garbage values in it
you can spend so much time cleaning your
data
and it's so important it's so important
that if you have if you have some kind
of
something wrong with the data coming in
it needs to be addressed whether it's a
source of the data maybe they use in
medical different measuring
tools so you now have to adjust for data
that came in from hospital a versus
hospital b or even off of machine a and
machine b that's testing something and
those those numbers are coming in wrong
the model has a high variance
again wind is a good example i was
talking about that with the car
you may have a hundred tests but because
the wind's blowing it's all over the
place
uh size of training data used is not
enough so a small amount of data is
going to also cause this problem you
only have a few points and you try to
plot everything
the model is too complex
this comes up a lot
we put too many pieces together and how
they interact can't even be tracked
and and so you have to go back back
break it up and find out actually what
correlates and what doesn't
so
what is underfitting a scenario where
machine learning models
can either learn
the relationship between the data points
nor predict
or classify a new data point
and you can see here we have our
efficiency of our car and our line drawn
and it's just going to be way off for
both the training and the predicting
data
as the model doesn't fully learn the
patterns it accepts every new data point
during the prediction
so instead of looking for a general
pattern
we just kind of accept everything
data used for training is not cleaned
and contains noise garbage and values
again under fitting and overfitting same
issue
you got to clean your data
the model has a high
bias we've seen this in all kinds of
things
from
[Music]
the mod the most common is the driving
cars to facial identification or
whatever it is the model itself when
they build it might have a bias towards
one thing and this would be an
underfitted model would have that bias
because it's averaged it out so if you
have
five people from india and 10 people
from
africa and 20 people from the u.s you
created a bias
because it's looking at the 20 people
and you only have a small amount of data
to work with
size of training data used is not enough
that goes with the size i was just
talking about
so we have a model with a high bias we
have size of training data used it's not
enough
the model is too simple
again this is one straight line through
all the data when it needs as a slight
shift to it for other reasons
so what is a good fit
uh a linear curve that best fits the
data is neither overfitting or
underfitting models but is just right
and of course we have the nice examples
here where we have overfitting
lines going up and down every point is
trying to be include gluted underfitting
the line really is off from where the
data is and then a good fit is got to
get rid of that minimize that
error coming through regularization is
taking the guesswork out you're looking
at this graph and you're going oh which
one is that really over fit or is that
under fit that's pretty hard to tell
so we talk about regularization
regularization techniques are used to
calibrate the linear regression models
and to minimize the adjusted loss
function and prevent overfitting or
underfitting
so what that means uh in this case we're
going to go ahead and take a look at a
couple different things
we're going to look at regularization
which we'll start with a linear model
we'll look at the ridge regularization
and the lasso regularization
and these models are just like just like
we did the
mlp the multi-layered positron in the sk
learn module you could bring in the
ridge module and you can bring in the
lasso module
so when we talk about um
ridge regression it modifies the
overfitted or underfitted models by
adding the penalty equivalent to the sum
of the squares of the magnitude of the
coefficients
and so we have a cost function equals
loss equals
lambda times the sum of w
squared or the absolute value of w
depending on how you're doing it now
remember we talked about error whether
we either square it or we absolute value
it
because that removes a plus or minus
sign on there and there's reasons to do
it either way but it is more common to
square the value
and then we have our
in this case the lambda is going to be
the penalty for the errors we've thrown
in a greek character for you just to
confuse everybody
and w is the slope of the curve of the
line
so uh we're going to look at this and
we're going to draw a line this is going
to be like a linear regression model so
if you had in sklearn you could import
just a standard linear regression model
it would plot this line across whatever
data we're working on
and we look at this of course we're just
extrapolating this i know they use some
specific data but you don't want to get
into the actual domain
and so for a linear regression line
let's consider two points that are on
the line
and we'll go ahead and have a loss
equals zero uh considering the two
points on the line we'll go and do
lambda equals one we'll set our w is
going to be 1.4
then the cost function equals 0 plus 1
times 1.4 squared which equals 1.96
so
really don't get caught up too much in
the math on this other than
understanding
that this is something that's very easy
for a computer to calculate and if you
ever see the loss plus the length plus
the lambda times w the sum of w squared
and then let's say we have a ridge
regression line and it does this we go
ahead and plot it and we do the
calculations on the data
and for the ridge regression let's
assume a loss equals 0.3 squared plus
0.2 squared equals 0.13 so when they put
all the calculations through
of the two points we end up with the
0.0.62
so we've now had a linear regression
model we now had a ridge regression
model
and the ridge regression model plots a
little differently than the standard
linear regression model
and comparing the two models with all
the data points we can see that the
ridge regression line fits the model
more accurately than the linear
regression line
and i find this true on a lot of data i
work with i'll end up using either the
ridge regression model or the lasso mars
regression model for fitting especially
dealing with a lot of like stock markets
daily um
setup they come out slightly better you
get a slightly better
fit
and so we have our lasso we just talked
about lasso coming in here
and the cost function equals
instead of doing a squared we're just
going to do the absolute value and so if
you remember this is where ridge
regression changes where's my ridge
regression model
we're squaring the value here
and if you look at this we're not
squaring the value we're just finding
the absolute value on here and so the
loss of this of the squared individuals
and here is our
lambda symbol again penalty for errors
and w equals the slope of the curve
and comparing the two models with all
the data points we can see that the
lasso regression line fits the model
more accurately than the linear
regression line
and this is like i said i use these two
models a lot uh the ridge and this is
important this is
this is kind of the meat of the matter
how do you know which one to use some of
it is you just do it a bunch of times
and then you figure it out
uh ridge regularization is useful when
we have many variables with relatively
smaller data samples
the model does not encourage convergence
towards zero but is likely to make them
closer to zero and prevent
overfitting the lasso regularization
model is preferred when we are fitting a
linear model with fewer variables
so in the la in the iris thing we had
four or five variables as you measure
the different leaf pieces
you might be doing the measurements on
the cancer project which has 36
different variables
so as we get down to the iris with four
variables
lasso lar will probably work pretty good
where you might use the ridge
regularization with more model with if
you have something significantly larger
and it encourages the coefficients of
the variables to go towards zero because
of the shape of the constraint which is
an absolute value
and with any of this we want to go ahead
and
do a demo and lasso and ridge regression
so let's take a look and see what that
looks like in our code and bring up our
jupiter notebook
we'll start with our imports pandas is
pd import numpy is np import matplot
library as plt
um sk learn we're going to import our
data sets it's kind of more generic
we usually just import one data set
instead of all of them but you know
quick and dirty when you're putting some
of these together
we have our sklearn model selection
we're going to import our train test
split for splitting our data up
and then we'll bring in our linear
regression model
and we'll go ahead and run these just to
load them up and then load our data set
we're just talking about that
you could just
have imported the load boston and boston
data set in there instead of loading all
the data sets
and then once we've loaded our data set
we want to go ahead and take a look at
that data and see what we got here
let me just go and pop that down there
and go and run it
and so we've gone ahead and taken our
boston
data we're going to look we put it into
our pandas data frame
the boston data set
and then the boston columns we want to
see what's going on with them
we have our target
we have the house price
uh etc and so our x equals boston um
ilocation
now remember in pandas the new updates
to pandas they want eye location if
you're going to pull data we used to be
able to leave this off
but it does something different it
creates a slice versus a direct
setup so make sure using that eye
location and the i the output so this is
all just bringing our data together
and we can see here if we do we print
the boston
panda's head
we can see here all of our different
aspects we're looking for
and if you're following the x and the y
the x is
everything
except for the last column
where y is uh all the it's that's what
this means all the rows except for the
last column and then y is all the rows
but just the last column so y is our
house price
and the x is the crimsian industry chas
knox and all these other different
statistics they've collected for house
sales in boston
there we go oops control
so we'll go ahead and split our data
x train and our x
test y train y test equals the train
test split which we imported
and we have our boston you could have
easily used the x and y on here as
opposed to boston
eye location
and we'll create our test size we're
going to take 25 percent of the data and
put it in as a test
and then we'll go ahead and run this
i need an extra drink there
so we have our training test and then of
course the print the train data shape
i love doing this kind of thing whenever
i'm working with this data print out the
shape
make sure everything looks correct uh so
that we have 127 by 13 and 127 by one
379 by 13 they should match and if
they're if the the data sets are not
quite matching
then you know something's wrong and
you're going to get all those errors i
don't know how many times i've gone
through here and
it's dropped a row on one of them and
not on the other or something weird just
happened when i'm cleaning the data
this is pretty straightforward and
simple because the data comes in a nice
pre-package is all clean for you
so let's go ahead and apply apply the
multiple linear regression model
and we'll call this lreg lrag linear
regression and we're going to go ahead
and fit that linear regression model to
x train and y train
then we'll generate the prediction on
the test set
so here's our l reg y predict
with our x test going into the
prediction
and let's calculate that mean square
error mse i told you you'll see mse used
a lot
people use it in variables and things
like that it's pretty common and we get
our mean squared error equals
this is just the basic formula we've
already been talking about what's the
difference squared
and then we look for the average of that
we'll go ahead and just run this
and you can see when we get through the
end of this we have our mean square
error on test
we have our total and then we have each
column coming down
and at this point unless you really know
the data you're working with it's not
going to mean a whole lot so if it's in
your domain you might be know what
you're looking at when you see these
kinds of numbers coming up
uh but if it's not it's just a bunch of
numbers and that's okay
at least that's okay for this demo uh
and then we're going to go ahead and
plot these so we can see what's going on
and this is always kind of fun it's
always nice to have a nice visual of
what you're looking at and you can see
here um
when we plot the coefficient scores on
here
and we
the guys in the back did a great job
putting some pretty colors together
making it look nice and setting up the
columns
you can see here
your nox has like just a huge
coefficient
when i look at a table like this i look
for what has very little
different coefficients they're not using
a huge change and what has huge changes
and that flags you for all kinds of
things as you're working with the data
but it depends so much on the domain
you're working with
these are great things though as just a
quick look to see what's going on with
your data and what you're looking for
and of course once we look at this now
our motive is to reduce the coefficient
score so now we want to take these and
and
bring them down as much as we can and
for that we're going to work with the
ridge regression on here
so let's start by going and we're going
to import our ridge model
the red regression from the sk learn
library or the scikit
and we're going to go ahead and train
the model so here's our ridge
r equals alpha equals 1. and i mentioned
that earlier
when i work with the ridge model
you'll see alpha equals 1. if you set
alpha equal to 0 that's a standard
linear regression model so you have
alpha equals one two three four and you
usually use one two or three four and a
standard integer on there
and we'll go ahead and fit the ridge
model on there with our x train and our
y train data
generate a prediction for that
for our x test
and we'll calculate the mean square
error
uh just like we did before this should
all look familiar
and we'll go ahead and print that out
and we'll look at the ridge coefficients
for our data and see what that looks
like
now
if i jump up and down between these two
you'll get a headache
[Laughter]
you'll still see the knox value let's
just look at the knox because that was
the biggest value it's a minus nine here
and if we go back up here the nox value
is a minus 18. so right off the bat i'm
seeing a huge change
in the biggest coefficient there
uh so if we're going to do that nice
setup we want to go ahead and just print
it and see what that looks like
there we go and we've
set up our plot subplots and again the
team put together some nice colors so it
makes it look good
we're doing an x bar based on the
columns
and our l regress coefficients color
equals color x spine bottom and so forth
so just put together a nice little graph
and you're starting to see
one this when you compare this if you
put on the same graph as this one up
here this is up here minus 18
this is at minus nine
and so this graph is half the size of
the graph above
uh the same thing with these values here
they might look the same but they're
actually all almost half the value on
here
and then finally you can do the same
thing for the lasso regression
this would all look very similar as far
as what we worked on before
and i'm just going to print that on here
and run it
and again let's go up to uh knox look
where nox is it's all the way down to
zero
and if we look at our next biggest
coefficient is minus 0.8 and really
here's our 22.73
let me go up here
16.7
and we go up here and we look at the
same number
uh 16.69
and so we look at this uh if i was
running this and doing a working on a
project with this i would look at these
numbers i start with the 16.69
come down here and compare it to
16.78 6 9 is better than 7 8.
so from the very beginning we might
start looking at this first model for
overall
predicting
but there's other factors involved uh we
might know that uh the knocked value is
central and the other ones aren't quite
as good and so we might start looking at
just certain
setups like what is our what is this
particular coefficient because it might
have a certain meaning to us and so
forth and so you can look at all those
different
items in there again but the bottom
dollar is our first model did better
than our other two models
our mean square error on the test set
continues to
come down on this
today we're going to look at feature
selection in machine learning
what's in it for you the need for
feature selection
what is feature selection
feature selection methods
feature selection statistics
so the need for feature selection to
train a model we collect huge quantities
of data to help the machine learn better
consider a table which contains
information on old cars
the model decides which cars must be
crushed for spare parts and when we talk
about huge quantities of data there they
save everything from people's favorite
cat pictures to
and you can imagine there's so much data
out there even in a company they'll save
all these little pieces of information
about people and companies and
corporations
you need some way to sort through
because if you try to run your models on
all of it
you'll end up with these very clunky
models and they might have issues which
we'll talk about later but in this case
we're talking about cars and crushing
but not all this data will be useful to
us some classes or part of the data may
not contribute much to our model and can
be dropped and you can see right here we
have who was the owner of the car
in our data a car will not be crushed
based on its previous owner
so that's kind of a clear cut you can
see that why would i care who owned the
car before once it's in the junkyard and
we're crushing the cars we're not gonna
really care about that
so here we have dropped the owner column
as it does not contribute to the model
having too much unnecessary data can
cause the model to be slow the model may
also learn from this irrelevant data and
be inaccurate
so feature selection is a process of
reducing the input variable to your
model by using only relevant data and
getting rid of the noise in the data
consider the database given below a
library wants to donate some old books
to make place in their shells for new
books we want to train a model to
automate this task
in this case the color of the book does
not matter and keeping it can cause a
model to learn to donate books based on
color we can remove this as a feature
using feature selection we can optimize
our model in several ways
and so the number one is to prevent
learning from noise and overfitting
that's actually the huge one because we
we don't want it to give us the wrong
prediction and that means also improved
accuracy uh so instead of giving us a
wrong prediction we also want it to be
as close to the right answer as we can
get and we want to reduce the training
time it's an exponential growth in some
of these models so the each feature you
add in increases that much
more training time we talk about feature
selection methods we put together a nice
little flow chart that shows the various
methods used for feature selection
and you have your basic feature
selection and then there is supervised
and unsupervised
under supervised there's intrinsic
wrapper method filter method
so we talk about unsupervised feature
selection refers to the method which
does not need the output label class for
feature selection and that was you can
see here under super unsupervised we
don't have i mean that's really a
growing market right now
unsupervised learning and so feature
selection is the same thing
supervised feature selection refers to
the method which uses the output label
class for the feature selection and if
you remember we looked at three
different
we have intrinsic wrapper and filter
method so we're going to start with the
filter method on this now remember we
know what the output is so we're going
to be looking at that output to see how
well it's doing versus the features in
this method features are dropped based
on their relation to the output or how
they are correlating to the output
you can see here we have a set of
features selecting best feature learning
algorithm and then performance
and so we want to find out which feature
correlates to the performance on the
output consider the example of book
classifier here we drop the color column
based on simple deduction
and that kind of sums it up in the in a
nutshell as we want to filter out things
that clearly do not go with what we're
looking for we look at the wrapper
method
in the wrapper method we split our data
into subsets
and train a model using this based on
the output of the model we add and
subtract features and train the model
again
and you can see here in the wrapper
method we have a set of features we
generate a subset we run it through the
algorithm and we see how each one of
those subset of features performs
consider the book data set by using the
wrapper method we would use a subset of
different features to train the machine
and adjust the subset according to the
output and so you can see here let's say
we take name and number of times red and
we run just those and we look at the
output and if we looked at him with all
four inputs and look at the output we'd
see quite a different variation in there
and we might say you know what condition
of the book and color really doesn't
affect what we're looking for and you
can see here we've run it on condition
of the book and color
depending on the output of the model we
will choose our final set of features
these features will give us the best
result for our model
and it might come up that the name
number of times red is probably pretty
important
the intrinsic method
this method combines the qualities of
both filter and wrapper method to create
the best subset
the model will train and check the
accuracy of different subsets and select
the best among them we kind of looked at
a little overview of some of the stuff
some of the common feature selection
algorithms based on which method they
belong to are given below
and you'll see it's primarily under
supervised there's not like i said a lot
of unsupervised methods and the ones
that are usually used these methods
and finds a way to create a supervised
connection between the data
and we talk about supervised methods we
have our filter method which we talked
about and it uses like the pearson's
coefficient
t squared anova coefficient those are
all under the filter method
and in the wrapper method recursive
feature elimination so remember we're
choosing a subset and we want to go
through there and look at each one so
you're just doing a lot of loops or
recursive calculations to see which one
works best and which ones don't have an
impact on the output
and there's a lot of genetic algorithms
to go with this too on the wrapper
method and how they evaluate it and with
the intrinsic method
there's the two main ones we're looking
at is the lasso regularization
the lasso algorithms are basically your
standard
regression model so it's finding out how
these
different methods fit together and which
ones have the best um add together to
have the least amount of error
the other one used in the intrinsic
method is the decision tree it says hey
if this one is this one produces this
result this one produces this result yes
no which way do we go based on the input
and the output variables we can choose
our feature selection model so you have
your numeric input coming in you have a
numeric output if you use the pearson's
correlation coefficient or spearman's
rank coefficient
you can then
select what features you're going to
feed into that specific model and you
maybe have a numerical input and a
categorical input so we're going to be
looking more at anova correlation
coefficient or kindle's rank coefficient
and if you have a core categorical input
and a numerical output we might be
looking at anova correlation coefficient
in kindle's rank coefficient
so based on the input and the output
variables we can choose our feature
selection model and you can see we have
categorical to categorical we might be
looking at the
chi-squared test
contingency tables and mutual
information let's go and take a look and
see uh in the python code what we're
talking about here
and i'm going to go ahead and use for my
ide the jupiter notebook in the and i
always launch it out of anaconda on here
and we'll go ahead and go up here and
create a new python 3 module
and we'll call it
feature
select
and since we're in python we're going to
be working mainly with your numpy your
pandas your matplot library so we have
our number array our data frame setup
which goes with the number array the
numpy the pandas data frame and then we
want to go ahead and graph everything so
we're going to import these three
modules
and then we put together some data
we're going to read this in it's kobe
bryant i guess he's a basketball player
our guys in the back we have a number of
them guys
both we have a lot of men and women so
it's probably a misnomer our team in the
back
they have a some of them have a liking
for basketball and they know who kobe
bryant is and they want to learn a
little bit more about kobe bryant what's
going in for what whatever is going on
with his game
in basketball so we're going to take a
look at him
uh and once we import the data we can
see what columns are available
original features count so we can see
how many features there are
the length of it and we'll actually have
a list of them and then print just
the data head the top five rows
and so when we do this
we can see from the csv file
we have 25 original features
our original features are your action
type combine shot type game event id and
so forth there's a lot of features in
here that they're recorded on all of his
shots this is we talk about like a
massive amount of data
i mean
people are sitting there and they record
all this stuff and they import this
stuff for different reasons
but depending on what we want to look at
do we really want all those features
maybe the question we're going to ask is
what's the chance if you're making any
one specific shot
in right from the beginning we can look
at the some of these things and say team
name
team name probably
maybe it does matter because the other
team might be really good at defense uh
game date maybe we don't really want to
look at the game date team id definitely
not of importance in any of this
uh so we look at this we have 25
features and some of these features just
really don't matter to us
we also have location x location y
latitude and longitude i'm guessing
that's the same data we've actually
imported the
the very similar data maybe they're
slightly zoned differently
but as far as our program we don't want
to repeat data some of the models when
you repeat data into them and this is
true for most models create a huge bias
they weigh that data over other data
so just at a glance these are the things
we're looking at we want to find out
well how do we get this these features
down and get rid of this bias and all
these
extraneous features that we don't really
want to
spend time running our models on and
programming on
and as i pointed out there's a location
x a location y latitude and longitude
let's take a look at that and see what
we're looking at here we'll go ahead and
create a plot of these
and we'll just plot we'll do a scatter
plot of location x and location y
and then we'll do a
scatter plot of
data lawn data lat which is probably
longitude and latitude and the scatter
plot let's go ahead and actually put a
little title here location and scatter
on there
we'll just go ahead and plot these and
when you look at this
coming in
these two graphs are pretty identical
except they're flipped
and so when we look at the location from
which they're shooting from
they're probably the same
and at this point we can say okay we can
get rid of one of these sets of datas we
don't need both x and y and latitude and
longitude because it's the same data
coming in and as we look at this
particular data the latitude longitude
we might also ask does it really make a
difference which side of the chord
you're on whether you're on the left
side or the right side
and so we might go ahead and explore
instead of looking at this as
x y we might look at it as a distance
and an angle we can easily compute that
and you can see we can create our data
distance equals location x
plus the location y squared standard
euclidean geometry or
triangular geometry
hypotenuse squared equals the each side
squared
and then once we've done that
we can also compute the angle
so the data angle is based on the arc
tangent
uh and so forth on here so this is all
this is we're just going to compute the
angle here
and then set that up
pi over 2 to get our angle
and we'll go ahead and run that
and you'll see some errors run come up
and that's because when we took slices
over here we took a slice of a slice
there's ways to fix that but it's really
not important for this example
so if you do see that you want to start
looking up here for
instead of data location x of
not location x zero
this would be like um i believe the term
is il dot i location uh if this was yeah
this is in pandas
uh so there's different things in there
but for this it doesn't really matter
these are just warnings that's all they
are and then let's combine our remaining
minutes and seconds column into one
there's another one so if you remember
up here we're trying to get rid of these
columns
do we really need let me see if i can
find it on here there we go there's our
minutes remaining
and then they had
what was it it was uh minutes remaining
and seconds column so there's also a
seconds column on here
see i can find that one
this is where it really gets kind of
crazy because here's our seconds
remaining so you can see that here's our
minutes remaining this gets crazy when
you're looking at hundreds of these
features and you can see that if if i'm
going to
say
write a model that's going to predict a
lot of this and i want it to run in this
case it's a basketball and how good his
shots are as the data comes in let's say
i want to have it run on your phone
if i'm running it across hundreds of
features
it's going to just hang up on your phone
where if i can get it down to just a
handful
we'll actually be able to come in here
and run it on a smaller device and not
use up as much memory
or processing power
so we'll go ahead and take data
remaining time here
and data minutes remaining times 60 plus
data seconds remaining so we're just
going to combine those
and we'll go ahead and reprint our data
so we can see what we got
coming across we have our action type
combined and this is we do this a lot uh
we want to take a look at oops i got so
so zoomed in let me see if i can zoom
out just a little bit
there we go
boom
all right so we come up here you can see
that we now have our distance our angle
remaining time which is now just a
number
uh that computes both the minutes and
seconds together
and we still have we've
we've been adding columns i thought you
said we're supposed to subtract columns
right
we're going to delete the obsolete
columns when we get to them so we're
just filtering out and this is a filter
method we're just filtering through the
things
that we really
don't need
and next let's go ahead and explore
team id and team name
let me just go ahead and run that and if
you look at this uh we have los angeles
lakers and then they have the team id
here and they're unique
there's not that's not really anything
that's going to come up um because
that's
this particular
athletes
works for that team so it's the same on
every line so there's another thing we
can filter out on there team id and
tname is just useless
the whole column contains only one value
each and
it's pretty much useless
let's go ahead and take a look at match
up an opponent that's an interesting one
and we see here that we have
the lal versus por and the opponent is
por and ind
again here's a lot of duplicate
information
so
this basically contains the same
information on here
again we're filtering all this stuff out
and this is because we're only looking
at one athlete and this might change if
you're looking at multiple athletes that
kind of thing now these are easy to see
we might have something that looks more
like this
we might have something where we're
looking at the distance which we
computed and the shot distance are they
the same thing
and what we can do is we can plot that
and plot them against each other on here
and we see it just draws a nice straight
line
uh and so again we're looking at the
same information
so again we're repeating stuff and we
really don't want to be running our
model on
uh repeat information on here so again
it contains the same information so now
let's look at the shot zone area
shot zone basic shot zone range
so now we're looking at the zones and
what does that mean and we'll go ahead
and and do this also in a scatter plot
in this case we're going to just create
three of these side by side so we're
going to create
our plot figure side 20 by 10
and then we're going to define our
scatter plot by category feature and
we're going to do each one
set up on here give it a slightly
different color and so our shot zone
area is going to be plot uh subplot 131
scatter one three one is how that's red
by the way
meaning that
it's number one
um we have three across
and this is the first one down so one
one one our scatter plot by category is
going to be the shot zone area we're
going to plot that
and then we're going to do the
shot zone basic and then the shot zone
range and you just push them through our
definition so each of those areas go
through and you'll see one three one one
three two one three three
again it's a one by three
setup and then it's just a place on each
one and so we look at this we can see
that
these shots
they map out the same so it's very again
redundant information
that should be intuitive
when we're looking at this
in this color
graphs it kind of helps you start
looking at something you it's very
intuitive like this is you start to
realize that some of the stuff
you'll be looking for in data you might
not understand
and you'll see these circular patterns
where they match or they mostly match
and you start to realize
when you're looking at these that
they're repetitive data and then you
want to explore them more closely
depending on what domain you're working
in so we look at these we look at them
and they look just like the regions of
the court but we already have stored
this information in angle and distance
columns so we've seen this image before
we go back up here and here's our the
similar image
and repeating that image is down here
and so let's go ahead and drop some of
this in this stuff so now let's drop all
the useless columns
and we can drop the shot id team id team
name
shot zone area shot zone range shot zone
basic
the match up
the longitude and latitude for putting
that into distance
seconds remaining minutes remaining
because we combine that into one column
shot distance because we have just
distance on there location x location y
the game event id
game id all this stuff is just being
dropped on here and we'll just go ahead
and loop through our drops
and this is a nice way of doing this
because as you're playing with this
this kind of data
putting your list into one setup helps
because then you're just writing it
through an iteration
and you can come back and change it you
might be playing with different models
and do this with models you might be
looking at all kinds of different things
that you can drop and add in as you test
these out and again we're working in the
filter method so this is a lot of human
interaction with the data and it takes a
lot of critical thinking to look at this
stuff and say what matches and what
doesn't and so we look at the remaining
features let me go ahead and just run
this
the original to the new count we had 25
features now we have 11 features you can
see that right there we just circle that
there's our 25 and there's uh old new
now we're down to 11. so we've cut it
down to less than half
and you can just see
the actual different information on here
and the remaining time
at this point we filtered it through and
then we'd move into the next process
which would be to run our model on this
and maybe we would drop
some of the features and see if it runs
better or worse and what happens
that's kind of would be the next step on
there versus the filter setup and that
would be one of the other setups
depending on which algorithm you use
so that wraps up our demo on uh filter
the feature selection and going through
and seeing how these different features
are being repeated in this particular in
a basketball
setup hi everyone today we have a really
interesting topic for you
in this video we'll be analyzing the
upcoming united states presidential
election using twitter sentiment
analysis in python
in the course of this session we will
understand in brief about the upcoming
election the candidates fighting the
2020 u.s election and throw light on the
result of the 2016 u.s election we look
at the election forecast by some of the
popular news agencies
as well as pole analysis websites such
as 538
before we begin
i want to make it clear that this video
is solely for learning purposes
we had simply learned do not lean
towards any party in the united states
or are buyers towards any candidate
the analysis is based on what people
have tweeted and we will understand the
mood and sentiment of the public
the main objective of this video is to
help you understand how to extract
tweets from twitter handles using python
libraries
store it in a csv file and perform
textual analysis
the results obtained are purely based on
the data that we have collected
let's begin
the battle for the 2020 us presidential
election has begun with the 59th united
states presidential election scheduled
to be held on the 3rd of november 2020
this will decide who will be in the
white house for the next four years
all 435 seats in the united states house
of representatives 35 of the 100 seats
in the united states senate and office
of the president of the united states
will be contested
both the republican party and the
democratic party have nominated their
respective president and vice
presidential candidates
the incumbent president donald trump is
the republican nominee
while the 47th vice president of the
united states joe biden is the
democratic party's nominee
the current vice president mike pence is
the republican party's vice presidential
nominee and is running for a second term
in office
senator kamala harris of california was
chosen by joe biden as his running mate
on 11th of august 2020.
now
let's see the results of the last u.s
presidential election in 2016. the
republican ticket of businessman donald
trump and indiana governor mike pence
had defeated the democratic ticket of
former secretary of state hillary
clinton and u.s senator from virginia
tim kaine
donald trump received a total of 304
electoral votes while hillary clinton
got 227 electoral votes
a significant number of central states
in the united states were swept by the
republican party
it was surprising to see that donald
trump getting nearly 46.4 percent
popular vote as compared to hillary
clinton who got 48.5 votes
donald trump's victory came after
crucial wins in the battleground streets
of florida ohio iowa north carolina and
pennsylvania
will donald trump be re-elected to the
white house or are we going to see a new
president and vice president of the
united states is the big question
let's see what our pollsters have to say
and what has been their forecast for the
upcoming election
according to 538
donald trump has not gained ground since
the final debate on 22nd of october
at this moment joe biden is favored to
win the election and he leads in both
national and state pools
the economist is analyzing polling
economic and demographic data to predict
the u.s elections
their model thinks joe biden is very
likely to beat donald trump in the
electoral college as per their forecast
joe biden has 96 percent chance of
winning the electoral college and this
99 percent chance of biden winning the
most votes
the democrats have 75 chance of
controlling the senate while the
republicans have around 25 percent
the democrats are highly likely to keep
their majority in the house of
representatives now according to the
guardian
joe biden is leading donald trump in the
national polls for the presidential
election
but to keep in mind this does not
guarantee the democratic candidate joe
biden's victory
hillary clinton also had a clear lead
over donald trump in the polls for
almost the entire 2016 campaign she
ended up losing the electoral college
now the bbc forecast tells that biden is
leading national presidential polls with
51 percent
he has hovered around 50 in recent
months and has had a 10 point lead on
occasions so clearly joe biden is set to
be the next u.s president let's wait and
watch what happens on the 3rd of
november
the voters of america will decide on 3rd
of november whether donald trump remains
in the white house for another 4 years
let's perform a twitter sentiment
analysis to understand the sentiments of
people tweeting about donald trump and
joe biden by tagging them in their
tweets
we have our code implemented already
i'll run through each line of code and
explain our analysis in detail the
objective is to check the polarity of
each tweet to figure out if it's
positive negative or neutral we'll
compare the tweets of donald trump and
joe biden to see who people are favoring
the most
finally we learn to create a word cloud
i have already extracted the tweets and
stored them in two separate csv files
it takes some time to fetch 10 000
tweets hence it won't be possible for me
to show it to you live
if you want to know how we extracted the
tweets for donald trump and joe biden
then please put your email ids in the
comments section of the video we'll
share the code file and the source file
with you
now you would need to install the tweepy
library fetch the twitter keys and
access tokens and then authenticate the
twitter api
i've extracted 5000 tweets each for
donald trump and joe biden converted
into a data frame and stored it in a csv
file
so let me open and show you both the
files
so here is my data set for donald trump
on the top you can see trump underscore
data 5000 which means there are 5000
tweets here
the first column
has the number of tweets it starts from
zero and goes all the way to 4999
the next column
is the text column which has the content
of the tweet
you can see
they have tagged at the rate real donald
trump
there are links as well there are
special characters like emoticons
and the third column is the user
which means
it's the user name
who had put that tweet
similarly
i have another data for biden
you can see these are
for joe biden
and here you can see the content they
have tagged kamala harris also
similarly we have the username
now let me take you straight to my
jupyter notebook where i have
implemented the code
okay so first and foremost let's import
all the required libraries so we have
the numpy library for numerical
computation then we have the pandas
library for data manipulation next we
are importing two libraries matplotlib
and c bond for data visualization
then we have
text blob and word cloud
to get the sentiment and to build the
word cloud
and finally we are importing the plotly
library for creating graphs
let me run this cell
in the current cell we'll import the
data sets using read underscore csv
function present in the pandas library
so i have passed in my location where
the data file is so i placed it on my
desktop
and
the index underscore col parameter or
column parameter refers to the columns
to be used as the row labels of the data
frame here 0 indicates that the first
column will be used as row labels
let me run it
ok now we have imported both the data
files
let me go ahead and
print the shape of one of the data
frames
so i'll write print
let's say we'll check the shape of
biden data frame so i'll write print
by then dot shape
i left shift enter
you can see there are 5000 rows and
there are two columns one is the text
column and the next column is the user
column
now let me
go ahead and print the head of the data
sets
so the head function will return the
first five rows
i'll write
trump
dot head
you can see these are the first
five rows from the trump
data frame and similarly if you want to
check for biden i can write biden dot
head
you can see it here
now you can also use the info method
so let me
show you that you can write drum dot
info
and this is the result so it tells there
are 5000 entries from 0 to
4999 there are two columns
and these are the number of
rows
and similarly you have the data types
okay
moving ahead in the next cell i am
displaying the 200th tweet present in
the trump data frame so i have my data
frame name mentioned then i have my text
column
and inside one more square bracket i
have put 200 which means i want to see
what's there in the
200th row
if i hit enter
so you can see this was the tweet fake
fake president
next
let me show you
the tweet number 1000 for biden so i'll
write biden
and inside square brackets i'll give the
text column
and
the number is
if i hit shift enter
so this is the tweet
now
the text blob function
is used in natural language processing
the sentiment property returns a named
tuple in the form of sentiment
in brackets polarity and subjectivity
let's check the sentiment of the 200th
tweet made for donald trump
if i hit shift enter
you can see this was the polarity
now minus 0.39
means
the polarity was negative and you can
see the subjectivity is around
0.933
similarly
let's check for biden's tweet number
so i'll write
text
blob which is my function name
and inside brackets i'll give biden
then
pass in my column name that is text and
i'll give the row number which is 1000
and then i'll give the
parameter
or the attribute sentiment
if i hit shift enter you can see the
polarity and the subjectivity
now moving ahead
here
i have defined a function that will add
another column called polarity to our
two data frames trump and biden
let me run this
okay
in the next cell
i have used the apply function that will
return the polarity based on the tweets
you can see we have the apply function
this might take some time to run it okay
we are done now
let me now display the top five rows of
the data frame
so
what i'll do is i'll click on this cell
go to insert and i'll hit
insert cell below
let's do one more
okay now here
i'll display the head of the data frame
once again so that you can see the
polarity column added
you can see it here
so for donald trump
we have the polarity you can see the
tweet and the polarity now 0.0 which
means these are neutral
minus is negative and anything that's in
positive value
indicates it's a
positive tweet or it has positive
polarity
similarly let's see for biden
i'll write
biden.head okay so here you can see the
polarity for biden
now this point five means it's a
positive tweet
okay
now
i want to create another column called
expression where we will classify the
tweets as positive negative or neutral
based on the polarity value
so i have used the np dot where function
and the condition we have here is
if polarity is greater than 0 it's a
positive tweet else if it is less than 0
it's a negative to it and if the
polarity is equal to 0 it means it's a
neutral tweet
let me run this
okay
so here you can see we have the column
called expression
and it has classified the polarity based
on negative
neutral as well as positive
similarly let's do the same for biden
data frame as well
okay
before moving ahead if you want to get
access to the source code and the data
sets we have used in this demo then
please put your email address in the
chat section
we'll send it to you via mail
also please subscribe to simply launch
channel and hit the bell icon to never
miss an update from simply loan
in the next cell of code
we have another function that will
basically help us creating a bar plot
based on the expression column from both
the data frames
so this is my user defined function name
and it has two parameters reviews and
title
you can see we have
grouped the expression column and found
out the count using the count function
then we have created or converted it
into a list
similarly
below you can see here we have defined
the
color for the bars using rgb values
now let me run it
okay
so we have successfully created our user
defined function
now let me go ahead and call the
function
and pass in my two parameters reviews
and title so here we have the function
name
and
under reviews we have the data frame
name trump and the title we have given
is analysis for trump
let me run this
okay
so you can see we have a horizontal
bar plot on the top you can see the
title of the plot which is analysis for
trump
and as per the tweets it has classified
as positive neutral or negative
if i hover over you can see there were
831 neutral tweets
1211 positive tweets and similarly there
were
958 negative tweets for donald trump
now
let me call that function once again so
i'll write exp underscore graph
which is my function name
then i'll pass in my
parameters this time i'll take biden and
the title i'll put is
analysis
for
biden
if i run it
okay
you can see the plot for biden now
if i hover over
there were
1290 positive tweets for biden
and
747 negative tweets
okay
let's
scroll down
now let me check the number of rows that
have polarity equal to 0
the number of rows that have polarity
less than 0 and greater than 0 for both
the data frames using the
dot shape attribute
so first we have
for trump now equal to equal to 0 means
we are checking the total number of
neutral tweets
you can see the result
now let's check for biden we have the
result below
let me run it
okay
now
we'll drop those columns that have a
polarity equal to zero from both the
data frames and display the shape you
can see
we have the condition mentioned
and we have also used the drop function
so all the neutral tweets will be
deleted
and i am printing the shape of the data
frame
there you go
so out of the 5000 tweet it has deleted
all the neutral tweets or dropped all
the neutral treats and this is the final
result
in the current cell
we have defined another function called
balanced underscore data
now this will help us get an equal
number of rows and columns and delete a
specified number of rows
let me run it all right
now i'll call that function to delete
169 rows from the trump's data frame and
37 rows from biden's data frame this
will help us subset the data frames
you can see
we have now
2000 tweets from each of the data frames
up next we will create some
visualizations to analyze the textual
data
so first i'm using the c bond library
and creating
a distribution plot for donald trump
if i hit shift enter
you can see this is the distribution
plot thus
there are bars at the back and there's a
trend line
okay
similarly let me now create a box plot
so this is
a box plot here you can see there are
some outliers
now let me add
a few cells below so that i can show
that plot for biden
so i'll write sns
dot
i'll use the function
dist plot
and under this plot i'll give
biden underscore
subset
and
i'll pass in my column that is polarity
let me run it
so this is the distribution plot for joe
biden
and now
let me also create the box plot so i'll
use the
c bond library and the box plot function
i'll pass in my data frame which is
biden underscore subset
and i'll give my column name that is
polarity
i'll run it
so here you can see the box plot for joe
biden
let me tell you how you can create a
cross table using the group by function
so before coming to this cell of code
let me insert cell above
okay
now using group by function you can
create a cross table
so i'll use
the trump underscore subset data frame
and
then i'll give my group by function
and inside group by function i'll give
my expression column
and i'll
count the number of expressions
if i run this
you can see this is a cross table
similarly you can do it for
joe biden as well
i'll just replace the
names i'll write biden
and the rest is the same
you can see
this is the cross table for biden
underscore subset
now moving ahead
let's find the polarity percentage for
negative and positive tweets to do this
i have defined a function called
pole underscore percent
and we have two parameters declared
subset and total
let me run this
ok
now here
i am calling the above defined function
and printing the polarity percentage for
biden and trump
and i have mentioned my two parameters
subset
and the total number
so these are the values moving ahead
now let's create a bar graph that will
show the negative and positive polarity
percentage for donald trump and joe
biden
let me hit shift enter
you can see we have a
really good bar graph now if i hover the
mouse cursor you can see
donald trump had 27.825
percent of positive tweets
and
22.17 negative
similarly joe biden had
31.6 positive tweets
and
18.4 negative tweets
now we want to find the public sentiment
based on trump and biden tweets
let me run this two cells first
okay
now for donald trump the total positive
polarity is a combination of trump's
total positive percentage and biden's
negative percentage
similarly
for joe biden the total positive
polarity is a combination of biden's
total positive percentage and
trump's negative percentage
let me run this
you can see the result here
next
let's plot a horizontal bar graph to
visualize the public sentiment
we have our x and y labels defined
we also have set our bar colors with the
help of rgb values
and we have the title as well
now if i go up you can see this is the
public sentiment
so
26.88
is the percentage that is in favor of
joe biden and for donald trump you have
23.11
now coming down
now in the next cell of code
we have a user defined function that
will basically plot a table which has
the most positive tweets for donald
trump and joe biden
the condition we are checking is that
the polarity should be equal to one
so if it's close to one or equal to one
which means
the tweet has positive polarity
let me
run it
okay now let me go ahead and call the
function now
let me scroll over to the top
you can see
these are the top five positive tweets
for donald trump
and
here you can see the top five positive
tweets for joe biden
likewise
let's check the polarity for most
negative tweets here the condition will
be the polarity should be
equal to minus 1 which means it's highly
negative
let me run it
okay
now
let's go ahead and call the function
negative tweets so i'll write neg
underscore
tweets
and then inside bracket i'll give my
parameters
which is trump underscore subset
and then
i'll give my title as
negative
tweets
for
donald trump
okay
now
let's copy this
we'll also check for joe biden so i'll
just replace this with
biden
and let's say
negative to it for
joe biden
let's run it
okay
if i go on top here you can see
the top
negative tweets for donald trump and
similarly we have the
top five negative tweets for joe biden
all right
finally
let's see how to create a word cloud
now word cloud is a method to show which
words are most frequently occurring
among the given text
i have defined a function called word
cloud you can see here and it has two
parameters data and title
inside
the built-in function or the word cloud
function we have
mentioned the max font size
the maximum words
scale value there's also background
color which is white
okay
let's run it
now this will create
a word cloud
so let me go ahead and
call the word cloud function and pass in
the arguments
so i'll write
word cloud which is my user defined
function
and i'll give my parameters
trump underscore subset
comma i'll give my title as
word
cloud
for
donald trump
let's see donald trump tweet
replies
okay
similarly
let's
do it for
joe biden
write word cloud
biden underscore subset
and then i'll give the title as
word
cloud
for
joe biden
to it
replies
okay
let me run it
there you go
you can see we have a nice
word cloud
so on the top you can see the title
which says word cloud for donald trump
tweet replies
so here you can see
some of the words like real donald trump
then there's
precedent love
right
all these
similarly if i scroll down you can see
the word cloud for joe biden tweet
replies you can see there's the handle
joe biden
falls there are some
other words like due taxes belief even
will
it's fact
and you can see kamala had his name here
okay now that brings us to the end of
this demo on twitter sentiment analysis
using text data
you learned how to classify tweets and
find the polarity
we also looked at how to create
interesting visualizations
with this data and understood the mood
of the public
finally you saw how to create a word
cloud that had the most frequently
occurring words in the tweets today
we'll talk about interview questions for
machine learning now this video will
probably help you when you're attending
interviews for machine learning
positions and the attempt here is to
probably consolidate 30 most commonly
asked questions and to help you in
answering these questions we tried our
best to give you the best possible
answers but of course what is more
important here is rather than the
theoretical knowledge you need to kind
of add to the answers are supplementary
or answers with your own experience so
the responses that we put here are a bit
more generic in nature so that if there
are some concepts that you are not clear
this video will help you in kind of
getting those concepts cleared up as
well but what is more important is that
you need to supplement these responses
with your own practical experience okay
so with that let's get started so one of
the first questions that you may face is
what are the different types of machine
learning now what is the best way to
respond to this there are three types of
machine learning if you read any
material you will always be told there
are three types of machine learning but
what is important is you would probably
be better off emphasizing that there are
actually two main types of machine
learning which is supervised and
unsupervised and then there is a third
type which is reinforcement learn so
supervised learning is where
you have some historical data and then
you feed that data to your model to
learn now you need to be aware of a
keyword that they will be looking for
which is labeled data right so if you
just say past data or historical data
the impact may not be so much you need
to emphasize on labeled data so what is
label data basically let's say if you
are trying to do train your model for
classification you need to be aware of
for your existing data which class each
of the observations belong to right so
that is what is labeling so it is
nothing but a fancy name you must be
already aware but just make it a point
to throw in that keyword labeled so that
will have the right impact okay so that
is what is supervised learning when you
have existing labeled data which you
then use to train your model that is
known as supervised learning and
unsupervised learning is when you don't
have this labeled data so you have data
it is not labeled so the system has to
figure out a way to do some analysis on
this okay so that is unsupervised
learning and you can then add a few
things like what are the ways of
performing uh supervised learning and
unsupervised learning and what are some
of the techniques so supervised learning
we we perform or we do
regression and classification
and unsupervised learning we do
clustering and clustering can be of
different types similarly regression can
be of different types but you don't have
to probably elaborate so much if they
are asking uh for
just the different types you can just
mention these and just at a very high
level
if they want you to elaborate give
examples then of course i think there is
a different question for that we will
see that later then the third so we have
supervised then we have unsupervised and
then reinforcement you need to provide a
little bit of information around that as
well because it is sometimes a little
difficult to come up with a good
definition for reinforcement learning so
you may have to little bit elaborate on
how reinforcement learning works right
so reinforcement learning works in in
such a way that it basically has two
parts to it one is the agent and the
environment and the agent basically is
working inside of this environment and
it is given a target that it has to
achieve and
every time it is moving in the direction
of the target so the agent basically has
to take some action and every time it
takes an action which is moving uh the
agent towards the target right towards a
goal a target is nothing but a goal okay
then it is rewarded and every time it is
going in a direction where it is away
from the goal then it is punished so
that is the way you can little bit
explain and
this is used primarily or very very
impactful for teaching the system to
learn games and so on examples of this
are basically used in alphago you can
throw that as an example where alphago
used reinforcement learning to actually
learn to play the game of go and finally
it defeated the co-world champion right
this much of information that would be
good enough okay then there could be a
question on overfitting uh so the
question could be what is overfitting
and how can you avoid it so
what is overfitting so let's first try
to understand the concept because
sometimes overfitting may be a little
difficult to understand overfitting is a
situation where the model has kind of
memorized the data so this is an
equivalent of memorizing the data so we
can draw an analogy so that it becomes
easy to explain this now let's say
you're teaching a child about
recognizing some fruits or something
like that okay and you're teaching this
child about recognizing let's say three
fruits apples oranges and pineapples
okay so this is a small child and for
the first time you're teaching the child
to recognize fruits then so what will
happen so this is very much like that is
your training data set so what you will
do is you will take a basket of fruits
which consists of apples oranges and
pineapples okay and
you take this basket to this child and
there may be let's say hundreds of these
fruits so you take this basket to this
child and keep showing each of this root
and then first time obviously the child
will not know what it is so you show an
apple and you say hey this is apple then
you show maybe an orange and say this is
orange and so on and so forth and then
again you keep repeating that right so
till that basket is over this is
basically how training work in machine
learning also that's how training works
so till the basket is completed maybe
100 fruits you keep showing this child
then the process what has happened the
child has pretty much memorized these so
even before you finish that basket right
by the time you are halfway through the
child has learnt about recognizing the
apple orange and pineapple now what will
happen after halfway through initially
you remember it made mistakes in
recognizing but halfway through now it
has learned so every time you show a
fruit it will exactly 100 accurately it
will identify it will say the child will
say this is an apple this is an orange
and if you show a pineapple it will say
this is a pineapple right so that means
it has kind of memorized this data now
let's say you bring another basket of
fruits and it will have a mix of maybe
apples which were already there in the
previous set but it will also have in
addition to apple it will probably have
a banana or maybe another fruit like a
jackfruit right so this is an equivalent
of your test data set which the child
has not seen before some parts of it it
probably has seen like the apples it has
seen but this banana and jackfruit it
has not seen so then what will happen in
the first round which is an equivalent
of your training data set towards the
end it has 100 percent it was telling
you what the fruits are right apple was
accurately recognized orange was
accurately recognized and pineapples
were accurately recognized right so that
is like 100 accuracy but now when you
get another a fresh set which we're not
part of the original one what will
happen all the apples maybe it will be
able to recognize correctly but all the
others like the jackfruit or the banana
will not be recognized by the child
right so this is an analogy this is an
equivalent of overfitting so what has
happened during the training process it
is able to recognize or reach 100
accuracy maybe very high accuracy okay
and we call that as very low loss right
so that is the technical term so the
loss is pretty much zero and accuracy is
pretty much hundred percent whereas when
you use testing there will be a huge
error which means the loss will be
pretty high and therefore the accuracy
will be also low okay this is known as
overfitting this is basically a process
where training is done training
processes it goes very well almost
reaching 100 accuracy but while testing
it really drops down now how can you
avoid it so that is a extension of this
question there are multiple ways of
avoiding overfitting there are
techniques like what you call
regularization that is the most common
technique that is used for
avoiding overfitting and within
regularization there can be a few other
subtypes like dropout in case of neural
networks and a few other examples but i
think if you give example or if you give
regularization as the technique probably
that should be sufficient so so there
will be some questions where the
interviewer will try to test your
fundamentals and your knowledge and
depth of knowledge and so on and so
forth and then there will be some
questions which are more like trick
questions that will be more to stump you
okay then the next question is around
the methodology so when we are
performing machine learning training we
split the data into training and test
right so this question is around that so
the question is what is training set and
test set in machine learning model and
how is the split done so the question
can be like that so in machine learning
when we are trying to train the model so
we have a three-step process we train
the model and then we test the model and
then once we are satisfied with the test
only then we deploy the model so what
happens in the train and test is that
you remember the labeled data so let's
say you have 1000 records with labeling
information now one way of doing it is
you use all the thousand records for
training and then maybe right which
means that you have exposed all these
thousand records during the training
process and then you take a small set of
the same data and then you say okay i
will test it with this okay and then you
probably what will happen you may get
some good results all right but there is
a flaw there what is the flaw this is
very similar to human beings it is like
you are showing this model the entire
data as a part of training okay so
obviously it has become familiar with
the entire data so when you are taking a
part of that again and you are saying
that i want to test it obviously you
will get good results so that is not a
very accurate way of testing so that is
the reason what we do is we have the
label data of this thousand records or
whatever we set aside before starting
the training process we set aside a
portion of the data and we call that
test set and the remaining we call as
training set and we use only this for
training our model now the training
process remember is not just about
passing one round of this data set so
let's say now your training set has 800
records it is not just one time you pass
this 800 records what you normally do is
you actually as a part of the training
you may pass this data through the model
multiple times so this thousand records
may go through the model maybe 10 15 20
times till the training is perfect till
the accuracy is high till the errors are
minimized okay now so which is fine
which means that your that is what is
known as the model has seen your data
and gets familiar with your data and now
when you bring your test data what will
happen is this is like some new data
because that is where the real test is
now you've trained the model and now you
are testing the model with some data
which is kind of new that is like a
situation like like a realistic
situation because when the model is
deployed that is what will happen it
will receive some new data not the data
that it has already seen right so this
is a realistic test so you put some new
data so this data which you have set
aside is for the model it is new and if
it is able to accurately predict the
values that means your training has
worked okay the model got trained
properly but let's say while you're
testing this with this test data you're
getting lot of errors that means you
need to probably either change your
model or retrain with more data and
things like that now coming back to the
question of how do you split this what
should be the ratio there is no fixed
number again this is like individual
preferences some people split it into 50
50 50 test and 50 training some people
prefer to have a larger amount for
training and a smaller amount for tests
so they can go by either 60 40 or 70 30
or some people even go with some odd
numbers like 65 35 or
63.33 and 33 which is like one third and
two thirds so there is no fixed rule
that it has to be something this ratio
has to be this you can go by your
individual preferences all right then
you may have questions around uh data
handling data manipulation or what you
call data management or preparation so
these are all some questions around that
area there is again no one answer one
single good answer to this it really
varies from situation to situation and
depending on what exactly is the problem
what kind of data it is how critical it
is what kind of data is missing and what
is the type of corruption so the whole
lot of things this is a very generic
question and therefore you need to be
little careful about responding to this
as well so probably have to illustrate
this again if you have experience in
doing this kind of work in handling data
you can illustrate with example saying
that i was on one project where i
received this kind of data these were
the columns where data was not filled or
these were the this many rows where the
data was missing that would be in fact a
perfect way to respond to this question
but if you don't have that obviously you
have to provide some good answer i think
it really depends on what exactly the
situation is and there are multiple ways
of handling the missing data or corrupt
data now let's take a few examples now
let's say you have data where some
values in some of the columns are
missing and you have pretty much half of
your data having these missing values in
terms of number of rows okay that could
be one situation another situation could
be that you have records or data missing
but
when you do some initial calculation how
many records are correct or how many
rows or observations as we call it has
this missing data let's assume it is
very minimal like 10
okay now
between these two cases how do we so
let's assume that this is not a mission
critical situation and in order to fix
this 10 percent of the data the effort
that is required is much higher and
obviously effort means also time and
money right so
it is not so mission critical and it is
okay to let's say get rid of these
records so obviously one of the easiest
ways of handling the data part or
missing data is remove those records or
remove those observations from your
analysis so that is the easiest way to
do but then the downside is as i said in
as in the first case if let's say 50
percent of your data is like that
because some column or the other is
missing so it is not like every in every
place in every row the same column is
missing but you have in maybe 10 percent
of the records column one is missing and
another 10 percent column 2 is missing
another 10 percent column 3 is missing
and so on and so forth so it adds up to
maybe half of your data set so you
cannot completely remove half of your
data set then the whole purpose is lost
okay so then how do you handle then you
need to come up with ways of filling up
this data with some meaningful value
right that is one way of handling so
when we say meaningful value what is
that meaningful let's say for a
particular column you might want to take
a mean value for that column and fill
wherever the data is missing fill up
with that mean value so that when you're
doing the calculations your analysis is
not completely way off so you have
values which are not missing first of
all so your system will work number two
these values are not so completely out
of whack that your whole analysis goes
for a task right there may be situations
where if the missing values instead of
putting mean may be a good idea to uh
fill it up with the minimum value or
with a zero so or with the maximum value
again as i said there are so many
possibilities so there is no like one
correct answer for this you need to
basically
talk around this and illustrate with
your experience as i said that would be
the best otherwise this is how you need
to handle this question okay so
then the next question can be how can
you choose a classifier based on a
training set data size so again this is
one of those questions
where you probably do not have like a
one size fits all
first of all
you
may not let's say
decide your classifier based on the
training set size maybe not the best way
to decide the type of the classifier and
even if you have to there are probably
some thumb rules which we can use but
then again every time so in my opinion
the best way to respond to this question
is you need to try out few classifiers
irrespective of the size of the data and
you need to then decide on your
particular situation which of these
classifiers are the right ones this is a
very generic issue so
you will never be able to just by if
somebody defines a problem to you and
somebody even if you if they show the
data to you or tell you what is the data
or even the size of the data i don't
think there is a way to really say that
yes this is the classifier that will
work here no that's not the right way so
you need to still
you know test it out get the data try
out a couple of classifiers and then
only you will be in a position to decide
which classifier to use you try out
multiple classifiers see which one gives
the best accuracy and only then you can
decide then you can have a question
around confusion matrix so the question
can be explained confusion matrix right
so confusion matrix i think the best way
to explain it is by taking an example
and drawing like a small diagram
otherwise it can really become tricky so
my suggestion is to take a piece of pen
and paper and
explain it by drawing a small matrix and
confusion matrix is about to find out
this is used especially in
classification learning process and when
you get the results and our model
predicts the results you compare it with
the actual value and try to find out
what is the accuracy okay so
in this case let's say this is an
example of a confusion matrix and it is
a binary matrix so you have the actual
values which is the labeled data right
and which is so you have how many yes
and how many know so you have that
efficient and you have the predicted
values how many yes and how many right
so the total actual values the total yes
is 12 plus 130 and they are shown here
and the actual value those are 9 plus 3
12 okay so that is what this information
here is so this is about the actual and
this is about the predicted similarly
the predicted values there are yes are
12 plus 3 15 yeses and no are one plus
nine 10 nos okay so this is the way to
look at this confusion matrix okay and
uh out of this what is the meaning
conveying so there are two or three
things that needs to be explained
outright the first thing is for a model
to be accurate the values across the
diagonal should be high like in this
case right that is one number two the
total sum of these values is equal to
the total observations in the test data
set so in this case for example you have
12 plus 3 15 plus 10 25 so that means we
have 25 observations in our test data
set okay so these are the two things you
need to first explain that the total sum
in this matrix the numbers is equal to
the size of the test data set and the
diagonal values indicate the accuracy so
by just by looking at it you can
probably have a idea about is this uh an
accurate model is the model being
accurate if they're all spread out
equally in all these four boxes that
means probably the accuracy is not very
good okay now how do you calculate the
accuracy itself right how do you
calculate the accuracy itself so it is a
very simple mathematical calculation you
take some of the diagonals right so in
this case it is 9 plus 12 21 and divided
by the total so in this case what will
it be let me take a pen so your your
diagonal values is equal to if i say d
is equal to 12 plus 9 so that is 21
right and the total data set is equal to
right we just calculated it is 25 so
what is your accuracy it is 21 by your
accuracy is equal to 21 by 25 and this
turns out to be about 85 percent
right so this is 85
so that is our accuracy okay so this is
the way you need to explain draw diagram
give an example and maybe it may be a
good idea to be prepared with an example
so that it becomes easy for you don't
have to calculate those numbers on the
fly right so a couple of
hints are that you take some numbers
which are with which add up to 100 that
is always a good idea so you don't have
to really do this complex calculations
so the total value will be 100 and then
diagonal values you divide once you find
the diagonal values that is equal to
your percentage okay all right so the
next question can be a related question
about
false positive and false negative so
what is false positive and what is false
negative now once again the best way to
explain this is using a piece of paper
and pen otherwise it will be pretty
difficult to explain this so we use the
same example of the confusion matrix
and
we can explain that so a confusion
matrix looks somewhat like this and
when we just yeah it looks somewhat like
this and we continue with the previous
example where this is the actual value
this is the predicted value and
in the actual value we have 12 plus 1 13
yes's and 3 plus 9 12 knows and the
predicted values there are 12 plus the
15 yes's and
1 plus 9 10 knows okay now in this
particular case which is the false
positive what is a false positive first
of all the second word which is positive
okay is referring to the predicted value
so that means the system has predicted
it as a positive but the real value so
this is what the false comes from but
the real value is not positive okay that
is the way you should understand this
term false positive or even false
negative so false positive so positive
is what your system has predicted so
where is that system predicted this is
the one positive is what yes so you
basically consider this row okay now if
you consider this row so this is this is
all positive values this entire row is
positive values okay now the false
positive is the one which where the
value actual value is negative predicted
value is positive but the actual value
is negative so this is a false positive
right and here is a true positive so the
predicted value is positive and the
actual value is also positive okay i
hope this is making sense now let's take
a look at what is false negative false
negative so negative is the second term
that means that is the predicted value
that we need to look for so which are
the predicted negative values this row
corresponds to predicted negative values
all right so this row corresponds to
predicted negative values and what they
are asking for false so this is the row
for predicted negative values and the
actual value is this one right this is
predicted negative and the actual value
is also negative therefore this is a
true negative so the false negative is
this one predicted is negative but
actual is positive right so this is the
false negative so this is the way to
explain and this is a way to look at
false positive and false negative same
way there can be true positive and true
negative as well so again positive the
second term you will need to use to
identify the predicted row right so if
we say true positive positive we need to
take for the predicted part so predicted
positive is here okay and then the first
term is for the actual so true positive
so true in case of actual is yes right
so true positive is this one okay and
then in case of actual the negative now
we are talking about let's say true
negative true negative negative is this
one and the true comes from here so this
is true negative right nine is true
negative the actual value is also
negative and the predicted value is also
negative okay so that is the way you
need to explain this the terms false
positive false negative and true
positive true negative then uh you might
have a question like what are the steps
involved in the machine learning process
or what are the three steps in the
process of developing a machine learning
model right so it is around the
methodology that is applied so basically
the way you can probably answer in your
own words but the way the model
development of the machine learning
model happens is like this so first of
all you try to understand the problem
and try to figure out whether it is a
classification problem or a regression
problem based on that you select a few
algorithms and then you start the
process of training these models okay so
you can either do that or you can after
due diligence you can probably decide
that there is one particular algorithm
which is most suitable usually it
happens through trial and error process
but at some point you will decide that
okay this is the model we are going to
use okay so in that case we have the
model algorithm and the model decided
and then you need to do the process of
training the model and testing the model
and this is where if it is supervised
learning you split your data the label
data into training data set and test
data set and you use the training data
set to train your model and then you use
the test data set to check the accuracy
whether it is working fine or not so you
test the model before you actually put
it into production right so once you
test the model you're satisfied it's
working fine then you go to the next
level which is putting it for production
and then in production obviously new
data will come and
the inference happens so the model is
readily available and only thing that
happens is new data comes and the model
predicts the values whether it is
regression or classification now so this
can be an iterative process so it is not
a straightforward process where you do
the training through the testing and
then you move it to production now so
during the training and test process
there may be a situation where because
of either overfitting or things like
that the test doesn't go through which
means that you need to put that back
into the training process so that can be
an iterative process not only that even
if the training and test goes through
properly and you deploy the model in
production there can be a situation that
the data that actually comes the real
data that comes with that this model is
failing so in which case you may have to
once again go back to the drawing board
or initially it will be working fine but
over a period of time maybe due to the
change in the nature of the data once
again the accuracy will deteriorate so
that is again a recursive process so
once in a while you need to keep
checking whether the model is working
fine or not and if required you need to
tweak it and modify it and so on and so
forth so let net this is a continuous
process of
tweaking the model and testing it and
making sure it is up to date then you
might have question around deep learning
so because deep learning is now
associated with ai artificial
intelligence and so on so can be as
simple as what is deep learning so i
think the best way to respond to this
could be deep learning is a part of
machine learning and
then obviously the question would be
then what is the difference right so
deep learning you need to mention there
are two key parts that interviewer will
be looking for when you are defining
deep learning so first is of course deep
learning is a subset of machine learning
so machine learning is still the bigger
let's say uh scope and deep learning is
one part of it so then what exactly is
the difference deep learning is
primarily when we are implementing these
our algorithms or when we are using
neural networks for doing our training
and classification and regression and
all that right so when we use neural
network then it is considered as deep
learning and the term deep comes from
the fact that you can have several
layers of neural networks and these are
called deep neural networks and
therefore the term deep deep learning
the other difference between machine
learning and deep learning which the
interviewer may be wanting to hear is
that in case of machine learning the
feature engineering is done manually
what do we mean by feature engineering
basically when we are trying to train
our model we have our training data
right so we have our training label data
and
this data has several let's say if it is
a regular table it has several columns
now each of these columns actually has
information about a feature right so if
we are trying to predict the height
weight and so on and so forth so these
are all features of human beings let's
say we have census data and we have all
this so those are the features now there
may be probably 50 or 100 in some cases
there may be 100 such features now all
of them do not contribute to our model
right so we as a data scientist we have
to decide whether we should take all of
them all the features or we should throw
away some of them because again if we
take all of them number one of course
your accuracy will probably get affected
but also there is a computational part
so if you have so many features and then
you have so much data it becomes very
tricky so in case of machine learning we
manually take care of identifying the
features that do not contribute to the
learning process and thereby we
eliminate those features and so on right
so this is known as feature engineering
and in machine learning we do that
manually whereas in deep learning where
we use neural networks the model will
automatically determine which features
to use and which to not use and
therefore feature engineering is also
done automatically so this is a
explanation these are two key things
probably will add value to your response
all right so the next question is what
is the difference between or what are
the differences between machine learning
and deep learning so here this is a
quick comparison table between machine
learning and deep learning and machine
learning learning enables machines to
take decisions on their own based on
fast data so here we are talking
primarily of supervised learning and
it needs only a small amount of data for
training and then works well on low-end
systems so you don't need large machines
and most features need to be identified
in advance and manually coded so
basically the feature engineering part
is done manually and the problem is
divided into parts and solved
individually and then combined so that
is about the machine learning part in
deep learning deep learning basically
enables machines to take decisions with
the help of artificial neural network so
here in deep learning we use neural nets
so that is the key differentiator
between machine learning and deep
learning and usually deep learning
involves a large amount of data and
therefore the training also requires
usually the training process requires
high-end machines because it needs a lot
of computing power and the machine
learning features are or the feature
engineering is done automatically so the
neural networks takes care of doing the
feature engineering as well and in case
of deep learning therefore it is said
that the problem is handled end-to-end
so this is a quick comparison between
machine learning and deep learning in
case you have that kind of a question
then you might get a question around the
uses of machine learning or some real
life applications of machine learning in
modern business the question may be
worded in different ways but the meaning
is how exactly is machine learning used
or actually supervised machine learning
it could be a very specific question
around supervised decision learning so
this is like give examples of supervised
machine learning use of supervised
machine learning in modern business so
that could be the next question so there
are quite a few examples or quite a few
use cases if you will for supervised
machine learning the very common one is
email spam detection so you want to
train your application or your system to
detect between spam and non-spam so this
is a very common business application of
supervised machine learning so how does
this work the way it works is that you
obviously have historical data above of
your emails and they are categorized as
spam and not spam so that is what is the
labeled information and then you feed
this information or the all these emails
as an input to your model right and the
model will then get trained to detect
which of the emails are to detect which
is spam and which is not spam so that is
the training process and this is
supervised machine learning because you
have label data you already have emails
which are tagged as spam or not spam and
then you use that to train your model
right so this is one example now there
are a few industry specific applications
for supervised machine learning one of
the very common ones is in healthcare
diagnostics in healthcare diagnostics
you have these images and you want to
train models to detect whether from a
particular image whether it can find out
if the person is sick or not whether a
person has cancer or not right so this
is a very good example of supervised
machine learning here the way it works
is that existing images it could be
x-ray images it'd be mri or any of these
images are available and they are tagged
saying that okay this x-ray image is
defective or the person as an illness or
it could be cancer whichever illness
right so it is tagged as uh effective or
clear or good image and defective
something like that so we come up with a
binary or it could be multi-class as
well saying that this is defective to 10
percent this is 25 and so on but let's
keep it simple you can give an example
of just a binary classification that
would be good enough so
you can say that in healthcare
diagnostics using image we need to
detect whether a person is ill or
whether a person is having cancer or not
so here the way it works is you feed
labeled images and you allow the model
to learn from that so that when new
image is fed it will be able to predict
whether this person is having that
illness or not having cancer or not
right so i think this would be a very
good example for supervised machine
learning in modern business all right
then we can have a question like so
we've been talking about supervised and
unsupervised and so there can be a
question around semi-supervised machine
learning so what is semi-supervised
machine learning now semi-supervised
learning as the name suggests it falls
between supervised learning and
unsupervised learning but for all
practical purposes it is considered as a
part of supervised learning and the
reason this has come into existence is
that in supervised learning you need
labeled data so all your data for
training your model has to be labeled
now this is a big problem in many
industries or in many under many
situations getting the label data is not
that easy because there's a lot of
effort in labeling this data let's take
an example of
diagnostic images we can just let's say
take x-ray images now there are actually
millions of x-ray images available all
over the world but the problem is they
are not labeled so their images are
there but whether it is effective or
whether it is good and information is
not available along with it right in a
form that it can be used by a machine
which means that somebody has to take a
look at these images and usually it
should be like a doctor and
then say that okay yes this image is
clean and this image is cancerous and so
on and so forth now that is a huge
effort by itself so this is where
semi-supervised learning comes into play
so what happens is there is a large
amount of data maybe a part of it is
labeled then we try some techniques to
label the remaining part of the data so
that we get completely labeled data and
then we train our model so i know this
is a little long winding explanation but
unfortunately there is no quick and easy
definition for semi-supervised machine
learning this is the only way probably
to explain this concept
we may have another question as
what are unsupervised machine learning
techniques or what are some of the
techniques used for performing
unsupervised machine learning so it can
be worded in different ways so how do we
answer this question so unsupervised
learning you can say that there are two
types clustering and association and
clustering is a technique where similar
objects are put together and there are
different ways of finding similar
objects so their characteristics can be
measured and if they have in most of the
characteristics if they are similar then
they can be put together this is
clustering then association you can i
think the best way to explain
association is with an example in case
of association you try to find out how
the items are linked to each other so
for example if somebody bought a maybe a
laptop the person has also purchased a
mouse so this is more in an ecommerce
scenario for example so you can give
this as an example so people who are
buying laptops are also buying the mouse
so that means there is an association
between laptops and mouse or maybe
people who are buying bread are also
buying butter so that is a association
that can be created so this is
unsupervised learning one of the
techniques okay all right then we have
very fundamental question what is the
difference between supervised and
unsupervised machine learning so
machine learning these are the two main
types of machine learning supervised and
unscienced and in case of supervised and
again here probably the keyword that the
person may be wanting to hear is labeled
data very often people say we have
historical data and if we run it it is
supervised and if we don't have
historical data yes but you may have
historical data but if it is not labeled
then you cannot use it for supervised
learning so it is it's very key to
understand that we put in that keyword
label okay so when we have labeled data
for training our model then we can use
supervised learning and if we do not
have label data then we use unsupervised
learning and there are different
algorithms available to perform both of
these types of trainings so
there can be another question a little
bit more theoretical and conceptual in
nature this is about inductive machine
learning and
deductive machine learning so the
question can be what is the difference
between inductive machine learning and
deductive machine learning or
somewhat in that manner so that the
exact phrase or exact question can vary
they can ask for examples and things
like that but that could be the question
so let's first understand what is
inductive and deductive training
inductive training is induced by
somebody and you can illustrate that
with a small example i think that always
helps so whenever you're doing some
explanation try as much as possible as i
said to give examples from your work
experience or give some analogies and
that will also help a lot in explaining
as well and for the interviewer also to
understand so here we'll take an example
or rather we will use an analogy so
inductive training is when we induce
some knowledge or the learning process
into a person without the person
actually experiencing it okay what can
be an example so we can probably tell
the person or show a person a video that
fire can burn the thing burn his finger
or fire can cause damage so what is
happening here this person has never
probably seen a fire or never seen
anything getting damaged by fire but
just because he has seen this video he
knows that okay fire is dangerous and if
a fire can cause damage
right so this is inductive learning
compared to that what is deductive
learning so here you draw conclusion or
the person draws conclusion out of
experience so we will stick to the
analogy so compared to the showing a
video let's assume a person is allowed
to play with fire right and then he
figures out that if he puts his finger
it's burning or if throw something into
the fire it burns so he is learning
through experience so this is known as
deductive learning okay so you can have
applications or models that can be
trained using inductive learning or
deductive learning all right i think
probably that explanation will be
sufficient
the next question is are knn and
k n stands for k nearest neighbors and k
means of course is the clustering
mechanism now these two are completely
different except for the letter k being
common between them k n is completely
different k means clustering is
completely different k nnn is a
classification process and
therefore it comes under supervised
learning whereas k means clustering is
actually
unsupervised okay when you have k n when
you want to implement k n which is
basically k nearest neighbors the value
of k is a number so you can say k is
equal to 3 you want to implement k n
with k is equal to 3 so which means that
it performs the classification
in such a way that how does it perform
the classification so it will take three
nearest objects and that's why it's
called nearest neighbor so basically uh
based on the distance it will try to
find out its nearest objects that are
let's say three of the nearest objects
and then it will check whether the class
they belong to which class right so if
all three belong to one particular class
obviously this new object is also
classified as that particular class but
it is possible that they may be from two
or three different classes okay so let's
say they are from two classes and then
if they are from two classes now usually
you take a odd number you assign odd
number two so if there are three of them
and two of them belong to one class and
then one belongs to another class so
this new object is assigned to the class
to which the two of them belong now the
value of k is sometimes tricky whether
should you use three should you use five
should you use seven that can be tricky
because the ultimate classification can
also vary so it's possible that if
you're taking k as three the object is
probably in one particular class but if
you take k is equal to five maybe the
object will belong to a different class
because when you are taking three of
them probably two of them belong to a
class one and one belong to class two
whereas when you take five of them it is
possible that only two of them belong to
class one and three of them belong to
class two so which means that this
object will belong to class two right so
you see that so it is the class
allocation can vary depending on the
value of k now k means on the other hand
is a clustering process
and it is unsupervised where what it
does is the system will basically
identify how the objects are how close
the objects are with respect to some of
their features okay and but similarity
of course is the letter k and in case of
k means also we specify its value and it
could be three or five or seven there is
no technical limit as such but it can be
any number of clusters that you can
create okay so based on the value that
you provide the system will create that
many clusters of similar objects so
there is a similarity to that extent
that k is a number in both the cases but
actually these two are completely
different processes
we have what is known as naive bayes
classifier and people often get confused
thinking that naive bayes is the name of
the person who found this classifier or
who developed this classifier which is
not 100 true base is the name of the
person bay s is the name of the person
but naive is not the name of the person
right so naive is basically an english
word and that has been added here
because of the nature of this particular
classifier naive bayes classifier is a
probability based classifier and
it makes some assumptions that
presence of one feature of a class is
not related to the presence of any other
feature of maybe other classes right so
which is not a very strong or not a very
what you say accurate assumption because
these features can be related and so on
but even if we go with this assumption
this whole algorithm works very well
even with this assumption and that is
the good side of it but the term comes
from that so that is the explanation
that you can
then there can be question around
reinforcement learning it can be
paraphrased in multiple ways one could
be can you explain how a system can play
a game of chess using reinforcement
learning or it can be any game so the
best way to explain this is again to
talk a little bit about what
reinforcement learning is about and then
elaborate on that to explain the process
so first of all reinforcement learning
has an environment and an agent and the
agent is basically performing some
actions in order to achieve a certain
goal and this goals can be anything
either if it is related to game then the
goal could be that you have to score
very high score high value high number
or it could be that your number of lives
should be as high as possible don't lose
light so this could be some of them more
advanced examples could be for driving
the automotive industry self-driving
cars they actually also make use of
reinforcement learning to teach the car
how to navigate through the roads and so
on and so forth that is also another
example now how does it work so if the
system is basically there is an agent
and environment and every time the agent
takes a step or performs a task which is
taking it towards the goal the final
goal let's say to maximize the score or
to minimize the number of lives and so
on or minimize the deaths for example it
is rewarded and every time it takes a
step which goes against that code right
contrary or in the reverse direction it
is penalized okay so it is like a carrot
and a stick system now how do you use
this to create a game of chess or to
create a system to play a game of chess
now the way this works is and this could
probably go back to this alphago example
where alphago defeated a human champion
so the way it works is in reinforcement
learning the system is allowed for
example in this case we are talking
about chess so we allow the system to
first of all watch playing a game of
chess so it could be with a human being
or it could be the system itself there
are computer games of chess right so
either this new learning system has to
watch that game or watch a human being
play the game
because this is reinforcement
learning is pretty much all visual so
when you're teaching the system to play
a game the system will not actually go
behind the scenes to understand the
logic of your software of this game or
anything like that it is just visually
watching the screen and then it learns
okay so reinforcement learning to a
large extent works on that so you need
to create a mechanism whereby your model
will be able to watch somebody playing
the game and then you allow the system
also to start playing the game so it
pretty much starts from scratch okay and
as it moves forward it it's at right at
the beginning and the system really
knows nothing about the game of chess
okay so initially it is a clean slate it
just starts by observing how you're
playing so it will make some random
moves and keep losing badly but then
what happens is over a period of time so
you need to now
allow the system or you need to play
with the system not just one two three
four or five times but hundreds of times
thousands of times maybe even hundreds
of thousands of times and that's exactly
how alphago has done it played millions
of games between itself and the system
right so for the game of chess also you
need to do something like that you need
to allow the system to pitch us and then
learn on its own over a period of
repetitions so i think you can probably
explain it to this much to this extent
and it should be
sufficient
now this is another question which is
again somewhat similar but here the size
is not coming into picture so the
question is how will you know which
machine learning algorithm to choose for
your classification problem now this is
not only classification problem it could
be a regression problem i would like to
generalize this question so if somebody
asks you how will you choose how will
you know which algorithm to use the
simple answer is there is no way you can
decide exactly saying that this is the
algorithm i am going to use in a variety
of situations there are some guidelines
like for example you will obviously
depending on the problem you can say
whether it is a classification problem
or a regression problem and then in that
sense you are kind of restricting
yourself to if it is a classification
problem there are you can only apply a
classification algorithm right to that
extent you can probably let's say limit
the number of algorithms but now within
the classification algorithms you have
decision trees you have svm you have
logistic regression is it possible to
outright say yes for this particular
problem since you have explained this
now this is the exact algorithm that you
can use that is not possible okay so we
have to try out a bunch of algorithms
see which one gives us the best
performance best accuracy and then
decide to go with that particular
algorithm so in machine learning a lot
of it happens through trial and error
there is no real possibility that
anybody can just by looking at the
problem or understanding the problem
tell you that okay in this particular
situation this is exactly the algorithm
that you should use then the questions
may be around application of machine
learning and this question is
specifically around how amazon is able
to recommend other things to buy so this
is around recommendation engine how does
it work how does the recommendation
engine work so this is basically the
question is all about so the
recommendation engine again works based
on various inputs that are provided
obviously something like uh you know
amazon a website or e-commerce site like
amazon collects a lot of data around the
customer behavior who is purchasing what
and if somebody is buying a particular
thing they are also buying something
else so this kind of association right
so this is the unsupervised learning we
talked about they use this to associate
and link or relate items and that is one
part of it so they kind of build
association between items saying that
somebody buying this is also buying this
that is one part of it then they also
profile the users right based on their
age their gender their geographic
location they will do some profiling and
then when somebody is logging in and
when somebody is shopping kind of the
mapping of these two things are done
they try to identify obviously if you
have logged in then they know who you
are and your information is available
like for example your age may be your
agenda and where you're located what you
purchased earlier right so all this is
taken and the recommendation engine
basically uses all this information and
comes up with recommendations for a
particular user so that is how the
recommendation engine works all right
then the question can be uh something
very basic like when will you go for
classification versus regression right
when do you do classification instead of
regression or when will you use
classification instead of regression now
yes so so this is basically going back
to the understanding of the basics of
classification and regression so
classification is used when you have to
identify or categorize things into
discrete classes so the best way to
respond to this question is to take up
some examples and use it otherwise it
can become a little tricky the question
may sound very simple but explaining it
can sometimes be very tricky in case of
regression we use of course there will
be some keywords that they will be
looking for so just you need to make
sure you use those keywords one is the
discrete values and other is the
continuous values so for regression if
you are trying to find some continuous
values you use regression whereas if
you're trying to find some discrete
values you use classification and then
you need to illustrate what are some of
the examples so classification is like
let's say there are images and you need
to put them into
classes like cat dog elephant tiger
something like that so that is a
classification a problem or it can be
that is a multi-class classification a
problem it could be binary
classification problem like for example
whether a customer will buy or he will
not buy that is a classification binary
classification it can be in the weather
forecast area now weather forecast is
again combination of regression and
classification because on the one hand
you want to predict whether it's going
to rain or not that's a classification
problem that's a binary classification
right whether it's going to rain or not
rain however you also have to predict
what is going to be the temperature
tomorrow right now temperature is a
continuous value you can't answer the
temperature in a yes or no kind of a
response right so what will be the
temperature tomorrow so you need to give
a number which can be like 20 degrees 30
degrees or whatever right so that is
where you use regression one more
example is stock price prediction so
that is where again you will use
regression so these are the various
examples so you need to illustrate with
examples and make sure you include those
keywords like discrete and continuous so
the next question is more about a little
bit of a design related question to
understand your concepts and things like
that so it is how will you design a spam
filter so how do you basically design or
develop a spam filter so i think the
main thing here is he is looking at
probably understanding your concepts in
terms of what is the algorithm you will
use or what is your understanding about
difference between classification and
regression
and things like that right and the
process of course the methodology and
the process so the best way to go about
responding to this is we say that okay
this is a classification problem because
we want to find out whether an email is
a spam or not spam so that we can apply
the filter accordingly so first thing is
to identify what type of a problem it is
so we have identified that it is a
classification then the second step may
be to find out what kind of algorithm to
use now since this is a binary
classification problem logistic
regression is a very common very common
algorithm but however right as i said
earlier also we can never say that okay
for this particular problem this is
exactly the algorithm that we can use so
we can also probably try decision trees
or even support vector machines for
example svm so we will kind of list down
a few of these algorithms and we will
say okay we want to we would like to try
out these algorithms and then we go
about taking your historical data which
is the labeled data which are marked so
you will have a bunch of emails and then
you split that into training and test
data sets you use your training data set
to train your model that or your
algorithm that you have used or rather
the model actually
so
and you actually will have three models
let's say you are trying to test out
three algorithms so you will obviously
have three models so you need to try all
three models and test them out as well
see which one gives the best accuracy
and then you decide that you will go
with that model okay so training and
test will be done and then you zero in
on one particular model and then you say
okay this is the model will you use we
will use and then go ahead and implement
that or put that in production so that
is the way you design a spam file the
next question is about random foreign so
what is random foreign so this is a very
straightforward question however the
response you need to be again a little
careful while we all know what is random
forest explaining this can sometimes be
tricky so one thing is random forest is
kind of in one way it is an extension
of decision trees because it is
basically nothing but you have multiple
decision trees and
trees will basically you will use for
doing if it is classification mostly it
is classification you will use the trees
for classification and then you use
voting for finding that the final class
so that is the underlyings but how will
you explain this how will you respond to
this so first thing obviously we will
say that random forest is one of the
algorithms and the more important thing
that you need to probably the
interviewer is waiting to hear is
ensemble learner right so this is one
type of ensemble learner what is
ensemble learner ensemble learner is
like a combination of algorithms so it
is a learner which consists of more than
one algorithm or more than one maybe
models okay so in case of random forest
the algorithm is the same but instead of
using one instance of it we use multiple
instances of it and we use so in a way
that is a random forest is an ensemble
there are other types of ensemble
learners where we have like we use
different algorithms itself so you have
one maybe logistic regression and a
decision tree combined together and so
on and so forth or there are other ways
like for example splitting the data in a
certain way and so on so that's all
about ensembl we will not go into that
but random foreign i think the
interviewer will be happy to hear this
word ensemble learners and so then you
go and explain how the random forest
works so if the random forest is used
for classification then we use what is
known as a voting mechanism so basically
how does it work let's say your random
forest consists of 100 trees okay and
each observation you pass through this
forest and each observation let's say it
is a classification problem binary
classification 0 or 1 and you have 100
trees now if 90 trees say that it is a 0
and 10 of the trees say it is a one you
take the majority you may take a vote
and since 90 of them are saying zero you
classify this as zero then you take the
next observation and so on so that is
the way uh random forest works for
classification if it is a regression
problem it's somewhat similar but only
thing is instead of vote what we will do
is sorry in regression remember what
happens you actually calculate a value
right so for example you are using
regression to predict the temperature
and you have 100 trees and each tree
obviously will probably predict a
different value of the temperature they
may be close to each other but they may
not be exactly the same value so these
100 trees so how do you now find the
actual value the output for the entire
forest right so you have outputs of
individual trees which are a part of
this forest but then you need to find
the final output of the forest itself so
how do you do that so in case of
regression you take like an average or
the mean of all the 100 crease right so
this is also a way of reducing the error
so maybe if you have only one tree and
if that one tree makes a error it is
basically 100
wrong or 100 right right but if you have
on the other hand if you have a bunch of
trees you are basically mitigating that
reducing that error okay so that is the
way random forest works so the next
question is considering the long list of
machine learning algorithms how will you
decide on which one to use so once again
here there is no way to outright say
that this is the algorithm that we will
use for a given data set this is a very
good question but then the response has
to be like again there will not be a one
size fits all so
we need to first of all you can probably
shorten the list in terms of by saying
okay whether it is a classification
problem or it is a regression problem to
that extent you can probably
shorten the list because you don't have
to use all of them if it is a
classification problem you only can pick
from the classification algorithms right
so for example if it's a classification
you cannot use linear regression
algorithm or if it is a regression
problem you cannot use svm or maybe now
you can use svm but maybe a logistic
regression right so to that extent you
can probably shorten the list but still
you will not be able to 100
decide on saying that this is the exact
algorithm that i am going to use so the
way to go about is you choose a few
algorithms based on what the problem is
you try out your data you train some
models of these algorithms check which
one gives you the lowest error or the
highest accuracy and based on that you
choose that particular algorithm okay
all right then they can be questions
around bias and variance so the question
can be what is bias and variance in
machine learning so you just need to
give out a definition for each of these
for example a bias in machine learning
it occurs when the predicted values are
far away from the actual value so that
is a bias okay and whereas they are all
all the values are probably they are far
off but they are very near to each other
though the predicted values are close to
each other right while they are far off
from the actual value but they are close
to each other you see the difference so
that is bias and then the other part is
your variance now variance is when the
predicted values are all over the place
right so the variance is high that means
it may be close to the target but it is
kind of very scattered so the point the
predicted values are not close to each
other right in case of bias the
predicted values are close to each other
but they are not close to the target but
here they may be close to the target but
they may not be close to each other so
they are a little bit more scattered so
that is what in case of a variance okay
then the next question is about again
related to bias and variance what is the
trade-off between bias and variance yes
i think this is a interesting question
because these two are
heading in different directions so for
example if you try to minimize the bias
variance will keep going high and if you
try to minimize the variance bias will
keep going high and there is no way you
can minimize both of them so you need to
have a trade-off saying that okay this
is the level at which i will have my
bias and this is the level at which i
will have variance so the trade-off is
that pretty much attack you you decide
what is the level you will tolerate for
your bias and what is the level you will
tolerate for variance and a combination
of these two in such a way that your
final results are not way off and having
a trade-off will ensure that the results
are consistent right so that is
basically the output is consistent and
which means that they are close to each
other and they are also accurate that
means they are as close to the target as
possible right so if either of these is
high then one of them will go off the
track define precision and recall now
again here i think it would be best to
draw a diagram and take the confusion
matrix and it is very simple the
definition is like a formula your
precision is true positive by true
positive plus false positive and your
recall is true positive by true positive
plus false negative okay so that's you
can just show it in a mathematical way
that's pretty much uh you know that can
be shown that's the easiest way to
define so the next question can be about
decision tree what is decision tree
pruning and why is it so
basically decision trees are really
simple to implement and understand but
one of the drawbacks of decision trees
is that it can become highly complicated
as it grows right and the rules and the
conditions can become very complicated
and this can also lead to overfitting
which is basically that during training
you will get 100 accuracy but when you
are doing testing you will get a lot of
errors so that is the reason pruning
needs to be done so the purpose or the
reason for doing
decision tree pruning is to reduce
overfitting or to cut down on
overfitting and what is decision tree
pruning it is basically that you reduce
the number of branches because as you
may be aware a tree consists of the root
node and then there are several internal
nodes and then you have the leaf nodes
now if there are too many of these
internal nodes that is when you face the
problem of overfitting and pruning is
the process of reducing those internal
nodes all right so the next question can
be what is logistic regression uh so
basically logistic regression is
one of the techniques used for
performing classification especially
binary classification now there is
something special about logistic
regression and there are a couple of
things you need to be careful about
first of all the name is a little
confusing it is called logistic
regression but it is used for
classification so this can be sometimes
confusing so you need to probably
clarify that to the interviewer if it's
really you know if it is required and
they can also ask this like a trick
question right so that is one part
second thing is the term logistic has
nothing to do with the usual logistics
that we talk about but it is derived
from log so that the mathematical
derivation involves log and therefore
the name logistic regression so what is
logistic regression and how is it used
so logistic regression is used for
binary classification and the output of
a logistic regression is either a zero
or a one and it varies so it's basically
it calculates a probability between zero
and one and we can set a threshold that
can vary typically it is 0.5 so any
value above 0.5 is considered as 1 and
if the probability is below 0.5 it is
considered as 0. so that is the way we
calculate the probability or the system
calculates a probability and based on
the threshold it sets a value of zero or
one which is like a binary
classification zero or one okay then we
have a question around k nearest
neighbor algorithm so explain k nearest
neighbor algorithm so first of all what
is a k nearest neighbor algorithm this
is a classification algorithm so that is
the first thing we need to mention and
we also need to mention that the k is a
number it is an integer and this is
variable and we can define what the
value of k should be it can be 2 3 5 7
and usually it is an odd number so that
is something we need to mention
technically it can be even number also
but then typically it would be odd
number and we will see why that is okay
so based on that we need to classify
objects okay we need to classify objects
so again it will be very helpful to draw
a diagram you know if you're explaining
i think that will be the best way so
draw some diagram like this and let's
say we have three clusters or three
classes existing and now you want to
find for a new item that has come you
want to find out which class this
belongs to right so you go about as the
name suggests it you go about finding
the nearest neighbors right the points
which are closest to this and how many
of them you will find that is what is
defined by k now let's say our initial
value of k was five
so you will find the k the five nearest
data points so in this case as it is
illustrated these are the five nearest
data points but then all five do not
belong to the same class or cluster so
there are one belonging to this cluster
one the second one belonging to this
cluster two three of them belonging to
this third cluster okay so how do you
decide that's exactly the reason we
should as much as possible try to assign
an odd number so that it becomes easier
to assign this so in this case you see
that the majority actually if there are
multiple classes then you go with the
majority so since three of these items
belong to this class we assign which is
basically the in in this case the green
or the tennis or the third cluster as i
was talking about right so we assign it
to this third class so in this case it
is uh that's how it is decided okay so k
nearest neighbor so first thing is to
identify the number of neighbors that
are mentioned as k so in this case it is
k is equal to five so we find the five
nearest points and then find out out of
these five which class has the maximum
number in that and and then the
new data point is assigned to that class
okay so that's pretty much how k nearest
neighbors work welcome to this video on
machine learning roadmap 2021.
ai and machine learning have been the
top burst words in 2020. machine
learning can be an interesting career
move for programmers developers and
other professionals looking for a script
in their career
over the last few years machine learning
and artificial intelligence together
have become a crucial component in many
of the world's most popular business
applications
as we approach 2021 it's a good time for
us to take a look at the machine
learning roadmap for 2021.
in this video
we will discuss the basics of machine
learning and the company is actively
hiring for machine learning roles you
will understand the skills required to
become a machine learning expert in 2021
the salary of a machine learning
engineer and how simply learn can help
you get certified in machine learning
now let's look at what machine learning
is machine learning is an application of
artificial intelligence that allows
systems to learn from vast volumes of
data
it enables you to process analyze and
train machines using data and create
models to solve business problems
machine learning has the potential to
learn from structured semi-structured
and unstructured data
there are various supervised
unsupervised and reinforcement learning
algorithms used to build machine
learning models
some of the most popular machine
learning algorithms are linear
regression logistic regression support
vector machines k nearest neighbors k
means clustering knife base and others
now some of the top companies hiring for
machine learning roles are microsoft
spotify google cell
erection oracle and walmart
there are numerous product based service
based as well as startup companies that
are hiring for machine learning
positions now learning machine learning
can position an individual for a variety
of exciting careers in a growing number
of industries
with machine learning becoming more
widely accepted and adapted technology
let's look at the important skills you
need to know to become a machine
learning expert in 2021
first we have programming machine
learning mostly depends on algorithms
which means one should possess sound
knowledge of different programming
languages such as python and r
you should have knowledge of basic
programming concepts and understand data
structures this will help you write
better and efficient codes you should
also know about searching sorting and
optimization algorithms the second skill
you need to know is mathematics and
statistics
statistics is the backbone of data
analytics you should have knowledge of
various measures such as mean median
variance etc distributions such as
uniform normal binomial poison etc and
analysis methods such as anova manova
t-test chi-square test hypothesis
testing and others
now this is required for building and
validating models from observed data a
basic understanding of high school
mathematics will help you understand how
machine learning algorithms work
the topics include probability linear
algebra and calculus the third skill you
need to know is database and sql
very often machine learning tasks are
carried out using data stored in the
form of tables that are present in
database servers
so it's important to know about
databases and sql good understanding of
relational databases and nosql databases
such as mysql postgresql oracle database
microsoft sql server is vital to store
manipulate retrieve and handle
structured data now we have data
wrangling
now there's a lot of pre-processing of
data that is needed before you start
building your machine learning model
collecting the data cleaning it
identifying the problems asking the
right questions and formatting the data
are crucial steps in machine learning
you should have knowledge of libraries
and packages such as numpy pandas plier
deep flyer and tidier to perform data
wrangling next we have data
visualization while working on any
machine learning problem it's important
to understand the data well
data visualization and exploratory data
analysis skills are very important to
show the hidden trends and insights in a
visual form using various charts and
graphs this will help you find out
unseen patterns in the data
you need to have experience with
matplotlib c-bond plotly and ggplot
libraries it would be an advantage to
know bi tools such as tableau and power
bi finally
the most important skill is machine
learning itself
you need to learn different machine
learning techniques and algorithms that
are widely used to solve business
problems
then implement the algorithms using
python and r libraries such as
scikit-learn tensorflow garrett and mlr
having knowledge of natural language
processing computer vision and time
series analysis would be a really good
advantage
to gain more experience in solving real
world problems you need to work on small
projects using variety of data sets
data science and machine learning
challenges such as those on github and
kegel are a great way to get exposed to
different kinds of problems and their
nuances now talking about the salary of
a machine learning engineer
according to glassdoor in the united
states a machine learning engineer can
earn around 114 000 dollars per annum
while in india you can earn nearly 7
lakh 73 000 rupees per annum
this salary may vary based on your
experience the industry you are applying
for and the company policy now moving on
to the final section
let me tell you how simply learn can
help you start your career in machine
learning
so let me take you to our website first
okay so i am on the chrome browser
let me search for simplylearn.com
and here
under what you want to learn let me type
machine learning it will show me the
relevant courses that simply learn
offers
in the machine learning category
so you can see here there are multiple
courses
first let me open the
first link
and let's open the second link as well
so
so this is the post graduate program in
ai and machine learning which is in
collaboration with purdue university and
ibm
if i scroll down
you can see the key features of this
course
so we'll get purdue alumni association
membership
industry recognized ibm certificates
enrollment to simply launch job assist
there's 25 plus hands-on projects on gpu
enabled labs you have
450 plus hours of applied learning
caption projects in three domains
and much more
and here you can see on the right this
is the certificate that you will get
after completing this
and you will also get
certificates recognized by ibm
and another key feature of this course
is you can enroll to simply learn job
assist program so you will get im jobs
crew membership for 6 months resume
assistance and career monitoring there's
interview preparation and career affairs
if i scroll further here you can see the
learning path
and you will learn about python for data
science
this machine learning
deep learning with tensorflow and carers
that's advanced deep learning and
computer vision you will also learn
about natural language processing that
is nlp and speech recognition
we have reinforcement learning
and you also have the opportunity to
select a few electives so we have ibm
watson for chatbots machine learning
with r there's git and github training
and two others
here you can see
the skills that will be covered so you
will learn about statistics which is a
core component of machine learning
we learn about python supervised
learning there's dance computer vision
tensorflow
there's reinforcement learning speech
recognition you will also learn about
numpy pandas and other libraries
and here you can see these are some of
the tools that will be covered in this
course
if i scroll further now this is the
important section you can see the
industry projects that you will get to
work on
so this is
on twitter this one on zumato one on
uber and mercedes-benz as well
now they are our course advisors
so please go ahead and enroll to this
postgraduate program in ai machine
learning if you want to kick-start your
career in
machine
learning now the next course we have is
machine learning certification course
if i scroll down you can see the details
of this course
so you will gain expertise with 25 plus
hands-on exercises you will get to work
on four real-life industry based
projects with integrated labs there will
be dedicated mentoring sessions from
industry experts 44 hours of instructor
led training with certification
here on the right you can see the skills
that will be covered
so we learn about time series modeling
linear and logistic regression you will
also learn about support vector machines
games clustering knife pace decision
trees
random forest
and you learn the concepts of bagging
and boosting and deep learning
fundamentals as well
here you can see the
course content
and if i scroll further now these are
the projects that you'll get to work on
and finally you will receive this
certificate once you complete the course
so that brings us to the end of this
video on machine learning full course i
hope it was useful and interesting if
you enjoyed the video then please
subscribe to the simply learn channel
thank you for watching and keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
you